TO THE APRIL TWENTY SECOND
MEETING OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE -- JUST DULL.
WE IN APPS IN THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WE'RE GONNA BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE HOME WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL ESTABLISH.
A QUORUM AND BEGIN TO VOTE ON
THE BILLS I WANT TO ANNOUNCE
THAT THE FOLLOWING BILLS BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S HEARING.
ITEM FOR AB TWO EIGHTY ONE AND
ITEM SEVEN AB.
FOR NINETY THE HEARING IS
TELEVISED ON CHANNEL TWENTY TWO
AND CAL CHANNEL DOT COM.
THE FIRST UP WE HAVE.
MISTER MAYOR SU CHI.
WITH.
WAS AB THREE FORTY FIVE MISTER
MURATSUCHI WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE COMBINATION TO
BE ABLE -- TO PROCEED
[inaudible]
FIRST.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE FOUR FIVE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BILL.
THAT WILL PROTECT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
MOSTLY LIVING AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
FROM THE HARMFUL HEALTH EFFECTS
OF OIL DRILLING NEAR HOMES
SCHOOLS AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE ANY NEW
OIL DRILLING TO BE CONDUCTED AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FEET.
FROM A RESIDENTS SCHOOL CHILD
CARE FACILITY PLAYGROUND
HOSPITAL FOR HEALTH CLINIC.
BUT FIRST LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS OF THE BILL
BEFORE YOU.
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA LIVE WITHIN TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED FEET.
OF AT LEAST ONE OIL OR GAS WELL.
NUMEROUS STUDIES LINCOLN
PROXIMITY TO OIL AND GAS WELLS
TO A HOST OF NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS.
INCLUDING INCREASED RISK OF
ASTHMA AND OTHER RESPIRATORY
ILLNESSES.
PRETERM BIRTHS.
CONGENITAL HEART DEFECTS.
HIGH RISK PREGNANCIES.
AN INCREASED RISK OF CANCER.
OIL AND GAS EXTRACTION PRODUCES
AIR TOXINS INCLUDING BONTA
ORGANIC COMPOUND COMPOUNDS LIKE
BENZENE AND FORMALDEHYDE.
FIND AN ULTRA FINE PARTICULATE
MATTER.
IN HYDROGEN SULFIDE AMONG OTHERS.
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
RISKS INCLUDE WATER
CONTAMINATION.
TOXIC CHEMICAL SPILLS AND
EXPLOSIONS.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AS A RESULT OF
SENATE BILL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY.
ISSUED A REPORT REGARDING THE
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION.
THIS STUDY RECOMMENDED A HEALTH
AND SAFETY BUFFER ZONE BETWEEN
SENSITIVE LAND USES.
AND OIL AND GAS WELLS IN ORDER
TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES WHERE
NEIGHBORHOOD DRILLING A CURSE.
DESPITE THIS RECOMMENDATION.
AND THE ABUNDANCE OF EVIDENCE
LINKING THE PROXIMITY OF OIL
DRILLING. TOO SENSITIVE
COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY DOES
NOT PROHIBIT OIL AND GAS
OPERATORS FROM PLACING WELLS.
NEAR SENSITIVE AREAS LIKE
SCHOOLS DAYCARES RESIDENTIAL
HOMES AND HOSPITALS.
THIS HEALTH PROTECTION ZONE
PROPOSED IN AB THREE FOUR FIVE
WILL CREATE.
THE BUFFER ZONE THAT WAS
RECOMMENDED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY.
TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
AND TO HELP REDUCE THE SERIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY RISKS
AND IMPACTS.
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY I'D LIKE TO
FIRST INTRODUCE ON A BILL
MARKETS.
A COMMUNITY MEMBER FROM SHAFTER
WHO WILL BE A HALF HER TESTIMONY
TRANSLATED BY.
A MISTER WONDERFUL FLORIDA'S.
WHAT IS THAT THIS?
WHEN I STARTED AND BECAUSE OF
THE -- WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS GIVE?
ON EACH SIDE TEN MINUTES AND YOU
CAN DIVIDE IT UP HOWEVER YOU
LIKE BUT WE WILL BE KEEPING TIME
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A FEW EXTRA
MINUTES FOR THE TRANSLATION.
THANK YOU.
WITH A SERVICE -- GIVEN GOING TO
PRESENT ON THE ON THE LAKERS.
ECONOMICAL COMMITTEES BUT
PHYSICALLY THAT IS GETTING A
COMPANION SEEN SEEN WHAT THE
WELL THEY LOOK GROVE ANIMALS --
A REPRESENT THAT ANOTHER MUST IS
THE PROPUESTAS DISCORDANT A
SINGLE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I COME FROM A
CHAPTER IN THE COUNTY OF KERN
TOGETHER WITH COMMUNITY MEMBERS
SUCH TROUBLE THIS MORNING WITH
ME.
OUR WORK HERE ON A VOLUNTARY
BASIS.
RACE IN OUR VOICES -- PORTICO
OVER COMMUNITIES.
ANONYMOUS BUT WHAT WHAT WE NEED
A KEY WHEN IT WAS ONE OF THE
IDEAS.
WHAT?
IN A CIRCLE WITH THE OTHERS WILL
DOUBLE MUST MUST PERSONA SCHOOL
GUNS.
IS DONE WORK ON THOSE IN NEED OF
SOME THE AND WORK AND NOT A YOU
KNOW SEAT OF ANY ALLOW ONE
UNITED YOU LET THE OTHER.
IN ORDER COMMUNITY WE HAVE SEEN
MANY CASES OF OF CANCERS
INCLUDING CANCER IN CHILDREN.
BECAUSE OUR QUALITY OR WATER
QUALITY AND OUR SOIL ARE NOT A
GOOD FOR US ANYMORE THERE'S OVER
POLLUTED.
BUT FIVE ORDER THAT IT WAS
BECAUSE IT WAS IS BOUTIQUE IS A
COME OUT THIS YEAR ON SOME OF
SAY THIS WOMAN WITH.
IT A MILLION OP OR FAMILY SIZE
TENNESSEE ON PLEASE LISTEN TO US
AND HAVE CONSIDERATION FOR US
WE'RE HUMAN BEINGS.
IN WE ARE ASAL ARE CONTRIBUTING
TO NOT ONLY OUR STATE BUT OUR
COUNTRY IN WERE DYING BECAUSE OF
A POOR ENVIRONMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
YES YES PERSONAL THINGS HERE.
THANK YOU FOR ATTENTION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
BOB NOT SHAMUS UNDER I'M AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR IN THE URBAN
AND ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
DEPARTMENT.
AT OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE IN LOS
ANGELES AND I EXAMINE I'M HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES FOR COMMUNITIES
LIVING NEARBY ACTIVE OIL
DEVELOPMENT.
AND IN PART OF A LARGER AND I H.
FUNDED STUDY IN LA.
MY GOAL HERE IS TO PROVIDE YOU --
THE DIRECTION OF THE EVIDENCE ON
OIL AND GAS OPERATION RELATED
EXPOSURE AND HUMAN HEALTH
IMPACTS THIS IS A REALLY LARGE
LITERATURE BUT I BROUGHT WITH ME
TO RESEND SCHOLARLY REVIEW
ARTICLES TO GIVE YOU AND I
REALLY URGE YOU.
TO LOOK AT THEM -- A SINGLE
DRILL OPERATION CAN LAST FOR
DECADES AND THE EXTRACTION
PROCESS PRODUCES MULTIPLE
EMISSIONS OF HEALTH HAZARDOUS
AIR POLLUTANTS SUCH AS BENZENE.
TALL YOU MEAN AT THE BENZENE
XYLENE FORMALDEHYDE HYDROGEN
SULFIDE PARTICULATE MATTER.
NITROUS OXIDES AND METHYLENE
CHLORIDE.
TOXIC MET METALS HAVE BEEN
MEASURED IN SOIL AND WATER HERE
THESE OPERATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
EXTRACTION AND DEVELOPMENT
OPERATIONS HAVE EXPANDED CLOSER.
AND CLOSER TO RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES WHICH INCREASES THE
OVERALL RISK OF EXPOSURE. TO AIR
WATER NOISE SOIL AND LIGHT
POLLUTION.
MANY OF THESE COMPOUNDS ARE
KNOWN TO BE TOXIC TO HUMAN
HEALTH CARCINOGENIC CAUSE
RESPIRATORY HARM.
OR OUR ENDOCRINE DISRUPTING
CHEMICALS MEETING THE ALTER THE
BODY'S HORMONE SYSTEM AT VERY
LOW LEVELS OF EXPOSURE WHICH
CAUSES LONG TERM DEVELOPMENTAL
OR REPRODUCTIVE HARM.
WHICH IS A CONSIDERABLE
CONSIDERATION FOR HEALTH ACROSS
GENERATIONS.
THERE'S A GROWING BODY OF
RESEARCH TO SPEAK TO THE POINT
HERE TODAY THAT LOOKS AT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PROXIMITY
OF THESE FACILITIES AND HUMAN
HEALTH.
MOST OF THESE DISTANCES FURTHER
AWAY THAN ARE BEING CONSIDERED
TODAY.
THE BASIC FINDING FROM THIS
GROUP OF STUDIES IS THAT
PROXIMITY MATTER IT'S LIVING
CLOSER TO AN OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT SITE IS WORSE FOR
YOUR HEALTH.
THEN LIVING FURTHER AWAY WITH
HIM TAX INCLUDING WORTH
PREGNANCY AND BIRTH OUTCOMES
SUCH AS LOW BIRTH WEIGHT AND
SMALL FOR GESTATIONAL AGE BABIES.
MIGRAINE HEADACHES FATIGUE AS MY
EXACERBATIONS SINUS PROBLEMS
HEADACHES SKIN PROBLEMS LOSS OF
SMELL NOSE BLEEDS KIDNEY DAMAGE.
THYROID PROBLEMS AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL STRESS.
THERE IS ALSO A HIGHER BURDEN OF
CANCER MORTALITY IN COMMUNITIES
NEARBY OIL EXTRACTION AND STRESS
INCLUDING SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
STRESS.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL AND JUSTICE
CAN MAKE HEALTH IN CONDITIONS
WORSE.
THE UPSTREAM OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY ALSO HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST RATES OF SEVERE INJURIES
FOR WORKERS IN THE COUNTRY.
THESE AREAMONG OUR COUNTRY'S
MOST DANGEROUS JOBS WITH
FIDELITY GREATS FOUR TO SEVEN
TIMES THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
THESE WORKERS ARE AT HIGH RISK
FOR BOTH DEADLY ACCIDENTS AND
TOXIC EXPOSURES AND WORKERS HAVE
BEEN MEASURED WITH HIGHER LEVELS
OF BENZENE IN THEIR BODIES.
AND A RANGE OF INJURIES BUT
FURTHER SETBACKS HAVE BEEN SHOWN
TO BE A MEANINGFUL PUBLIC HEALTH
POLICY APPROACH TO LIMIT HUMAN
HEALTH EXPOSURE TO HARMFUL
CONTAMINANTS.
THERE IS MEANINGFUL PRESIDENT
HERE WHEN THE OVERWHELMING
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE HAS POINTED
TO THE NEED FOR POLICY ACTION.
DATA ON TOBACCO LEAD AND YES A
LEAN.
EITHER GOOD EXAMPLES WHERE
POLICYMAKERS TOOK ACTION AND
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF COUNTLESS
NUMBER THE FUTURE GENERATIONS
GIVEN THE EVIDENCE.
THE AUTHOR THAN A GOOD GRIEF
FAIR VIEW ALL RIGHT SOME PEOPLE
ARE PUSHING FOR NEW STUDIES ON
EXACTLY HOW EXPOSURE HAPPENS IN
ORDER TO BELIEVE THE EVIDENCE
THAT THESE HEALTH IMPACTS EXIST.
THAT'S SOMETHING SCIENTISTS CAN
POTENTIALLY TEASE OUT BUT WE
ALREADY KNOW THESE HEALTH
IMPACTS EXIST AND I THINK
THERE'S ALREADY MORE THAN ENOUGH
EVIDENCE FOR POLICY MAKERS TO
TAKE ACTION.
SO I URGE YOU TO LOOK AT THE
EVIDENCE YOURSELF AND TAKE
PUBLIC HEALTH PROTECTIVE ACTION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LORRAINE THE ABOUT AND ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT AB
THREE FOUR FIVE THAT WILL
MANDATE A TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED FOOT.
HEALTH AND SAFETY BUFFER BETWEEN
NEW OIL AND GAS WELLS AND
SENSITIVE LAND USES WHICH
INCLUDE SCHOOLS DAY CARE CENTERS
HOMES AND HOSPITALS.
I HAVE BEEN A REGISTERED NURSE
FOR FORTY SIX YEARS THIRTY SIX
OF THOSE WHO WERE AT SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL IS A
TRAUMA NURSE.
AND DURING MY ENTIRE CAREER I
WAS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT THE PEOPLE I CARED ABOUT
WERE BREATHING.
YOU CAN LOOK FOR THREE WEEKS
WITHOUT FOOD THREE DAYS WITHOUT
WATER THREE MINUTES WITHOUT AIR
BUT IMAGINE THAT THAT AIR THAT
YOU BREATHE THE TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND TIMES EVERYDAY.
IS DIRTY I AM NOW VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THE PEOPLE I CARE
ABOUT OUR BRIEFING AIR POLLUTION
EFFECTS CALIFORNIANS. THREE
WHERE BUT IT AFFECTS SOME MORE
THAN OTHERS.
THERE AT OUR AS MENTIONED A HOST
OF PEER REVIEWED STUDIES THAT
LINK CLOSE SINCE THE OIL AND GAS
WELLS. TO SERIOUS HEALTH
PROBLEMS FOR THE ELDERLY THE
CHILDREN AND PREGNANT WOMEN
ESPECIALLY.
HYDROGEN SULFIDE IS ALL LONG
IRRITANT AND AN ASTHMA TRIGGER
THALIA WAYNE IS A POTENT
NEUROTOXIN BENZENE IS A KNOWN
HUMAN CARCINOGEN WE MUST HAVE
SAFE DISTANCE BETWEEN.
OPERATIONS OF OIL AND GAS AND
OUR HOMES OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
HOSPITALS.
JUST THINK OF THE COST OF ONE
THOUSAND ONE MILLION.
POINT NOT ONE POINT NINE MILLION
SCHOOL DAYS LOST EVERY YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA -- TO SCHOOL CHILDREN
DUE TO ASTHMA ALONE.
AB THREE FOUR FIVE IS BUT A
SMALL STEP IN CONFRONTING A
SERIOUS.
SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE AIR
POLLUTION. FIVE AND A HALF
MILLION CALIFORNIANS MOSTLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR LIVE WITHIN A
MILE OF CURRENTLY OPERATING OIL
AND GAS WELLS THESE PEOPLE HAVE
SUFFERED FOR DECADES.
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO CLEAN UP IN
CALIFORNIA.
TODAY I ENCOURAGE YOU TO PLEASE
STOP REPEATING THE MISTAKES OF
THE PAST PLACE SUPPORT A. B.
THREE FOUR FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW I'M GOING TO
INVITE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TO LINE UP.
AND PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO YOUR NAME ANY AFFILIATION AND
WHETHER OR NOT YOU SUPPORT THE
BILL.
WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY MORE
TESTIMONY ON THIS POINT.
THIS IS THIS IS FOR SUPPORT OF
THE BILL SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION WILL GO NEXT.
WE ARE KNOWN MY NAME IS ALLEY
SAID OF IT I WOULD SEE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEIR
ENVIRONMENT AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
FOOT SET BACK I HAD SEEN.
THE ARE IMPACTS ON THE HILL
COMMUNITY MEMBER MORE TESTIMONY
NOW JUST NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT
ALL THE THINK EARLY SAID RIVERA.
OKAY A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED WOULD
SET BACK APPROVED AND PLEASE
SUPPORT PERFECT THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M LYNETTE LAYER OF DAVIS
FROM STE.
YOUR LINE OF CLIMATE ACTION IN
SUPPORT ALSO REGISTERING SUPPORT
FOR SO CAL THREE FIFTY AND SAID
JAMES ENVIRONMENTAL TEST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M BETSY THAGGARD WITH
FOSSEL FREE CALIFORNIA ARE SEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SUPPORTERS
ASK YOU TO PLEASE VOTE I AB.
THREE FOUR FIVE I'M ALSO HERE
REPRESENTING SO HOW. THREE FIFTY
SOUTH BAY LA.
WHO THANKS REPRESENTATIVE
MURATSUCHI VERY MUCH FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL TO PROTECT
THEIR HEALTH THANK YOU?
HELLO MY NAME IS MERRY GOES
MONTH -- MOST OR NURSE I LIVE
ACROSS THE STREET FROM THE WILL.
FOR THIRTY EIGHT YEARS MY WHOLE
FAMILY EVEN STOP REPORT.
DISEASES BLOODY NOSES KEY
INDICES AND ALSO RESPIRATORY
PROBLEMS ALSO THERE IS ME THIS
MAIL AND THEN ALWAYS DAILY BASIS
I THANK YOU WE CAN'T TAKE COST
MONEY RIGHT NOW JUST WHETHER
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI SYLVIA ARREDONDO --
WILMINGTON RESIDENT I SUPPORT AB.
THREE FOUR FIVE HI.
ANJEALKA JARA CAME FROM SELMA
CALIFORNIA A SUPPORT.
AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE HELLO MY NAME
IS JENNIFER MARTINEZ AND I LIVE
IN SOME OF CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT.
AB.
THREE FOUR FIVE HELLO MY NAME IS
A LITTLE BIT LESS CROSSING OVER
I'M HERE WITH THE VOICES AND
SOLIDARITY AGAINST OIL AND
NEIGHBORHOODS IN IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE FOUR FIVE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ON THE EAST LESS
AND I WITH CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ASTHMA COLLABORATIVE IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT.
I AM DOCTOR RESTS ON A SPORTS SO
I AM COMING FROM KERN COUNTY OF
AGE WE SUPPORT.
THREE FOUR FIVE WHEN I SEVEN
MILLION RESIDENTS GO TO ANOTHER
A FEW ARE THEY I MEAN IF WE ARE
PROBLEMS THAT AT THIS POINT THEY
THINK.
HI MY MADE OF A GOVERNMENT
SCHOOL A COMMUNITY CAN YOU SAY
SHES THAT'S HOW THE LATE AYE
MEANS WHAT.
EIGHTY THREE FORTY FIVE THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE FULL HILL
INSTEAD AND I SUPPORTED THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK COOLEY A
COLD.
CALL I FELT.
I HOPE YOU TO SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MONICA MON WITH
CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COALITION WE SUPPORT PASSAGE OF
AB THREE FOUR FIVE THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED ME NUMBER SOLD
RELEASE?
SO PERCENT ON THE DENTAL SCHOOL
AND NOT SEE ONLY THE HISTORY OF
OUR THE LAW.
AVE.
THAT IS PUT INTO A SINGLE
BECAUSE HELLO MY NAME IS ERICA
RESIGNED FROM THE COMMUNITY OF
LOST TALES IN THE COUNTY OF KERN
AND I SUPPORT AB.
THREE FOUR FIVE HI MY NAME
SATURDAY EIGHT AM WITH CENTER
CALIFORNIA BERMAN TO JUSTICE
NETWORK FROM KERN AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL ALONG WITH FRANCISCO
AND SALAS A RESIDENT FROM MARVIN.
AB I GOT TO SEE -- RESIDENT FOR
MARVIN AND THE SANCHEZ FAMILY
WHO LIVE NEXT OIL ON ARMAND
THINKING.
HI MY NAME'S ELIZABETH PRESS I
ALSO WORK AT CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE NETWORK
AND I ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
INGRID BOSTON WITH THE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY IN THE ENVIRONMENT
IN SUPPORT AND ALSO REGISTERED
SUPPORT FROM GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE AND ALSO SUBMITTING A
LETTER ON BEHALF OF TWENTY THREE
ADDITIONAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
SUPPORT.
HI MARGARET HOW WITH THE
ALLIANCE NURSES FOR HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT AND WE ARE DEEPLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
HI.
MY NAME IS WORKING MISSUS I
SUPPORTED THAT I REMEMBER THAT
YOU CAN FOR A SCOPE.
I SUPPORT A AB DO.
THREE FORTY FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON
DOCTOR CATHERINE GROUP A WHITE
COORDINATOR FOR CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST FRACKING IN DANGEROUS
DRILLING HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF OUR TWO HUNDRED MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS TO SAY WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ALSO WANTED TO ENTER INTO THE
RECORD A LETTER FROM DOCTOR JOEL
JOHNSON AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PREVENTATIVE MEDICINE SHE
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY BUT SHE
SUBMITTED A LETTER DOCUMENTING
HEALTH IMPACTS NEAR OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS.
HI MY NAME IS TIM PRADAL I'M
RESIDENT OF KERN I LIVE IN AMMAN
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND I'M ASKING YOU TO WAR I MY
NAME IS PHILIP AT THAT -- HE I
GAVE HER THE CARE COUNTY IN NICE
HOPE OR THAT AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE HI MY NAME IS
HAS BEEN ANSWER BECAUSE THE LINE
I LIVING KERN COUNTY AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE WHEN A SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE TOTALING IS WHEN
WITH A WITH A CHAPTER.
HE APPOINT A LOT.
DISCORDANT A SINGLE.
THANK YOU HI AM PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCHER KYLE FOR OUR A
REPRESENTING -- OF EARTH WORKS
AND FACT CHECKER ALLIANCE AND I
STAND WITH THE FROM LIKE
COMMUNITIES IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE HI MY NAME IS
LEGION ALSO A AND I AM A MASTER
PUBLIC HEALTH STUDENT AT THE UC
BERKELEY SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF MAYBE
THREE FOUR FIVE THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED IN THE NUMBERS WE
HAVE A LOW WHO THEY BINGO THEY
LIKE WHEN YOU KNOW THEY ARE
BEING DESTROYED KEEP THAT APPLE
YEAH?
THAT IS CONVINCING.
HI MY NAME IS SIR PATTERSON I'M
FROM THE CENTER ON RACE POVERTY
THE ENVIRONMENT AND I'M STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND THE
PROTECTION OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA CROWDED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT. ONE OF
THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
JASON FIVE FULL OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
BILL MCGOVERN COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR SUPPORT.
THEN IT MOUNTING ISLAM BERMAN
CALIFORNIA THE SUPPORT.
HI EVAN MINTON VOICES FOR
PROGRESS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
LAUREN COMMA SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
BRENDA WIKI THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DAN WHAT HOURS CLEAN WATER
ACTION CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
DAVE GARCIA REPRESENTING FACT
FOR YOU COUNTY WE BAN FRACKING
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH THE 72%
VOTER APPROVAL RATE IN SUPPORT.
BY FROM FACILITY COMMUNITIES FOR
A BETTER ENVIRONMENT THE STRONG
SUPPORT.
DOESN'T JOHNSON SOUTH OF A
RESIDENT WITHIN TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FEET OF AN OIL DRILLING
SUCH STRONG SUPPORT.
LIZ THAT HERNANDEZ PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY IN
STRONG SUPPORT SOUTH CENTRAL
RESIDENT.
HI THE END OF US IS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ROOM TO DOESN'T
FLYING IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
ALSO REGISTRY SUPPORT FOR THE
CENTER COMMUNITY ACTION
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE FROM THE
INLAND EMPIRE THANK YOU.
TIFFANY IN REGISTRY IN SUPPORT
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
COALITION EACH SEE.
SYLVIA CHIEF FROM ASIA PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK RICHMOND
RETURNING STRONG SUPPORT.
SHEENA ROBINSON FROM THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENT ON AT WORK
IN OAKLAND'S REGISTERING STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAN OF TANG -- WEST -- ASIAN
PACIFIC ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK REGISTERING STRONG
SUPPORT THANK.
JUDY POPE THREE FIFTY BAY AREA
ACTION AND SAN DIEGO THREE FIFTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
JANET **** THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY THREE FIFTY RIVERSIDE AND
SO CAL THREE FIFTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANDREA WEBER RESIDENT OF
RICHMOND STRONG SUPPORT PLEASE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
OKAY THEN WITHOUT I WOULD ASK
THE OPPONENTS OF THE BILL TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND ASK THE
SUPPORTERS TO PLEASE -- MAKE
ROOM FOR THEM.
AND THE SAME -- GROUND RULES OF
TEN MINUTES SPLIT BETWEEN YOU
ALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MADAME TUSSAUDS.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SCOTT
WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL.
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES.
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS.
IN THE ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
UNION.
I'M HERE BECAUSE THIS IS TOO
IMPORTANT OF AN ISSUE TO NOT.
HAVE THE INTEGRITY OF THE FAX
BORN BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
THE BILL AS WRITTEN.
AND AS PRESENTED BY THE AUTHOR.
IS ON WARRANTED.
IT'S IRRESPONSIBLE.
AND IT'S FRANKLY RECKLESS.
THE ANALYSIS PREPARED FOR THIS
BILL WHICH I THINK WAS QUITE
THOROUGH.
FAILED TO CITE.
A SINGLE STUDY SUPPORTING.
THE BILL AS PRESENTED BY THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
IT CITED TWO STUDIES. ONE STUDY
WAS CITED BY THE AUTHOR.
WHICH HE SPOKE ABOUT EXTENSIVELY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NOTATIONS IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
YOU'LL SEE THAT THE C. C. S. T.
STUDY THAT WAS REFERENCED.
WAS ISSUED WAS IT A REPORT THAT
WAS ISSUED RELATIVE TO HYDRAULIC
FRACKING.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES IT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING.
THE SECOND STUDY REFERENCED IN
THIS ANALYSIS AND THE ONLY OTHER
STUDY REFERENCED.
IS THE BORDER THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD STUDY OF NEIGHBORHOOD AIR
NEAR PETROLEUM SOURCES OR SNAPS.
THE ANALYSIS CORRECTLY.
SITES.
THAT THERE IS NO DATA AVAILABLE
FROM THE SNAP STUDY.
SO YOU HAVE TO STUDIES.
NO CONCLUSIONS RELATIVE TO THIS
BILL.
IN MY THIRTY TWO YEARS AROUND
HERE BEFORE YOU PUT AN ENTIRE
INDUSTRY OUT OF BUSINESS.
INCLUDING TENS AND THOUSANDS OF
MINE MEMBERS.
YOU SHOULD AT LEAST TAKE THE
TIME AND CARE. TO BASE IT ON
SCIENTIFIC FACTS.
MADAM CHAIR THAT IS SIMPLY NOT
EVIDENT HERE TODAY [inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
THE DEFINITION OF EXISTING WELLS.
IN THIS BILL.
IS SOBRE NINE SO BROAD.
IN SO EXTENSIVE IT WILL
VIRTUALLY APPLY TO THE VAST
MAJORITY OF EXISTING WELLS
[inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
AGAIN EXASPERATING THE THE
IMPACT ON MY MEMBERS
[inaudible]
JOBS.
WHAT PEOPLE FAIL TO RECOGNIZE IS
THAT IN THESE EXISTING WELLS?
THEY WENT THROUGH A LOCAL
APPROVAL PROCESS.
WITH LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
THEN COLLUDED.
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS.
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION.
THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF THOSE
PROJECTS AND WHERE THEY WERE
CITED. TO NOW COME FORWARD.
WITH A PIECE OF LEGISLATION. TO
CLOSE DOWN IN INDUSTRY IN ONE
FELL SWOOP [inaudible]
WITHOUT ANSWERING.
THESE SERIOUS SERIOUS FLAWS IN
THE BILL.
DOES IT HUGE DISSERVICE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT HAS.
IT HAS.
IT UNINTENDED OR PERHAPS
INTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
IN THAT THE DEFINITION WOLF WHAT
IT WILL AFFECT FLOW LINES.
AND WAIST LINES WHICH COULD
CREATE A PERVERSE INCENTIVE FOR
WELL OWNERS TO NOT DO THE TYPE
OF WORK THEY NEED TO IMPROVE.
AIR EMISSIONS FOR FEAR OF BEING
CLOSE BY BEING FLAG AS A NEW OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION UNIT.
THIS BILL IS NOT READY FOR PRIME
TIME MEMBERS.
I WOULD URGE YOU TO REJECT THIS
BILL TODAY.
AND SEND IT BACK UNTIL THERE IS
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
SCIENCE AND WORK DONE -- BEFORE
PASSING OUT.
SO WITH THAT MY CLIENTS WOULD
URGE A NO VOTE.
MANAGER MEMBERS HEALING GARCIA
FOR THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTING THE STATE'S MAJOR
PRODUCERS OF OIL AND REFINERS OF
TRANSPORTATION FUELS.
THAT ARE VITAL TO OUR ECONOMY.
AND VERY MUCH NECESSARY FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TO DRIVE TO WORK
AND TO HOME.
IN ON VACATION THIS SUMMER.
LET ME JUST ADD A POINT TO MR
WATCHES A POINT BECAUSE HE'S
ACTUALLY RIGHT.
IF WE WERE IN A COURT OF LAW.
I WOULD HAVE TO OBJECT --
BECAUSE WE'RE ASSUMING FACTS NOT
IN EVIDENCE.
WE MAKE A STATEMENT HERE A VERY
DIRECT STATEMENT.
ABOUT THE AFFECT OF OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION IN TERMS OF ITS
IMPACTS -- TO COMMUNITIES.
AS IF IT'S FACTUAL WHEN IN FACT
IT IS NOT.
WHAT I SPENT MY A A SPRING BREAK
DOING IN -- TO NOT EXACTLY WHAT
I EXPECTED BUT I READ REPORTS I
READ THE OIL CHANGE
INTERNATIONAL REPORT WHICH IS
THE BASIS FOR THIS BILL.
CALLS FOR THE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FOOT BUFFER.
A SEARCH THE SAME -- FALSE
STATEMENTS BUT ACTUALLY DID
SOMETHING I READ THE REPORT AND
I READ THE FOOTNOTES BUT I WAS
TAUGHT TO DO THAT IN LAW SCHOOL.
I READ THE FOOTNOTES AND THAT
LED ME TO THE CCSD REPORT PAGE
CITED.
THE SPECIFIC PAGE CITED BY THE
OIL CHANGE INTERNATIONAL REPORT.
SPECIFICALLY TELLS YOU THAT THE
FINDINGS DO NOT APPLY TO
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA IMPACTS MAY BE
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT BUT HAVE
NOT BEEN MEASURE.
SO WE ARE MAKING STATEMENTS AS
THE AS IF THEY ARE FACT WE ARE
PROPOSING TO SHUT DOWN.
THOUSANDS OF WELLS IN CALIFORNIA
80%.
OF THE PRODUCTION LOS ANGELES
12% STATE WIDE.
POTENTIALLY ENDANGERING THE JOBS
OF THOUSANDS OF FOLKS THAT
MISTER WHAT SPOKE.
TO HARMING COMMUNITIES AND WE'RE
ALL DOING IT ALL ON A FALSE
ASSUMPTION THAT THERE A FAX OR
IN.
SO I SAID WELL IT'S NOT THE CCS
T. REPORT BECAUSE THAT CLEARLY
DOESN'T SAY THAT THERE ARE --
NOTED -- IMPACTS SO MAYBE IT'S
THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
MAYBE THAT ONE SAYS THAT SO I
READ THAT REPORT [inaudible]
THAT REPORT.
CLEARLY CONCLUDES.
THAT THE LITERATURE IS UNABLE TO
CONCLUDE AT THIS TIME WHETHER OR
NOT LIVING WORKING OR GOING TO
SCHOOL IN THE OIL AND GAS
FACILITIES.
IS ASSOCIATED WITH A LONG TERM
NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS.
THAT'S THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REPORT ISSUED IN FEBRUARY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHICH VERY
CLEARLY CONCLUDES THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
OF WHAT THIS STATUTE.
PROPOSES TO STATE AS FACT.
AGAIN JOBS ARE AT RISK OIL.
OIL SUPPLY FOR THE STATE
TRANSPORTATION FUELS ARE AT RISK.
AND WE'RE BASING IT ON FALSE
ASSUMPTIONS.
MISTER WHICH MENTIONED THE SNAPS
ANALYSIS THAT.
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
CONDUCTING TODAY.
THEY'RE CONDUCTING THAT ANALYSIS
REVIEWING.
THE IMPACTS ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
OIL AND GAS PRODUCTION IN
NEIGHBORING FACILITIES THAT CAME
AS A RESULT OF AB SIX SEVENTEEN
MISS GARCIA'S BILL.
THAT BILL IS SUPPOSED TO GIVE US
DATA.
DATA WHICH WE CAN RELY ON TO
IMPLEMENT POLICY DATA DRIVEN
POLICY AND FOR THAT REASON OUR
INDUSTRY.
A SUPPORT THE BILL BECAUSE WE
WANT TO DEVELOP POLICY BASED ON
DATA.
WHAT AB THREE FORTY FIVE NOW
DOES IT SAYS LET'S FORGET THE
DATA?
LET'S FORGET THE ANALYSIS LET'S
JUST PRESUME THE FAX.
AND THAT'S SIMPLY SOMETHING THAT
WE CANNOT ACCEPT.
BECAUSE JOBS ARE AT RISK FUEL
SUPPLIES AT RISK OUR ECONOMY AND
THE SPECIFICALLY.
COMMUNITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY ARE AT RISK SO WE JUST
CAN'T ACCEPT THAT AS FACT.
WHAT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ALSO
POINTS OUT IN ALL MAKE THIS MY
LAST POINT?
WAS THAT THERE WERE CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED.
IN LOS ANGELES AND AN
APPROPRIATELY SO ECAUSE THEY
WERE SMALL OPERATORS.
THAT WERE WORKING OPERATING
BELOW THE STANDARD OF CARE
OPERATING EQUIPMENT THAT WAS IN
DISREPAIR.
THAT IS A SPECIFIC SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT WE ARE HAPPY TO ADDRESS WE
ARE HAPPY. TO JOIN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THIS BODY AND WORKING
ON THAT ISSUE BECAUSE WE CANNOT
ACCEPT.
AND WE WON'T ACCEPT AND SUPPORT
SOMEBODY OPERATING BELOW THE
STANDARD OF CARE.
BUT THAT IS A VERY VERY
DIFFERENCES SITUATION THAT WHAT
YOU HAVE HERE IN AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE YOU HAVE A
STATE WIDE.
HALF MILE SET BACK REGARDLESS OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES REGARDLESS OF
THE SITE REGARDLESS OF THE WORK
THAT WAS DONE LOCALLY TO ENSURE
THE PROTECTION THAT COMMUNITY.
AND THAT IS GOING TO HARM JOBS.
IN IS A BROAD BLANKET APPROACH
TO TO SIMPLY DOES NOT WORK WE
CAN'T ACCEPT AND WE WON'T.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
BUT I WOULD VERY VERY MUCH
ADAMANTLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK
AT THE SPECIFIC STUDIES THAT.
ASK FOR INFORMATION BECAUSE IT'S
SIMPLY NOT THERE. FOR THAT
REASON THE THE WEST IS A FUN
POSITION OPPOSE THE BILL.
MANAGER MEMBERS AS READY AS A
BEHALF OF STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALL
BE -- BRIEF BECAUSE I KNOW IN
SPIRIT OF TIME WE'VE ALREADY
COVERED MANY ISSUES -- BUT IN
SHORT CALIFORNIA MUST DO A
BETTER JOB OF BALANCING THE
PRIORITIES ON THE ENVIRONMENT
WITH ALSO THE ISSUES THAT ARE
AFFECTING WORKING FAMILIES TODAY.
YOU'RE WELCOME MILLER WITH THE
INCOME INEQUALITY THAT EXIST.
CALIFORNIA'S GREATNESS WAS
CREATED BY THE MANUFACTURING
SECTOR.
GOOD QUALITY UNION JOBS THAT ARE
NO LONGER IN EXISTENCE AS WE'RE
LOOKING TO ADDRESS ISSUES WITH
THE ENVIRONMENT AND THEY JUST
TRANSITION IT SHOULDN'T BE TO
ELIMINATE ALL THESE GOOD QUALITY
JOBS ARE ACTUALLY EMPLOYING MANY
UNION MEMBERS.
AND ARE PROVIDING FOR FAMILY
SUSTAINING WAGES WITH ACCESS TO
QUALITY HEALTHCARE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WANTS TO THE ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BUT AS WAS STATED BY THE
GERMAN FROM WEST BUT THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO ADDRESS IT.
AND IF HE WOULD A REACHED OUT
EARLIER AND ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
PERHAPS IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
BETTER CONVERSATION TO LOOK AT
HOW TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF CONCERN
WHEN THERE'S LESS THAN STANDARD.
OPERATIONS OF THOSE WELLS BUT
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL
INTENDS TO DO.
THIS BILL IS MORE OF AN
EMOTIONAL ARGUMENT TO BASICALLY
GET RID OF AN INDUSTRY THAT
CURRENTLY PROVIDES.
REASONABLE COST ENERGY FOR A LOT
OF WORKING FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE AND THAT IS ACTUALLY
EMPLOYING THOUSANDS OF UNION
MEMBERS WITH ACCESS TO
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU PROVIDING WORKING
FAMILIES IN THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WITH A
CAREER NOT JUST A JOB BUT AN
ACTUAL CAREER.
THOSE ARE THE BLUE COLLAR JOBS
THAT CALIFORNIA IS NOW
HEMORRHAGING TO OTHER STATES.
WE SUPPORTED A LOT OF THE STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS THAT THE
STATE HAS ALREADY PASSED WE WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN IT IN THEIR
PASSAGE.
BUT HOWEVER WE NEVER MEANT FOR
THEM -- TO RADIC KATE ALL THESE
INDUSTRIES WE WENT TO ACTUALLY
MAKE THIS INDUSTRY SAFER.
MORE EFFICIENT.
IN ACTUALLY CREATE THOSE JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A LOT OF THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
SO BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE REASONS
AND BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA'S
STRONGEST ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS TO ADDRESS A LOT OF
THESE PERMITTED.
WE HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
TO REJECT THIS BILL SENATE BACK
AND ALLOW US TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON A DIFFERENT FORM THANK
YOU.
YOU KNOW NOW I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TO PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IT AGAIN
WE ARE NOT ACCEPTING TESTIMONY
JUST YOUR NAME.
ANY AFFILIATION YOU WANT TO GIVE.
AND WHETHER OR NOT YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL.
ON A DAY ON BEHALF OF THE AM
VETS AMERICAN VETERANS
DEPARTMENT A CALIFORNIA WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
CARLOS PORTABLE ON BEHALF OF
TEAMSTER JOINT COUNCIL SEVEN AND
TEAMSTER TRUCK COUNCIL.
FORTY TWO WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND BOTH INTERVIEWS HAVE SENT
LETTERS OF OF A POLL OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL FOR YOUR REVIEW
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TOMORROW DAVIS
BUSINESS REP FOR IBEW LOCAL
ELEVEN ELECTRICIANS UNION LOSS I
JUST COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL AS IT IS.
DONE RIGHT NOW THE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
NORMA BRIANNA'S CHRISTIANSEN
AMERICAN GI FORUM AGI F. AND THE
POST COMMANDER VFW POST SIXTY
SEVEN WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
I UNDERSTAND JUST IBEW LOCAL
ELEVEN TWELVE THOUSAND MEMBERS
IN LA COUNTY ASK FOR YOU TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CAROL CAN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL REPRESENTING THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND NEW CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I KEEP DONE DISTRICT COUNCIL OF
OUR WORKERS SAY THE CALIFORNIA
AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
TOM LIMóN SAN DIEGO PER
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION.
BRIAN JAMISON WORK FOR AIR
ENERGY ELEVEN TOP CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS SURROUNDED THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY DEGREES BY OIL
FIELDS PERFECT FOR YOUR SIDE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE THOUGHT.
THIS BILL.
I'M DOROTHY ROSENMAN FI A HO.
I OWN A GAS WILL IN THE SUTTER
BASIN AND I OPPOSE THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
HELLO Là MERION RAINY I LIVE IN
THE ONLY DISADVANTAGE AND
INCORPORATED COMMUNITY INVENTOR
COUNTY WITH A MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD
INCOME OF FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
WITH THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
THERE 93% OF LATINO.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MIKE BURGER RESIDENT OF INTER
COMPANY OF RETIRED UNION IRON
WORKER AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
ROB LOVELACE SOUTHWEST REGIONAL
COUNCIL OF CARPENTERS FIFTY
THOUSAND OF US OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
SIR.
OF LOS CARTON KERN COUNTY.
INDEPENDENT OIL PRODUCES
ALLIANCE.
AND ALSO A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
OF FORTY YEARS.
WE ALSO OPPOSE THE BILL.
IS THERE KESSLER FROM SELMA
FRESNO COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
UNLESS SIMMERING GARCIA FROM
SOMEONE TELL SOMEONE
CALIFORNIATRUSTSWOMEN COUNTY AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
ALEX ALEX THE HILL PETROLEUM
ENGINEER FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MAKING NELSON WAS CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE CORPORATIONS
BAKERSFIELD I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M MORE IN THE LAST FEW WITH
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES CORPORATION
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BILL GILLESPIE.
PROUD FATHER OF LAUREN.
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES CORPORATION.
BAKERSFIELD OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHRIS COLOR WITH CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES CORPORATION FROM LA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS KAYLA CAN NICK I'M
FROM CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION I LIVE IN MOSCOW
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS THE FINAL VOTE ON I
AM WITH CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION AND I LIVE IN
SHAFTER CALIFORNIA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FROM MALLOY'S SUMMIT TEAMS STERN
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OVER TO ARE YOU --
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF EVER KNOW
WHO WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE OIL
COMPANIES SINCE NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEW HELPER
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
CONSTRUCTION COMMITTEE OPPOSE
THE BILL.
J. HAWES AIR ENERGY AYE OPPOSED
HIS BILL.
MIKE DRAIN THEIR ENERGY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I'M CHOICE TYPE KINGS OLD TOOLS
KERN COUNTY CALIFORNIA OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED COMMITTEE
I AM JACK I WON A TROUBLED HERE
THIS MORNING FROM SOUTHERN
ORANGE COUNTY.
AND I'M BASICALLY JUST A PRIVATE
TAXPAYING CITIZEN.
AND I OPPOSE THE BILL SB
[inaudible]
THIRTY FIVE THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
MARTIN RODRIGUEZ BUSINESS AGENT
LOCAL FOR THIRTY THREE I WORKERS
I REPRESENT FIFTY FOUR AND I
WORKERS AND WE WERE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MITCH BONDS IRON WORKERS LOCAL
FOUR THREE THREE LOS ANGELES MID
BUSINESS AGING DISCOUNTS WILL
REP WE STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KAYLA WHAT WE KEEP BY
REPRESENT WOMEN WORKING IN THE
OIL INDUSTRY AND I STRONGLY
DISAPPROVE OF THIS BILL.
I'M RANDALL KEITH I LIVE IN EL
DORADO COUNTY.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
JOHN SPAULDING REPRESENTING THE
KERN ANNUAL AND MODEL COUNTIES
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
STACEY MURPHY VICE PRESIDENT
BUSINESS REP FOR TEAMSTERS LOCAL
THIS BILL.
PHILLY BAR LAWS THE TEAMSTERS
LOCAL EIGHT FIFTY THREE I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HAROLD ROE BLESSED WITH THE
LATTER BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
EIGHT THOUSAND MEMBERS AND WE
OPPOSE AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE I AM TRACEY
KELLY WITH TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHT
FIFTY THREE IN OAKLAND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME SAN FRAN I'M WITH
CHARLIE ON MANAGE ALL FIELD
OPERATIONS THAT ARE SAFE AND
COMPLIANCE LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M RAY CLAN WITH
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES CORPORATION
I'M A PROFESSIONAL PETROLEUM
ENGINEER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S KEN HANEY WITH
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES THIRTY YEAR
RESIDENT OF KERN COUNTY ALONG
WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS OF OIL
WELLS.
AND I ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS GENET PETERSON A
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES CORPORATION
I'M A FIELD ADMIN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DON CHAMPION I LIVE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES CORPORATION
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS DON NELSON I'M A
LICENSED PATROLLING MENTION HERE
FROM BAKERSFIELD AND MY OFFICE
IS SAFELY LOCATED ABOUT FIFTY
FEET FROM AN OIL WELL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M RON MILLER EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE LA ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF AHUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND SKILLED TRAINED
MEN AND WOMEN OF THE BUILDING
TRADES -- WE WORK IN THE MOST
HEAVILY REGULATED INDUSTRY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE OIL
INDUSTRY.
LET'S -- FUND IT.
AND ENFORCE THE LAWS THAT ARE IN
PLACE WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ABIGAIL FONT I LIVE IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA I WORK
FOR CHEVRON AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS MEGAN LOPEZ I
LIVE IN BIGGER SO CALIFORNIA AND
I WORK FOR CHEVRON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALEX ROTH WELL
I WORK FOR SIGNAL HILL PETROLEUM
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAM REGULARLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANKS.
HELLO MY NAME'S ALL THEIR
ARRESTS WITHIN TWELVE RENDON
OLYMPIAN AND ALSO CURRENTLY ROLE
CHAMPION I'M FROM OUT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THIS BILL THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MANUAL KENYA
PRESIDENT THE NEEDS A PHARMACY
BASED IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE ABSOLUTELY OPPOSES JOB BILL
BECAUSE OF ALL THE IMPACTS OF
OUR FARM COST IN OUR LABOR THAT
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE IMPACTS IN
OUR FRONT COMMUNITIES.
WHO ARE THE PEOPLE AT THE END?
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY SOUL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HOPING THAT
YOU DO NOT MOVE THIS FORWARD
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS VICTOR
OFFICE I AM THE MAYOR OF THE
CITY ONCE CALLED IN THE SHERMAN
OF THE LATINO ELECTED OFFICIALS.
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE
REPRESENT A LOT OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND WE AFTER BIG YOU.
OPPOSE THIS BILL PLEASE THANK
YOU.
OUR JARI OFGEM HAVE THE LEGAL
CALIFORNIA'S IS LOOKING CAUCUS
OPPOSES BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON OTHER PURCELL --
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE CITY
OF OFTEN ONLY KINGS COUNTY I'M
ALSO REPRESENTING -- FRESNO
COUNTY NOT TO WORK FOR FRESNO
COUNTY AND I DO HAVE A LOT OF
RELATIVES WORKING CURRENT CONNIE.
SAYING WE STRONGLY OPPOSED HIS
FILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RON ROLE THAT I'M A
BUSINESS AGENT FOR THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS REGIONAL
COUNCIL AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
FORTY THOUSAND MEMBERS WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY QUEST REPRESENTING DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES IN OPPOSITION.
ROB STOKER REPRESENTING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE OH FOUR AS WELL AS THE
ALAMEDA BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL
IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
MARKETS GOMEZ SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER HERE SACRAMENTO WHO OWNS
TO DIESEL TRUCKS.
ALSO CENTRAL REGION CHAIR FOR A
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
JOINT COMMITTEE CALIFORNIA'S
BACK CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
ON BEHALF OF OUR OUR CHAMBER AND
ARE -- SEVENTY EIGHT LOCAL
CHAMBERS AND AND AFFILIATES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE BILL.
I'M A CASE TO HIM I WORKED WITH
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE CORPORATION
AND LIVES IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
DANIEL BY THE WHAT CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES CORPORATION I'M IN
OPPOSITION -- TO A. B.. THREE
FOUR FIVE AND I HOPE THAT YOU
ALSO CONSIDER OPPOSE IN THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DANNY
BERNARDINI BUSINESS MANAGER NAPA
SOLANO BUILDING TRADES AND I'M
SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON YEAH UNIFIED
ISN'T REPRESENTING THE FRESNO
AREA HISPANIC FOUNDATION IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL OPPOSED.
CARE IS NEEDED -- I LIVE IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA I WORK
FOR AIR ENERGY IN THE LEASE
OPERATOR AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE HELLO MY NAME
IS ONE RIGHT NOW I AM IN
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA.
THE WORKING IN THE OIL INDUSTRY
FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS
REPRESENT ERA ENERGY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROBERT BE ABOUT I'M
AN ENVIRONMENTAL ADVISER FOR AIR
ENERGY IN KERN COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PATRICK FLORES A WORK FOR HER
ENERGY IN BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY ROBBIE I
REPRESENT THE LOCAL FAR FOR NOT
BOILERMAKERS AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSES BILL.
HELLO MY NAME SAID WE'RE
GONZALEZ I WORK FOR ERROR ENERGY
FOR IN BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN CROSS OF
MIRROR REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF A
UNITED STEEL WORKERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE HERE TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK.
HELLO LOOK AS CHAMBERS WORK FOR
ENERGY LIVE BIGGEST THE
CALIFORNIA THIRD GENERATION ALL
MAN.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS GREG HARTMAN I
REPRESENT THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
LOCAL EIGHT AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS DEBBIE YOUR
THREE GUESTS AND I AM IN OUR
HEALTH ENVIRONMENT SAFETY
DEPARTMENT WAS CHEVRON I OVERSEE
THE CONTRACTOR EACH YES
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM PROCESS.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DOUG KESSLER AND
DISSECTED TRACTOR C. SO QUITE A
FRESNO KERN SLURRING AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DEREK SILLY OF
PHONE FRESNO COUNTY AND I
OPPOSES THE HELLO MY AND MY
GARCIA FROM SOME OF CALIFORNIA
IN FRESNO COUNTY AND WE HAVE I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS LISA LESTER I WORK
FOR ERIN ENERGY I LIVE AND HAVE
RAISED MY FAMILY IN CALLING THE
OIL FIELD.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FILLING A SUDDEN I
WORK FOR AIR ENERGY MY OFFICE IS
IN AN OIL FIELD WHERE IT'S VERY
SAFE AND CLEAN AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
HI AM SHAUN BEECROFT I'M AN
ENGINEER FOR CHEVRON AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON BENJAMIN HIKING
OVER THE CLING AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE -- WE HAVE A MEMBERSHIP
OF ONE SIXTY FIVE WITH A STRONG
OPPOSITION AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE HI MY NAME IS
MELISSA TRIAL WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BUSINESS FEDERATION
REPRESENTING TWENTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS AND WE OPPOSE THE
SPELL.
TONY GARCIA TEAMSTERS LOCAL
THREE FIFTEEN IN MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS
AND WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
MY CUES BUSINESS AGENT -- THREE
FIFTEEN WORK DIRECTLY WITH THE
THE REFINERIES IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOVERNOR DAY RODRIGUEZ FROM
TEAMS LOCAL THREE FIFTEEN AND WE
ALSO OPPOSES BILL.
HI THERE ARE METAL INDIAN IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR OF
TEAMSTERS THREE FIFTEEN AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL.
JERRY SEASON TEAMSTERS LOCAL
THREE FIFTEEN BUSINESS AGENT
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M JOHNNY WALKER WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF BY
LAWMAKERS RUN A COACH ACOSTA
COUNTY AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S EDWIN LOMBARD ON THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS NYDIA DAILY AND
I'M A BOILERMAKER OUT OF LOCAL
FIVE FORTY NINE AND I'M A
PREMISE I LIVE IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND I WORK IN THE BAY
AREA AND I'M OPPOSE OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JUST GONZALEZ OF A
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA NOW WITH
THE SEE SUPPORT THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TO SEE A FLORIST
HELLO I'M FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA
WITH THIS HE SAID FOR THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JEANETTE BURNETT HERE ON BEHALF
OF CREE LA AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME'S DAVE SHEPPERD I
WORK PERCENT NO PEAK RESOURCES
IN BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON ZACK
STRUCTURES WITH ADOLESCENT
RESCUED MENTORING SOLUTIONS OF
LA NOW WE HELP AT RISK YOUTH GET
UNION CAREERS AND WE ARE IN FIRM
OPPOSITION IN THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO HERE IN
OPPOSITION.
MY NAME IS JERRY FERNANDEZ I'M
WAS C. NJ ENERGY SERVICES AND ON
BEHALF OF THIRTEEN HUNDRED AND
FORTY FOUR EMPLOYEES.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL -- I AM
FORCED CAN REALLY WORK WITH
CHEVRON AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RON JAY SMITH WITH
ADOLESCENT RESCUE IN MENTORING
SOLUTIONS WE HELP THOUSANDS OF
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN IN SOUTH
CENTRAL CENTRAL LA AN EAST LA.
GET JOBS IN.
THE TRADE INDUSTRIES WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AUGUSTINE LEE FROM
KERN COUNTY OR EMPLOYEE OF ERROR
ENERGY AND AND I OPPOSE AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE MY NAME IS DAN
MY NIKE I WORK WITH THEIR ENERGY
AND BIG SHOW CALIFORNIA AND
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS GREG MCNISH WITH
THEIR ENERGY IN BAKERSFIELD.
I ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TERRY WE REPRESENT
VERY PATROLLING THE CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
THE NAME'S DAVID OPPENHEIMER
EMPLOYEE OF CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION ALSO FOURTH
GENERATION -- RESIDENT KERN
COUNTY BEEN AROUND INDUSTRY A
LONG TIME.%
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JAMES FORWARD I'VE
WORKED -- FOR ERROR ENERGY IN
THE OIL INDUSTRY FOR AROUND
THIRTY YEARS.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JUSTIN FANTASQUE
YEMEN'S SO THESE ENGINEER FOR
AIR ENERGY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MOLLY CLARKE AND THE
FACILITIES ENGINEER FOR AIR
ENERGY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S TRAVIS WOOLF I WORK
FOR KINGS ALL TOOLS AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JIMMY THOMAS THEY
WORK FOR ERROR ENERGY AND I
OPPOSE AB.
THREE FORTY FIVE MY NAME'S BILL
BECKER WITH KINGS WELL TOOLS SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S OBERTO PLACENCIA WORK
FOR YOU BE NATURAL RESOURCE -- A
FIELD TECHNICIAN AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FRED WILLARD WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA RESOURCE CORPORATION
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
RICHARD HILL WORK FOR CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE CORPORATION OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
RON MICHAEL'S WITH CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES CORPORATION AND I
OPPOSE A BILL.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY SRNA AREA
MANAGER FOR HARBISON FISHER BEEN
IN INDUSTRY FOR TWENTY THREE
YEARS.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS EVA GLORIA I
REPRESENT VERY PETROLEUM I'M AN
ENGINEERING ANALYST AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
CHRISTINE HALLE I'M AN ENGINEER
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR SENTINEL
PEAK RESOURCES AND A KERN COUNTY
GRAND MOTHER.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO JOIN US IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IT'S
JUST NOT WELL THOUGHT OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JIM
TASKER OF A FORTY YEAR OLD
VETERAN OF THE OLD BUSINESS -- I
WORK FOR CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS JUSTIN FOR NIGHT
WORK FOR AREA ENERGY AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM TO MILLER EVER TO
NORTHFIELD FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I HAVE BRING FRIEDMAN HEALTH AND
SAFETY ENGINEER FOR ERROR ENERGY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CHEN ARAMBULA WHEN MEN WITH
CHEVRON -- STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME'S MARK TATUM WAS CHEVRON
AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS COREY WILLIAMS A
COMMUNITY OUTREACH ADVISER FOR
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES CORPORATION
BEEN IN THE INDUSTRY FOR FORTY
SIX FORTY THREE YEARS.
AT THIS INDUSTRY HAS PROVIDED A
VERY COMFORTABLE -- INCOME FOR
MY FAMILY I'M A SINGLE MOTHER SO
I STRONGLY AT OBJECT TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JESSE BOYD COMMISSION
OF OUR EMPLOYEES I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME THE PROGRAM IS TWENTY
SEVEN YEARS IN THE OIL INDUSTRY
WORKING DIRECTLY ON THE PILL.
AND THIS IS A PUT MY FAMILY
THROUGH COLLEGE AND HIGH SCHOOL
ALL THAT'S GOOD STUFF I OPPOSE
THE A. B..
MY NAME IS RAYMOND RODRIGUEZ
SOME AN ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEER
FOR CALIFORNIA RESOURCES AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE KERN COUNTY
LEAGUE OF UNITED LATIN AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THERE WERE ACTUALLY DIRECTOR OF
REGULATORY AFFAIRS FOR
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES CORPORATION --
ALSO STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL HAVEN'T.
DIRECTOR OF SUSTAINABILITY WITH
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JOINED HAVA
I'M AN ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEER I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
CAPTION MY NAME IS DANIEL VASSAR
I'M A SENIOR FACILITIES ENGINEER
FOR CHEVRON IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MANY WAS JUST GONZALEZ UPPER
FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME'S RHETORIC OF OUR AND
I FOR PRESENT CALIFORNIA POSES
Và.
HI MY NAME IS TWENTY MINUTES AND
I'LL FOR THE CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS CANDY GARCIA AND I'M
FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE PROP AB.
THREE FOUR MY NAME'S CHRIS AGAIN
DOLLARS SOMETHING FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS PART REGUS FROM
FRESNO CALIFORNIA MY
ORGANIZATION IS HE SAID PUTTING.
AN APPLES THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEVEN
GOMEZ I AM THE BUSINESS MANAGER
OF THE UNITED SO SAGE THE
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
FOUR SIXTY BAKERSFIELD.
AND ON BEHALF OF MY EIGHT
HUNDRED MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES I ASK THAT YOU OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS WILLIAM MASTERS SAMA
ALSO A MEMBER OF LOCAL FOR SIXTY
IN BECAUSE FOR CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS NOT YET FLOOR IS A
MEMBER OF LOCAL FOR SIXTEEN AND
I ALSO OPPOSE THIS BILL
[inaudible]
DANNY RIGHT.
BUSINESS MANAGER LOCAL TWO FOUR
SIX FRESNO CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
MEMBERS FRESNO MADERA KINGS AND
TULARE COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
RENDON LEVIN BURKE YOU A LOCAL
TWO FOUR SIX FRESNO WE OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME IS ROBERT ABOUT
THEM A MEMBER OF THE FRESNO AREA
PLUMBERS PIPE AND REFRIGERATION
FETTERS YOU A LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
JOHN HENRY LOPEZ FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA YOU A PLUMBERS
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX
AND FRESNO AND OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON GLENN LOVE ON
BEHALF OF IRON WORKERS UNION
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT ALSO
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
WHEN WE RETURN LIVE IN SANTA
MARIA I OWN AND OPERATE TO
CATTLE RANCHERS IN NORTHERN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WHICH IS
ENJOYED OIL PRODUCTION FOR
NEARLY A CENTURY A SUPPLEMENTAL
INCOME?
I'M HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WHICH
REGARDS THE OIL INDUSTRY AS AN
IMPORTANT FOUNDATION OF OUR
COUNTY ECONOMY AND VIGOROUSLY
OPPOSES AB THREE FORTY FIVE
THANK.
MY NAME IS SHERRY BROUGH I WORK
FOR CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA.
I AM A SINGLE MOTHER OF THREE
AND THIS INDUSTRY HAS ALLOWED ME
TO SOLELY SUPPORT MY FAMILY.
AND I UP OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M TERRY NICHOLS.
THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION.
I'VE BEEN IN THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS IN THE FRESNO COUNTY AND
KERN COUNTY AREA.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ED HAZARD I'M A
FOURTH GENERATION CALIFORNIAN MY
FAMILY AND I ARE SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY OIL AND GAS MINERAL AND
ROYALTY OWNERS AND I AM
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF ROYALTY OWNERS.
REPRESENTING THE INTERESTS OF
THE OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ROYALTY OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA
PRIVATE CITIZEN ROYALTY OWNERS
AND EVEN MORE MINERAL OWNERS.
COLLECTIVELY WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
AB THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON I'M WILL SKY
JUNIOR FROM FRESNO ON THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OUT VERY
INVOLVES A CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU HAVE -- ON MY MEMBERSHIP
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL WE FEEL IT
WOULD BE ALL OVER TO THE FAMILY
FARM ALSO TO COMMUNITY AND ALSO
WE FEEL THEY'VE PROBABLY CREATED
A LOT OF COLLATERAL DAMAGE THANK
YOU.
DAVE I LOVE FROM IBEW LOCAL ONE
EIGHTY SOLANO NAPA AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
SETTLES NETWORK FOR CHEVRON
PIPELINE OF POWER AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MELISSA ONE MARK I'M FROM
BAKERSFIELD I'M A MOM AND A
SINGLE BREADWINNER FOR MY FAMILY
AND I WORK FOR CHEVRON I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
THREE FOUR FIVE JOHN THE
GOVERNMENT FACILITY ENGINEER
WITH CHEVRON A BIGGER STILL
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING CALLING
CALIFORNIAN I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS LINDSAY ELOISE
AND I WORK FOR CHEVRON AS A
FIELD ENGINEER ON A RIG THIS
INDUSTRY HELP PAY FOR MY
EDUCATION AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME SPREADING ELISE
WORKER CHEVRON AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
SHANE HOW SERVICEMEN THIS PLAN
FOR CHEVRON I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON RANDY ROBINSON
AND THE SECURITY COORDINATOR FOR
CHEVRON BAKERSFIELD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES BILL.
MY NAME IS RIGHT ABOUT IT I WORK
FOR CHEVRON OUT OF SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
YEAH MY NAME'S BOBJENNINGS ON
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FOR THE BUILDING TRADES
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND I LIVE IN FRESNO.
MY NAME IS DANIEL VICE I'M A
PROCESS SAFETY ENGINEER WITH
CHEVRON BAKERSFIELD.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ADAM OF YOU JUST
AT WORK FOR CHEVRON AND
BAKERSFIELD I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M BLOODY
RODRIGUEZ I'M A REALTOR CHERUBS
AT TURNER LUCK WITH THE KERN
COUNTY HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE REPRESENT OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND LATINO
FAMILIES IN KERN COUNTY.
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI I'M JENNIFER PITCH I
REPRESENT THE YOUNG
PROFESSIONALS AND ENERGY FOR
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS GOT ELEVEN
SILENCE AND WITH CURRENT
CITIZENS FOR ENERGY AND WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JESS
BEEN ABROAD I WORK FOR CHEVRON
AS A FACILITY ENGINEER AND A
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS DAVID **** A RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS CHARLIE **** FROM
REBEL CALIFORNIAN I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
CHARLIE **** AIR ENERGY AND ALSO
THE RIVERDALE SCHOOL DISTRICT --
BOARD MEMBER.
FROM FRESNO COUNTY AND I POSE
THIS BILL.
TANYA STOLTZ FROM CALLING A
CALIFORNIA I AM ON THE CITY
COUNCIL AND ALSO A RESIDENT AND
I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
DAVE MCCLAIN WORK FOR HARBISON
FISHER BAKERSFIELD AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS BOB SUMMER
SIGNED THE AUTOMATION MANAGER
FOR CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
CORPORATION AND ALSO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOUR TIME GUY HERE FILLED
C. R. C. CALIFORNIA.
WHEN IT'S TIME YOU REYES I'M AN
ENGINEER PERCENT OF PEAK
RESOURCES I'M HERE TO OPPOSE AB
THREE FOUR FIVE FOR ME MY FAMILY?
HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR GIBA MOVED --
WORKING IN -- SO I WORKING --
FOREST'S INTENT RESOURCES IN THE
BECAUSE A CALIFORNIA AND I ON
BEHALF OF MY FAMILY I FROM
EUROPE WAS HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROBERT HASS BROCK I
WORK FOR WEATHERFORD ON HALF MY
FAMILY AND THE THREE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE EMPLOYEES WE EMPLOYEE
STATEWIDE THEIR FAMILIES.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THIS I AM WRONG WRESTLED COOPER
AND I OWN MY OWN SMALL BUSINESS
OIL INDUSTRY ROBBINS ENVIRO BACK.
I DEFINITELY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
WHEN IS MASON WAGNER WORK FOR
CHEVRON AND BIG FOR CALIFORNIA
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL?
NEWMAN IN STEVENS WORK FARE
ENERGY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS P. ANTHONY THOMAS
RIBBONS IN THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA NOT
TO GASP IS.
PATROLLED NATURAL GAS PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION STRONG OPPOSITION
AND REGISTERING THAT FOR A. B..
THREE FORTY FIVE THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLC WISHING TO VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY I SEE NINE AND BEFORE I
MOVED TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
WE'LL CALL PLEASE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HERE FRIEDMAN
HERE FLORA FLOOR HERE CHAU.
EGGMAN GARCIA.
GARCIA HERE LIMON.
MATHIS.
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE MELENDEZ WROTE TO
TREAT THEIR WROTE TO G. HERE
STONE.
OKAY WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM -- BEFORE I GO TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS ARE YOU
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YES TO THE BILL OKAY.
WITHOUT ALL GO TO MISTER FLORA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS
RESEARCH YOU'RE JUST HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FOR YOU HERE
AND AND MAYBE A FEW COMMENTS AT
THE END BUT DO YOU AGREE WITH
THE ANALYSIS IN THE BILL'S
SUPPORTERS.
THAT IF THIS BILL PASSES THE
RESULT IN STUDY NOW SIGNIFICANT
IN STATE PRODUCTION.
I DISAGREE.
HI OF YOU KNOW THERE THERE WAS
REFERENCE MADE TO WHAT THE
PEOPLE LEARN IN LAW SCHOOL FIRST
THING I LEARNED A LAW SCHOOLS
READ THE BILL.
THE BILL SAYS THAT THIS ONLY
APPLIES TO ALL NEW OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT.
SO WITH HIS BILL ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
AND THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN.
WE CAN DISCUSS THAT -- LOOK AT A
LATER TIME BECAUSE I DO HAVE.
CONCERNS THAT THIS IS GOING TO
LIMIT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF IN
STATE WILL PRODUCTION -- MOVING
FORWARD IN THE FUTURE A AND
EQUALLY OUT FOR FOLKS THAT HAVE
PROPERTY RIGHTS WHERE THEY HAVE
THE MIDDLE RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT'S UNDERNEATH THE
GROUND THAT WILL ALSO BE A HUGE
CONCERN SO NOW WE'RE DEALING
WITH THE PRIVATE PROPERTY ISSUE.
BUT DOES THIS THING PROGRESSES.
IT IS FASCINATING THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO IN THE
STATE WE TALK ABOUT THE LOAN
COMMUNICATE WITH LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY AND ALL THAT WE NEED
TO DO TO SUPPORT AND PROTECT
THEM. ONE OF THE BIG THINGS THAT
THAT DRIVES UP THE COST AND THE
COST OF LIVING IN THE STATE IS
QUITE FRANKLY FOOD THE COST OF
FOOD THE COST OF TRANSPORTATION.
SO IF THERE IS ANY ASPECT OF
THIS BILL THAT LIMITS IN STATE
OIL PRODUCTION.
AND DRIVES UP THE COST WILL BE
TRANSPORTATION OR THE COST TO
FARM THE COST. TO TO PUT A
PRODUCT IN THE SUPERMARKET THAT
OUR OUR COLLEAGUES AND OUR
FRIENDS GO BY WE HAVE A SERIOUS
ISSUE.
AND SO ANYTHING THAT WE DO ON
THAT -- I AM CONCERNED AS WELL
AS ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE OF
IT IF WE SHUT DOWN THE IN STATE
OIL PRODUCTION WHERE WE GONNA
SUPPLEMENT THAT FROM.
IT'S GONNA BE FROM OVER SORT OF
FOREIGN OIL.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA THE MOST REGULATED
OIL INDUSTRY ANY ATTIRE COUNTRY.
THAT'S THE SAFEST PLACE THAT WE
CAN GET THIS OIL IS RIGHT HERE
BELOW US IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO I WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGES
**** THING MOVES FORWARD THAT WE
TAKE THIS IN MIND WE TALK ABOUT
THE LOW INCOME COMMUNITY BUT
LET'S REALLY FOCUS ON WHAT.
THE ASPECT AND WHAT THIS
ACTUALLY MEANS BECAUSE IF WE DO
NOW I PERSONALLY BELIEVE IT'S
GONNA SHUT DOWN ABOUT 12% OF THE
PRODUCTION.
AT THE NUMBER THAT I'VE SEEN --
IT'S NUMBER THAT I BELIEVE IN.
AND IF THAT IS THE CASE.
WE'RE GONNA SEE A SIGNIFICANT
COST OF LIVING INCREASE THAT IS
GOING TO HURT THE LOW INCOME
FOLKS IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND I
STRONGLY -- ENCOURAGES TO TAKE A
SECOND LOOK AT THIS BILL AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I WILL NOT BE ABLE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT MIGHT
MAYOR BRIEFLY RESPOND SURE.
YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER FLOOR
FOR YOUR YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
CONCERNS AND I SHARE.
YOUR DESIRE NOT TO SHUT DOWN THE
INDUSTRY.
I SUPPORT GOOD UNION JOBS.
BUT I THINK.
ANY KIND OF OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT.
SHOULD NOT COME AT THE EXPENSE
OF THE HEALTH OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ALL ABOUT.
ARE ONLY TRYING TO PROTECT THE
MOST VULNERABLE OF CALIFORNIANS
BY BY HAVING A MINIMUM SET BACK
JUST TO GIVE YOU A CLEAR.
YOU KNOW -- IDEA OF WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE THERE ARE
OTHER COMMUNITIES INCLUDING OUR
FAVORITE STATE OF TEXAS.
THE CITY OF DALLAS HAS A FIFTEEN
HUNDRED FOOT.
OIL DRILLING SET BACKFROM THE
SENSITIVE POPULATIONS THAT WERE
TRYING TO PROTECT.
HOUSING SCHOOLS FAITH
INSTITUTIONS.
THIS IS NOT A RADICAL IDEA WE'RE
JUST TRYING TO PROTECT.
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
DOES THAT NEED MEDICAL CARE.
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
SO I'M NOT TRYING TO SHUT DOWN
THIS INDUSTRY I'VE NEVER TALKED
ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN THIS
INDUSTRY AND I'VE ALWAYS I HAVE
A STRONG RECORD.
THE SUPPORTING GOOD UNION JOBS.
BUT THE DEVELOPMENT OF OIL AND
GAS SHOULD NOT COME AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AND THAT IS WHAT I'M
PROPOSING HERE A MINIMUM SET
BACK. TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
OKAY -- ZOOM MISTER MAYOR SU CHI --
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO ASK YOUR
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON LANGUAGE THAT DEALS WITH
VARIANCES AND POSSIBLY ALSO WITH
WHAT IS CONSIDERED TO BE A NEW
WELL BECAUSE I THINK THAT ONE OF
THE POINTS OF THE CAN.
OF CONTENTION IS.
ON WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT IS NEW --
OPERATIONS AND WHAT ISN'T BUT
ALSO YOU KNOW THE THE IDEA THAT
IF A WELL CAN DEMONSTRATE THAT
IT CAN OPERATE -- SAFELY AND
WITHOUT TREMENDOUS AIR QUALITY
ISSUES BECAUSE THERE ARE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF WELLS IS THIS
FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF OIL
THERE'S DIFFERENT APPS.
THAT THERE BE A ROBUST VARIANCE --
PROCEDURE THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
FOLLOW DO YOU ARE WHAT YOU WOULD
YOU WOULD YOU AGREE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT LANGUAGE OF
COURSE.
OKAY THANK YOU AND I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION.
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
WELL IT WILL ACTIVITIES AND
WE'RE NOT -- GIVEN THE AMOUNT
AND EVEN THE GROWTH OF OIL
EXPLORATION IN URBAN AREAS AND
COMMUNITIES ARE RIGHTFULLY
CONCERNED SO I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
CONNECTS I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU I APPRECIATE TO
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE I JUST WANT
TO EMPHASIZE.
YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL THAT --
THE OPPOSING WITNESSES INDICATED
THAT WE WERE.
PROCEEDING WITH THIS BILL
RECKLESSLY WALLOW IN FACT.
YOU KNOW I ASKED MY STAFF TO
PRINT OUT.
THE SAME COPY THAT -- THE
REPRESENTED FROM THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
REFERENCE THE FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REPORT.
FROM THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND IN THEIR CONCLUSION THEY
RECOMMEND THAT LOS ANGELES
COUNTY EXPANDING THE MINIMAL SET
BACK.
DISTANCE THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS
BEYOND THREE HUNDRED FEET
BECAUSE OF SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
INDICATING THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY IMPLICATIONS.
AGAIN I WOULD EMPHASIZE ALSO
THAT WE ARE BEHIND THE CITY OF
TO RELEASE SOME COMMUNITIES IN
THE CITY OF TEXAS IN TERMS OF
HAVING A MINIMUM SET BACK. TO
PROTECT CHILDREN [inaudible]
SENIORS FAMILIES.
WHERE OIL DRILLING IS CURRENTLY
TAKING PLACE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE BACKYARDS IN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS NEAR SCHOOLS?
NEAR PLAYGROUNDS NEAR HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
PROPOSAL.
AND I ASK.
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. TO
ENGAGE IN THIS CONVERSATION
[inaudible]
THAT.
AS WE PROCEED.
TOWARD OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO HAVE SOME COMMON SENSE
CONVERSATIONS AS TO ALLOWING THE
INDUSTRY TO GO FORWARD BUT WOULD
NOT AT THE EXPENSE.
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY.
OF OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
AND FOR THAT REASON I ASK FOR
HIS SUPPORT FOR A BI.
THREE FOUR FIVE THANK YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WAIVER ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
ITEM FIVE AB THREE FORTY FIVE BY
A MEMBER MURATSUCHI THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
I'VE FLORA.
CHAU EGGMAN GARCIA.
GARCIA I LOW MOAN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE HI READ THROUGH
G. AYE STONE. FOUR ONE THANK YOU
FOR ONE LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
MR DAILY YOU ARE UP.
WITH.
AB.
ELEVEN SIXTY MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AYE.
GLAD YOU GOT THE EASY BILLS ON
THE WAY NOW FOR THE
CONTROVERSIAL ONES WOULD BE HERE
WHILE.
THE AB ELEVEN SIX I JUST WANTED.
TELL YOU IS WE HAVE TIMBER
HARVEST PLANS WHICH YOU GO OUT
YOU JIM TO TEMPER OURS PLAN YOU
GO HARVESTER TIMBER.
WE HAVE SUSTAIN YOU'LL UNITS
WHICH ARE A TEN YEAR TIME FRAME
TO DO.
YOUR WORK IN AS YOU GO IN AND
OUT WHEN YOU NEED.
TO DUE TO THE FIRE REGIMES AND
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING IN THIS
BILL IS SIMPLY -- TO GO FROM TEN
YEARS TO TWENTY YEARS.
THEY'VE BEEN -- AT THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY THEY'VE BEEN ASKED AND
THAT NEVER BEEN DENIED TO DO IT
A TWENTY YOUR PROGRAM AND SELL
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
JUST EXTEND THAT.
TEN TO TWENTY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY BUT I HAVE A COUPLE
WITNESSES WITH ME THIS AND I WAS
SURE ALSO WITH YOU THAT -- THESE
BILLS -- THESE PROJECTS ARE ALL
OF MY DISTRICT SO FAR THERE'S
NONE OTHER IN THE REST THE STATE
SO THIS IS ALMOST LIKE A
DISTRICT BILL BUT WOULD.
LOVE TO HAVE YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JEFF PUBLICLY --
MAJI FORSTER FOR W. M. BEATTY
ASSOCIATE SOME LICENSE FOR STERN
CITY CALIFORNIA.
OUR COMPANY MANAGES TO ARE THE
THREE CURRENT SUSTAIN YOU'LL
PLANTS IN THE STATE.
BOBBY GOT OUR FIRST PLANS
APPROVED IN THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND ONE IT'S A TEN YEAR
PLANS WE HAD TO GO THROUGH THE
RENEWAL PROCESS IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE RENEWAL
PROCESS WAS MORE OF AN APPROVAL
PROCESS IN OF THE RENEWAL -- IT
WAS A FULL REVIEW -- ALL THE
REVIEWING AGENCIES AND EVEN
THOUGH.
OUR SIXTEEN YEAR PLANS WERE IN
FULL COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAWS
THAT REVIEW STILL TOOK.
NOT NINE MONTHS. FOR A RENEWAL
OF THE PLAN THAT'S IN COMPLIANCE.
CALPERS AND CHARGED WITH
MONITORING COMPLIANCE WITH THE
EFFECTIVENESS [inaudible]
AND THE RELIANCE IT HERE'S TO
THE RULES. FOR THE SUSTAIN YOUR
PLANS -- AND THAT'S REVIEWED
ABOUT SIX TIMES A YEAR OF THE
FILE TIMBER HARVEST PLANS UNDER
THE SUSTAIN YOU'LL PLAN SO THAT
THE SUSTAIN YOUR PLAN IS UNDER.
CONSTANT MONITORING BUT NOT ONLY
CAL FIRE BUT DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE WATER QUALITY --
CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC SERVICES AND
ALSO THE GENERAL PUBLIC THEY
REVIEW OUR PLANS AS WELL.
ALREADY IN STATUTE IS A IS A OF
A LAW THAT SAYS YOU CAN'T HAVE
DATA IN ASSISTING YOU'LL PLANTS
OLDER THAN TEN YEARS OLD.
SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS
TO STAY IN YOUR PLAN.
HAVE A TWENTY YEAR LIFESPAN AND
AT THE MID POINT AT TEN YEARS
YOU DO AN UPDATE.
THIS TOMORROW HELP MONITOR
COMPLIANCE MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
OVER CUT IN THE FOREST.
AND OTHER THAN THAT IT'S
MONITORED.
SEVERAL TIMES YEAR THE CHEESE
PEER REVIEW PROCESS.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
WHERE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY WOULD EXTEND THE
LIFE OF A SUSTAIN YOUR PLAN FROM
TEN TO TWENTY YEARS -- AND THIS
IS DANIEL PLAN IS JUST ONE OF
THE MECHANISMS THAT TIMBERLAND
OWNERS CAN USE TO SHOW THAT
THEY'RE OPERATINGIN A
SUSTAINABLE FASHION -- THE S. Y.
P. HAS TO INCLUDE PROJECTIONS
SEPTEMBER GROWTH AND HARVESTING
OVER A HUNDRED YEAR LONGER.
PLANNING HORIZON -- HAS TO
INCLUDE ASSESSMENT OF WATERSHED
WILDLIFE RESOURCES AS WELL AS
CONSTRAINTS OF OTHER RESOURCES.
RESOURCE VALUES ON TIMBER
PRODUCTION -- THE ISSUES THE
ADEQUATELY COVERED IN AN
APPROVED AS Y. P. MAY THEN BE
ADDRESSED AN INDIVIDUAL TIMBER
HARVEST PLANS BY REFERENCING THE
S. Y. P..
FOLLOWING APPROVAL AGAIN THAT'S
WHY PEAS AND FORCE FOR TEN YEARS
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU THERE IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO HELP SORRY MADAM
CHAIR CHRISTMAS KELLY ON BEHALF
OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANIES ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
GOT WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE OF
THE FOREST PRODUCTS INDUSTRY
INCLUDING THE CARPENTERS AND
MACHINISTS WOULD.
AND PAPER WORKERS POPE WORKERS
AND SEVERAL OTHER UNIONS IN
SUPPORT ASK ANYONE IS IN SUPPORT
TO COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
OVER HERE WHICH WILL HAVE UP IN
A MOMENT.
AND JUST VOICE YOUR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TAYLOR
RUSH WITH A CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN SUPPORT.
HEY THERE IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL.
IS THERE ANYBODY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK.
AND THE OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
OKAY WITH THAT MAYBE ROLL CALL
PLEASE ITEM FOURTEEN AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE MEMBER DOLLY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA CHAU EGGMAN GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN.
MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ BROUGHT TO TREAT.
RIGHT TO TO NOT VOTING.
STONE. TWO ZERO EIGHT TWO ZERO
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE -- THANK
YOU THANK YOU -- MISTER BLOOM
YOUR HERE WITH THE BE A FIFTEEN
ELEVEN I JUST FOR THOSE WHO
WEREN'TIN THE ROOM WE'RE GOING
TO BE GIVING ALL OF THOSE WHO
ARE TESTIFYING OF OF FOUR
AGAINST BILLS. TWO MINUTES
APIECE.
THANK YOU.
TERRIFIC GOD GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
PRESENTING AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN
WHICH WOULD UPDATE THE STATUES
STATUTES GOVERNING THE SANTA
MONICA.
WE HAVE SOME STATUTES THERE --
TOO GOVERNING THE SANTA MONICA
RIGHT IN THE WE GET A LAUGH
SANTA MONICA BAY RESTORATION
COMMISSION REPLACING THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD AS
THE AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT WITH THE
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN ALSO REVISES
THE PURPOSE OF THE COMMISSION
GIVING IT NEW GOALS RELATED TO
THE RESTORATION AND ENHANCEMENT
OF THE SANTA MONICA BANDITS
WATERSHED.
THE COMMISSION IS A NON
REGULATORY BODY THAT ADOPTED AND
UPDATED THE SANTA MONICA BAY
RESTORATION PLAN IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT PLAN WHICH
IS NOW CALLED THE SANTA MONICA
BAY RESTORATION PLAN DEVELOPED.
NEW GOALS AND OBJECTIVES FOR THE
PROTECTION OF THE BAY.
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN WILL ALIGN THE
PURPOSE OF THE COMMISSION WITH
THESE NEW GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
THAT INCLUDE PROTECTION AND
IMPROVEMENT OF THE ECOSYSTEM OF
THE BAY.
ENHANCEMENT OF ITS SOCIO
ECONOMIC BENEFITS AND
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE MONITORING
AND ASSESSMENT OF ACTIONS TAKEN
TO ENHANCE THE BAY.
AS THE COMMISSION IS WORK TO
IMPLEMENT THE RESTORATION PLAN
THE STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
HAS PROVIDED IT WITH ASSISTANCE
FOR GRANTS AND OTHER FORMS OF
SUPPORT.
THE REVISED PURPOSE AND GOALS OF
THE COMMISSION CREATE A NATURAL
ALIGNMENT WITH THE ROLE OF THE
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY.
A MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN THE COMMISSION THE
CALIFORNIA OF OUR MIDDLE
PROTECTION AGENCY THE NATURAL
AND THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
WILL BE UPDATED. TO INCLUDE THE
STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY IN
ORDER TO INSURE CONTINUING
COORDINATION BETWEEN THESE
AGENCIES.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
ALTER THECOMMISSION'S
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE NOR DOES IT
CHANGE THE PUBLIC PROCESS THAT
IS CURRENTLY UNDER WAY TO
ADDRESS THE STRUCTURE.
IT SIMPLY REPLACES THE STATE
AGENCY THAT IS CHARGED WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL'S TOM FORD
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BAY FOUNDATION MOVE THE BILL.
THIS IN MOTION SECOND BUT IF
YOU'D LIKE TO ADD ANYTHING.
SURE THAT -- THE ONE OTHER THING
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT IS IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN NEW
ACTION PLAN WAS APPROVED BY THE
GOVERNING BOARD OF THE SANTA
MONICA BAY RESTORATION
COMMISSION.
WHICH REALIGNED SOME OF OUR
PRIORITIES WE HAVE ONLY FORTY
FOUR ACTIONS -- TO TRY TO
COMPLETE IN ORDER TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH OF THE BAY THE BENEFITS --
TO THE RESIDENTS OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND TO THE WILDLIFE AND
THOSE NEW -- GOALS MORE DUE TO
MORE CLOSELY ALIGN -- WITH THE
GOALS IN THE STRATEGIC PLAN OF
THE STATE BECAUSE THE
CONSERVANCY SO IT'S A VERY
TIMELY ISSUE FOR US -- I NEED TO
THANK THE STATE.
WATER BOARD FOR ALL OF ITS
SUPPORT OVER MANY MANY YEARS THE
WATER QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE'VE LABORED -- FOR ARE
STARTING TO PAY OFF FOR SIDE TO
SEE THOSE VALUES AND IT'S NOW
TIME FOR US TO MOVE ON TO
INCREASE -- VISITOR SHIPPED TO
THE COAST LINE TO INCREASE
PROTECTION AND RESTORATION OF
THE COASTLINE AND TO GET
OURSELVES READY -- WITH CLIMATE
RESILIENCE AND ADAPTATION
PLANNING ALL OF WHICH WE FIND TO
FIND A GREAT DEAL OF TALENT AND
SUPPORT WITHIN STATE BECAUSE
CONSERVANCY.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE HER SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
OKAY IS THERE ANYBODY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
OKAY YOU CAN COME OVER TO THE
TABLE IN TWO MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS A MULTILATERAL
REPRESENTED BY WHAT LET'S LAND
TRUST.
WE WOULD EAGERLY SUPPORT -- NEW
LEGISLATION FOR THE SANTA MONICA
RESTORATION COMMISSION.
IT WAS BASED ON THE MORE
CONFERENCE A ROADMAP THAT WE
WERE PROMISED TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO -- WHAT WE THAT WE
STILL DON'T HAVE I?
DISAGREE WITH THE NOTION THAT
THIS DOESN'T ALTER THE PUBLIC
PROCESS ON THE COMMENTS OF
MISTER FOR JUST MADE HE'S NEVER
ACTUALLY.
MADE PUBLICLY TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMISSION -- ORGANIZATIONS
A MEMBER OF THE WATERSHED
ADVISORY COUNCIL WE'VE NEVER.
IN IN THE SIX YEARS THAT I'VE
BEEN REGULARLY ATTENDING
MEETINGS.
I'M NOT HEARD A SINGLE COMMENT --
OF CONCERN ABOUT CONTINUE WITH
THE WATER BOARD THE NEW ACTION
PLAN DOES NOT.
SIGNIFICANTLY REALIGN THE
COMMISSION.
I THINK THERE ARE MANY ISSUES --
I THINK SURE THEIR ADVANTAGES TO
RE HOUSING IT WITH THE
CONSERVANCY THEY'RE ALSO
DISADVANTAGED.
EXCUSE ME DISADVANTAGES THE
WATER BOARD HAS A REGIONAL
STRUCTURE THAT HAS A LOCAL.
A REGIONAL WATER BOARD -- THAT
WE CAN GO TO MEETINGS EVERY
MONTH THEY'VE GOT OFFICES THERE
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S TRUE THE
CONSERVANCY.
AND WE SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL ADVANTAGES AND
DISADVANTAGES OF ALL THE OPTIONS
ON THE TABLE WHICH IS WHAT THE
PUBLIC PROCESS WAS SUPPOSED TO
DO.
RATHER THAN HAVING HEARD IT DOWN
TO ONLY THE PERCEIVED ADVANTAGES
OF ONE OPTION.
SO IN AN IDEAL SITUATION I'D ASK
YOU TO TO PUT THIS ON ON HOLD
FOR AWHILE IT SEEMS PREMATURE TO
GET THE ROADMAP.
ARM MORE REALISTICALLY GIVEN THE
TIME OF THE DAY -- WHAT I WOULD
ASK IS A COMMITMENT FROM THE
MEMBER? TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS NOT JUST THE BAY
FOUNDATION BUT ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
TO FINISH THIS PUBLIC PROCESS
AND I KNOW THAT WHEN THE
COMMISSION WAS CREATED WAS A TWO
STEP PROCESS SB.
FIFTY SEVEN SIMPLY ASK FOR MORE
INFORMATION.
AND THAT WAS GIVEN IN A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THEN THAT
BECAME SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY ONE
WHICH CREATED.
THE ARE SIMILAR TO BE
RESTORATION COMMISSION I WOULD
HAVE TIME TO GO INTO MORE
DETAILS BUT THERE'S THERE'S A
LOT TO TALK ABOUT THERE'S DIDN'T
THE NOMINATION PAPERS NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH EXPLAINED WHY
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
WAS SELECTED AS THE HOSTING
AGENCY.
BEFORE WE GO TINKERING WITH THIS
WE REALLY OUGHT TO HAVE.
STE PUBLIC DISCUSSION.
AND AGAIN THEY JUST HAD A SURVEY
YOU CAN WRAP UP I WILL.
LITERALLY JUST FILLED OUT A
SURVEY WITH FORTY RESPONDENTS
NOT A SINGLE RESPONSE RAISE THIS
ISSUE IT'S JUST IT'S NEVER EVER
BEEN RAISED IN A SINGLE MEETING.
WE FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS BY
HAPPENSTANCE IT'S IT'S JUST
WASN'T COMMUNICATED SO I WHAT I
WOULD ASK DISAPPOINTED AS A
COMMITMENT FROM THEM TO BE
AUTHOR.
OUR TOWARD MORE CLOSELY WITH
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS I THINK
THAT'S THE BEST ALL OF GET THEM
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS OR ANYBODY ELSE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL.
OKAY SIGNAL RETURNED TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
READY.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- TO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR FOR YOUR VOTE ON THIS --
MEASURE THAT -- THE BILL'S GOING
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S A MORE
EFFECTIVE APPROACH FOR THE
SUPPORT AN IMPROVEMENT OF SANTA
MONICA BAY -- I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS
ASKED OF ME TO CONSIDER MOVING.
THE COMMISSION TO THE NATURAL
SOURCES AGENCY AND GOING FORWARD
HI I DO COMMIT TO WORKING WITH
THE STATE WATER BOARD IN THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY AT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LEVEL TO SEE IF
WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT CAN
WE ROLL CALL PLEASE BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
I AM TWENTY THREE A. B. FIFTEEN
ELEVEN BY MEMBER BLOOM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA CHAU EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA ISLA MON.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MURATSUCHI ROAD TO GI STONE. SIX
ZERO SIX ZERO THANK YOU THANK
YOU IS MR LEVINE HERE.
I DO NOT SEE SO MISTER COOPER.
WE ARE UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB
ONE TWENTY SIX MAKES
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT TO MAKE
CLEAN VEHICLES MORE SENSIBLE TO
A GREATER NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS.
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL INCREASES
REBATE LEVELS BY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS.
AND LIMIT ELIGIBILITY FOR HIGH
INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
THESE IMPROVEMENTS TO THE CV RPG
WERE ORIGINALLY PROPOSED MY BILL
AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY FOUR ERROL
SMEDLEY ADOPTED TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH A ONE YEAR
SUNSET.
AB SIXTEEN FIFTEEN FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CONTINUE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENTS FOR ANOTHER TWO
YEARS UNFORTUNATELY.
WAS IMPROVEMENTS EXPIRED
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR.
AB ONE TO ONE TWENTY SIX WILL
CONTINUE THE CRP PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENTS TO HELP MEET THE
GOAL OF REACHING MORE.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES BY BOTH
THE REBATE LEVEL FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AB ONE TWENTY SIX
WILL MAKE THE VEHICLES MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO CALIFORNIA DRIVERS
LIVING COMMUNITIES WITH POOR AIR
QUALITY.
MOVE THE BILL.
MISTER WHO ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS YES I AM
OKAY THANK YOU -- AND YOUR
WITNESS AND SUPPORT HIGH SOON.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON -- MANAGER
MEMBERS BILL TOGETHER WITH
COLORS FOR CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL ESPECIALLY WITH THE
INCORPORATION OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WILL MAKE THE CLEAN
VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT BOTH MORE
EFFECTIVE.
AND MORE EQUITABLE -- WE HAD A
LOT OF SUCCESS IN CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC VEHICLES ARE SELLING
MUCH MORE THAN EVER.
BUT THE DOWNSIDE OF THAT IS
THERE'S LESS REBATE MONEY TO GO
AROUND SO WE NEED TO FOCUS THOSE
REBATES IN THE PLACES WHERE THE
MAKE THE MOST DIFFERENCE AND AS
MISTER COOPER HAS SAID.
THAT HE IS WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
LESS AFFLUENT.
AND SO BY HAVING THE INCOME CAP
WE RESERVE THOSE REBATES FOR THE
PEOPLE FOR WHOM THEY WILL MAKE
THE MOST DIFFERENCE.
AND THAT WAY WE CONTINUE TO
EXPAND THE ELECTRIC FIELD
VEHICLE MARKET AND DO IT IN THE
MOST EQUITABLE MANNER SO WE'RE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL -- PLEASE COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE.
CAN THE SERGEANTS PLEASE WITH
THE MICROPHONE UP FOR THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU.
IF YOU JUST COME UP IS AND GIVE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND WHETHER YOU'RE IN SUPPORT.
BOTTOM FACILITY -- POLICY
DIRECTOR COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT TIME ALSO --
CHAIR OF THE STEERING COMMITTEE
OF A CHARGE AT TE CALIFORNIA.
I CAMPAIGN I JUST WANNA SAY THAT
OF MAKING THESE PROGRAMS COST
EFFECTIVE IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES SO LOWER INCOME CAP --
WOULD GO A LONG WAY AND ALSO --
I THINK INTRODUCING MORE RANGE.
AND ALSO -- NOT HAVING EXCEPTION
FOR FUEL CELLS I THINK IS
IMPORTANT.
AS ALWAYS SUPPORT -- THIS BILL
AND WE ALSO WHEN ENCOURAGE A
EVERY SOURCE BOARD.
TO COME UP WITH THE REPORT SO WE
HAVE MORE DATA TO ANALYZE ON CBS
THANK YOU THANK YOU YEAH SO JUST
FOR THEM SUPPORTERS JUST NAME
AFFILIATION BUT THESE.
THANK YOU CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA
CRIED WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ALSO A MEMBER OF
CHARGE AHEAD CALIFORNIA HERE IN
SUPPORT WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS THANK.
HELLO KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF
OF VALLEY CLEAN AIR NOW IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE -- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
NOBODY OKAY WE HAD A MOTION I
BELIEVE.
AND DO WE HAVE A SECOND.
I HAVE A MOTION A SECOND HOMES
GARCIA WE HAVE I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH US IN TAKING THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M VERY HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR FORWARD.
THANK YOU THEY WILL CALL FOR
THIS ITEM THREE AB ONE TWENTY
SIX REMEMBER COOPER THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA CHAU EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY RIGHT MCCARTY
AYE MELINDA'S.
ROSTER. TWO THREE AYE STONE. SIX
ZERO SIX ZERO BILLS OUT THANK
YOU WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER AUTHORS.
OKAY MS EGGMAN WHO THE WINNER.
HER HAND WAS UP FIRST.
I CAN DO THAT.
IF YOU DO WE ARE HERE OKAY. FOR
THIS.
TO THIS IS FOR AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS AND MADAM CHAIR.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE WERE TO
STEPS TO CALIFORNIA RECYCLING
MARKET DEVELOPMENT ACT WHICH
SEEKS TO BALANCE CALIFORNIA'S
AMBITIOUS ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION GOALS.
WITH THE CHANGING MARKET
REALITIES ARE STATES TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION GOAL OF 75% IS RAPIDLY
APPROACHING MEANWHILE AFTER
IMPLEMENTING ITS NATIONAL SORT
POLICY WAS STRICT CONTAMINATION
LEVEL CAPS.
CHINA AS WE KNOW IS NOW REFUSING
TO ACCEPT MOST OF OUR RECYCLED
MATERIAL THE RESULT OF THIS MUCH
IS WHAT WE LIKE TO CALL RECYCLE
MATERIAL IS NOW SITTING IN A
LANDFILL -- ALSO CAUSING
PROBLEMS I CAN TELL YOU MEMBERS
BEFORE I CAME DOWN UP 2%.
THERE IS A THREE ALARM FIRE AT
THE PORT OF STOCKTON AT A
RECYCLING CENTER THAT IS OVER
PILED WITH PLASTICS AND PAPER --
AND OTHER KINDS OF WASTE THIS IS
EXACTLY THE KIND OF THING THAT
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS AS
WE'RE GOING FORWARD.
WE KNOW THAT'S A PROBLEM NOW
THERE'S NO MARKET AND SO IT IS
BEING STOCKPILE THINGS THAT WE
THOUGHT WERE RECYCLE ARE NOW
SITTING AROUND.
AND CATCHING ON FIRE -- IF WE'RE
SERIOUS ABOUT FIXING THE PROBLEM
THAT WE NEED TO START ADDRESSING
RECYCLE RECYCLING
COMPREHENSIVELY.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO RESPOND TO
THE CONTAMINATION LEVELS OF OUR
RECYCLED EXPORTS WE HAVE TO LOOK
BACK EVEN FURTHER.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHT THREE SIX TO DO
THAT.
BY LOOKING AT NEARLY EVERY
ASPECT OF RECYCLING FROM PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND CURBSIDE RECYCLING
PROGRAMS TO MARKET DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TECHNOLOGY
INCENTIVES WITH ME TODAY I HAVE.
NICK LAPIS WITH A CALIFORNIA
AGAINST WASTE MARK PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES AND
JOHN KENNEDY WAS RULE COUNTY
REPRESENT AS OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES A PIECE
PLEASE.
CAPTION IN A CLASS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
WE'VE HAD A REALLY SUCCESSFUL --
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPING CALIFORNIA OVER THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS BUT A LOT OF
THAT HAS RELIED ON SENDING
RECYCLES OVERSEAS.
NOW THAT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
HAS SAID THAT THEY NO LONGER
WANT MANY OF OUR CYCLES.
AND OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
FOLLOWING SUIT.
IT'S ON ONE HAND A SORT OF
EXISTENTIAL RISK FOR THE
RECYCLING INDUSTRY BECAUSE SO
MUCH -- WE RECYCLED NO LONGER AS
MARKETS BUT THE SAME TIME IT'S
AN OPPORTUNITY.
AND THIS BILL REINVESTED
RECYCLING IN CALIFORNIA -- AND
KEEPS EXPANDING RECYCLING TO
INCLUDE COPPER.
COMPOSTING ORGANICS AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
FOR HER LEADERSHIP.
IN THIS AREA I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
FOR THE COMMITTEE THAT YOU HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE SOLID
WASTE INDUSTRY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE. TO MY KNOWLEDGE
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE AND I THINK THAT THE
FACT THAT THESE THREE SECTORS.
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR HANDLING
SOLID WASTE AND PROMOTING SOLID
WASTE AND RECYCLING POLICY ARE
ALL HERE UNIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE?
I CANNOT I CANNOT.
OVER STATE THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
CHINA SOARED WE DO NOT HAVE
ADEQUATE CAPACITY IN THE
CALIFORNIA. FOR PURPOSES OF NOT
ONLY PROCESSING SOLID WASTE BUT
FINDING A HOME FOR RECYCLED
MATERIAL ONCE IT HAS BEEN
PROCESSED WE THEREFORE ASK AND
JR AYE VOTE.
HELLO JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
WE SEE IT AS A VITAL TOOL TO
HELP US COMPLY WORK TO ADDRESS
NATIONAL SORT AND COMPLY WITH SB --
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE PASSED
A COUPLE YEARS AGO -- THE
REQUIRES THE STATE TO DIVERT 75%
ORGANIC WASTE FROM LANDFILLS BY --
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE'RE HAVING
A REALLY HARD TIME DOING THAT
AND CAL RECYCLE SAYS THAT COULD
COST UP TO TWENTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS.
EVEN AFTER SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS AND PUT -- PROPOSED
BENEFITS THAT COULD STILL BE
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR SO IN ADDITION TO
THESE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS REALLY
HELPING TO CHEN UP AND IN STATE
RECYCLING PROGRAM. TO DEAL WITH
NATIONAL SOARED WE THINK THE
ORGANIC WASTE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
WILL ALSO GO A LONG WAY TO
HELPING US MEET OUR THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE REQUIREMENTS.
SO WE'RE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BOOK FOR TWO OTHER WAYS TO
HELP -- THESE RECYCLING
FACILITIES PENCIL OUT AND CREATE
MORE JOBS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S REALLY A WIN TO
ADDRESS NATIONAL SOARED A WIN TO
ADDRESS -- HELP LOCALS ADDRESS
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING AND
BRING JOBS TO THE STATE SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO CONVEY --
SEE SACKS SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
AS WELL.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
BUT IN CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MALANA
BEHOFF OF THREE SECTORS ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION --
CLEAN CITIES COALITION AND ALSO
THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS THAT PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT TO THESE HIS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS TO THE
AUTHOR.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WE GET CONSERVATION
VOTERS AND SUPPORT I WANT TO
THANK SOME MEMBER EGGMAN FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
LARA COMMON BE HAVE A SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
JEFF KNEW JAY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF BLADE JOHNSON HERE ABOUT
STATES AS A FEW ON MARCH HERE IN
SOUTH SUPPORT.
FIGURES FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO
VOICE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
OKAY SING NOT A RETURN TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS MISTER
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
THANK YOU I'M I WILL BE IN A
MOTION THAT.
OKAY MOTORCYCLE.
SO YES I'M -- SUPPORTERS BILL OF
COURSE I'M A CO AUTHOR AND I
CAN'T THINK OF ANY ISSUE THAT WE
COULD BE TALKING ABOUT TODAY ON
EARTH DAY.
OF COURSE.
SUCH AS THE RECYCLING AND WASTE --
CRISIS WERE FACING CALIFORNIAN
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY I KNOW THIS
IS THE POLICY COMMITTEE OR MY
MULLIN RACING THAT TODAY LIKE
LIKE WE ARE LOOKS LIKE.
BUT I WANTED TO MAYBE IF YOUR
SPONSOR COULD TALK ABOUT THE
INCENTIVE PEACE AND HOW.
THAT WOULD PLAY OUT AND HOW THAT
WOULD WORK WITH EXISTING -- YOU
KNOW KIDS CONSUMER -- BASICALLY
APPLICATION TO THAT OR HOW OR
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT FOR IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA ATTEMPT TO MAKE
THAT ALL [inaudible]
CANCEL OUT.
I THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION SO
WHAT WE'RE HAVING ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE THREE
SECTORS REPRESENTED HERE.
SIR FIGURE OUT WHAT THE BEST WAY
IS TO FIND THAT CENTER PROGRAMS.
WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED I
THINK WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE HOW TO
SPEND THE MONEY -- THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
HOW TO GENERATE THE MONEY --
GINGER AFTER BEING ONE A
LANDFILL TIP FEES AND OTHER A
GENERATOR CHARGE AS YOU'RE WELL
AWARE ALL THOSE OPTIONS HAVE --
AND TALKED ABOUT OVER THE YEARS
WHAT WE'RE HAVING A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOALS TO REACH
A CONSENSUS AMONG ALL INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
WITH SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY
AGREES ON OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
NO I REALLY APPRECIATE BRING
THIS BILL FORD I'M VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY.
IN A SECOND WEBER ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ITEM TWENTY FIVE ALWAYS ARE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'M SO
SORRY GOOD JUST JUST THE TO
THINK EVERYBODY IN THE COALITION
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR A
COUPLE YEARS NOW AND IN.
A CLEARLY YOU CAN SEE WITH A LOT
OF PEOPLE THE TABLE AND CONTINUE
TO WORK OUT SOME OF THE SMALLER
DETAILS -- BUT EVERYONE AGREES
IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM AND BROKEN.
WE GOT A TACTLESS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY WITH THAT --
ROLL CALL PLEASE I DON'T TWENTY
FIVE A. B. FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE
BY MEMBER EGGMAN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
CHAU.
EGGMAN BY EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA ISLA MON.
MATHIS -- MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
THE I. MELINDA'S WROTE TO CHEAT.
READ THROUGH THREE AYE STONE.
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO YOUR BILL
WITHOUT.
THE ROLE OPEN.
NEXT ON THE LIST I HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
WELL I'M HERE I DO HAVE A
SWIMMER GARCIA GARCIA IS BILL
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO WAIT.
I AM PRESENTING FOR EDUARDO
GARCIA DO YOU MIND WAITING IS
NOW I HAVE FOR AUTHORS WHO ARE.
RIGHT INCHES TO GO AND YOU'RE
TRAPPED HERE SO.
THEY WERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY THIS.
HE WALKED OUT SO THEN.
NEXT I HAVE A MISTER SALAS IS
NEXT.
NO WE HAVE THE SIGN IN SHEET --
I'M SORRY I SEE I HAVE YOU
GARCIA BURKE.
THAT'S OKAY COME ON I'M SORRY.
WE FOUGHT TO GET IN HERE FOR HER
SO I THOUGHT YOU.
AND REGARDS HERE OKAY.
I BEG YOUR PARTY'S MY
DOPPELGANGER OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
AND MY FOR MYSELF OKAY -- OKAY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR
GUYS HERE I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB.
FIFTY SIX BEFORE I BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- THAT REMOVES THE
ANY OTHER DUTIES AS THE FIND
FUNCTION OF THE AUTHORITY AND
MAKE THE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES
IN FACT ON BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR
WE WILL COMMIT TO FURTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL -- CLARIFY
THE PC PRESIDENT WILL RECUSANT
THEMSELVES FROM ANY AUTHORITY
DECISIONS REGARDING PROCUREMENT
AND ADDRESS THE APPROPRIATE
RECOVERY OF AUTHORITY
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
AB FIFTY SIX WILL ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT NO ONE DISAGREES WITH
THE NATURE OF ENERGY PROCUREMENT
IN CALIFORNIA HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED.
CURRENTLY IN THERE IS AN ISSUE
WITH OUR GREAT FOR ANY REASON
THE STATE IS LEFT WITH LITTLE
RECOURSE OUR OPTIONS TO ALLOWED
US TO ACT QUICKLY.
AB FIFTY SIX GIVES THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATE
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY IN ADVANCE
TRANSPORTATION FINANCING
AUTHORITY TO PROCURE POWER. TO
MEET THE STATE'S CLIMATE CLEAN
ENERGY AND RELIABILITY GOALS.
THIS NEW AUTHORITY ALREADY EXIST
AT THE PC -- THIS BILL SIMPLY
EXPAND IT TO A STATE CONTROLLED
ENTITY THIS BILL WILL NOT
INTERFERE AT ALL WITH
PROCUREMENT AS IT CURRENTLY
HAPPENS BY THOSE SERVICING
ENTITIES AND IT IS NARROWLY
DEFINED TO ADDRESS SPECIFIC.
RESIDUAL GAPS IDENTIFIED BY THE
STATE.
IN FACT IF THERE ARE NO NEEDS ON
THE GRADE THE IDEAS THAT THIS
ENTITY WOULD NOT BE USED AT ALL.
AB FIFTY SIX DESIGNS THE NEW
FUNCTION OF KATE BUT TO OPERATE
LIKE A UTILITY THAT ONLY ACTS
WHEN DIRECTED ME TO BY THE STATE
AND IS SUBJECT TO STRICT STATE
OVERSIGHT.
THIS IS THE RIGHT MOVE FOR
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE HERE WITH US HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY TODAY IS NOT
FRIEDMAN FROM THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATT
FRIEDMAN I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK IN
SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTY SIX WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
ENERGY IN ADVANCE TRANSPORTATION
FINANCING AUTHORITY TO SERVE AS
A BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT ENTITY.
FOR ELECTRICITY AND RELIABILITY
PRODUCTS UNDER SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES ON BEHALF OF
RETAIL ATROCITY CUSTOMERS WITHIN
THE STATE.
THE APPROACH HERE IS DESIGNED TO
RECONCILE THE RAPID EVOLUTION OF
RETAIL ELECTRICITY MARKETS WITH
THE STATE'S CLEAN ENERGY
RESOURCE PLANNING AND
RELIABILITY POLICIES.
CAVE TO COULD SERVE AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT WOULD BE
USED TO PROVIDE VARIOUS TYPES OF
RESIDUAL ON BACKSTOP PROCUREMENT.
SUBJECT TO REVIEW AND APPROVAL
BY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE P. YOU SEE TODAY HAS
SUBSTANTIAL AUTHORITY TO ORDER
BACKSTOPS PROCUREMENT UNDER
EXISTING LAW.
YOU SEE TODAY.
MAY DIRECTOR CENTRAL BUYER TO
PROCURE RESOURCE ADEQUACY WITH
COST COLLECTED FROM ALL
CUSTOMERS.
THE P. YOU SEE MAY DIRECT THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
SATISFY SYSTEM WIDE UNMET NEED
UNDER THE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING PROGRAM WITH COST
COLLECTED FROM ALL CUSTOMERS.
AND IT MAY AUTHORIZE A VOLUNTARY
ENTITY TO CONDUCT RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD COMPLIANCE
PROCUREMENT.
IF A SMALL LOAD SERVING ENTITY
REQUEST THE OPPORTUNITY TO OPT
INTO SUCH A STRUCTURE.
AB FIFTY SIX WOULD ESSENTIALLY
CREATE A PUBLIC OPTION.
THAT ALLOWS TAKE. FIVE TO BE
SELECTED BY THE P. YOU SEE FOR
THESE PURPOSES INSTEAD OF THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL IS INTENDED
TO MODIFY OR EXPAND THE P. UC'S
EXISTING AUTHORITY UNDER ANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS.
CHANGES TO THE P. UC'S AUTHORITY
OVER RESOURCE ADEQUACY OR
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING OR
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
PROGRAM.
ARE OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT THESE
EXISTING PROGRAMS.
BUT I BELIEVE MANY OF THEIR
CRITIQUES WOULD RELATE TO
EXISTING LAW AND NOT TO WHAT IS
BEING PROPOSED IN THIS BILL AND
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS. TO CLARIFY
THAT AB FIFTY SIX DOES NOT
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF THE P. UC'S
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO ORDER
BACKSTOPS RETIREMENT.
AND DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY NEW
AUTHORITY FOR THE P. YOU SEE TO
ENGAGE IN OVERSIGHT.
OF COMMITTEE CHOICE AGGREGATORS.
OR ELECTRIC SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE TAKEN IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TODAY REFLECT
THAT COMMITMENT -- EXISTING
PROCUREMENT BACKSTOPS IN THE
STATE.
TODAY INVOLVED THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES AND THE
CALIFORNIA EYES SO AND WE THINK
THEIR REASONS FOR MOVING AWAY
FROM THESE BACKSTOPS AND TOWARDS
A PUBLIC OPTION.
THERE ARE GROWING CONCERNS ABOUT
THE INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
THEIR CREDIT CHALLENGES.
AND THE FACT THAT THERE IS A
GENERAL BELIEF THAT THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES MAY BE BEST
SUITED. TO SERVE AS WIRES ONLY
COMPANIES TO FOCUS ON THE SAFE
AND RELIABLE OPERATION OF THEIR
DISTRIBUTION AND TRANSMISSION
NETWORKS.
IN TERMS OF THE CALIFORNIA ISO.
YES ARE YOUR TIME IS UP TO YOU
CAN FINISH UP.
THANK YOU I I GUESS I'LL JUST
END BY SAYING I WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT ALTER
THE EXISTING AUTHORITY THE
COMMISSION.
AND IT PRESERVES THE AUTHORITY
OF EMERGING RETAIL PROVIDERS TO
MAKE THEIR OWN RESOURCE PLANNING
CHOICES WE THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THE CONVERSATION WITH A VARIETY
OF STAKEHOLDERS IF THE BILL
MOVES OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY THANK YOU WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
YES MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT
CARL LUNDEN HERE ABOUT THE
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE.
SPACE COULD THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION OF THE BIOMASS
INDUSTRY -- WE'RE ALSO
SUPPORTING BILLS WELL THANK YOU
PAUL PEOPLE BRIEF.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MARK A PRAYER ON
BEHALF OF CHARGE POINT A MAJOR
PROVIDER OF THE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
OKAY WILL HAVE A THREE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF YOU CAN COME TO
THE TABLE.
TAKE TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JEFF CIPHERS
VICE PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICE ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT NINETEEN LOCAL PUBLIC
CCA POWER AUTHORITIES SERVING A
POPULATION OF TEN MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS BILL IS SEEKING TO SOLVE A
REAL PROBLEM BUT AS RECOGNIZED
IN THE ASSEMBLY UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE IT NEEDS
FURTHER WORK TO GET IT RIGHT.
AND NSURE IT ISN'T JUST A POWER
GRAB BY THE CBC.
WE DO NEED TO PROTECT GRADE
RELIABILITY BUT WE NEED TO DO IN
A WAY THAT DOESN'T HARM.
A RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS CCA'S
WORK CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE MARKET STABILITY
DURING PEONIES FIRST BANKRUPTCY.
BACK THEN GAMING BY SOME ENERGY
COMPANIES CONTRIBUTED THE
BLACKOUTS AND HIGH RATES WE NOW
HAVE OPERATING CCA'S.
AND THEIR STRONG INTEREST IN
STOCKTON AND AROUND CALIFORNIA
TO EXPAND REPAIR AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS CCA'S
PROVIDE.
THE CURRENT BILL WHATEVER
CENTRAL BUYER HANDLE RESOURCE
ADEQUACY.
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS BUT WE AGREE WITH THIS
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS THAT
PROCUREMENT AUTHORITY SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON SPECIFIC UNMET NEEDS.
NOT ON QUOTE ANY OBJECTIVES
AUTHORIZED BY THE PC.
CCA'S ARE ON TRACK TO BUILD TEN
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF DIVERSE
AND WELL INTEGRATED NEW
RENEWABLE SOURCES BY.
TWENTY THIRTY SO IT MAKES NO
SENSE TO INCLUDE RENEWABLE
ENERGY OR RENEWABLE ENERGY
INTEGRATION IN THE BILL.
BUT RESOURCE ADEQUACY IS
DIFFERENT AND WE ENCOURAGE
SLIMMING THIS BILL DOWN TO FOCUS
SOLELY ON THAT MATTER.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
THE CONSTRUCTION OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY ISN'T ACCIDENTALLY
STOPPED HOWEVER BECAUSE HE SEES
ARE DEVELOPING THOSE TEN
THOUSAND MEGAWATTS FOR BOTH
ENERGY AND RESOURCE ADEQUACY.
THOSE TWO THINGS ALWAYS GO
TOGETHER IN EVERY PROJECT.
WE WOULD SUPPORT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDING THE BILL TO CREATE A
DEFAULT PROCUREMENT ENTITY FOR
RESOURCE ADEQUACY ALONE.
AND THAT INCLUDES LOCAL
RELIABILITY WE ALSO ASKED THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT NEEDS
ARE COORDINATED BETWEEN ENERGY
COMMISSION THE I SO IN THE PC.
AND TO CONTINUE ALLOWING
ELECTRIC PROVIDERS TO SELF
PROVIDE RESOURCES AS THEY DO NOW.
FOR ANY SHORTCOMINGS THE CENTRAL
DEFAULT BUYER WOULD STEP IN AND
BY THE REMAINING THESE NEEDED
RESOURCES AND ASSIGN THOSE COSTS.
TO ANYONE WHO DIDN'T PARK HERE --
AND THEY WOULD DO THAT ON THE
GENERATION SIDE OF THE BILL.
SO WITH GOODS BACKSTOP
PROCUREMENT LIKE THAT WE CAN
PROTECT OUR GRADE WITHOUT
HURTING RATE PAYERS.
ENERGY JOBS WHERE THE CLIMATE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. FOR MEMBERS REBEKAH
LEE ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON WE HAVE A LOT
OF CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
IMPRINTS.
AND YET TO BE ABLE TO ANALYZE
THE AMENDMENT AS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE HOWEVER -- OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT NEED A CENTRAL BUYER
FOR PREFER RESOURCE POLICY
PROCUREMENT WING AT A CENTRAL
PLANNER TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
RETAIL PROVIDERS COME THROUGH ON
THE PROMISE TO DELIVER THE CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS OF THAT'S BEEN LAID
OUT BY THIS LEGISLATURE -- AND
WITH THESE CONCERNS WE ARE GOING
OVER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OR THE GENIE MINOR ON
BEHALF OF MARIN CLEAN ENERGY AND
SEE THE STATE'S FIRST CCA ALSO
IN OPPOSITION APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND GETS AS
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT
DO THINK THERE'S THERE'S STILL
SOME LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT'S
BROAD AND WOULD.
APPLY TO OUR PROCUREMENT
AUTONOMY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE
BRANDENBURG REPRESENTING CINEMA
CLEAN POWER WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED --
TO FOR THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS
MADE BY THE SPEAKER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JASON OCCURRED WITH THAT'LL
STAND GILBERT ROBESON'S MATH ON
BEHALF OF THE CLEAN POWER SF.
OPPOSE FOR THE SAME REASONS
ARTICULATED.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO VOICE
THEIR CONCERNS PROPOSITION COME
ON UP.
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS TO WIN THE
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
OUR PARTNERS THE LARGE SCALE
SOLAR ASSOCIATION.
AND THE AMERICAN WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CAUCUS WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
CONSIDERATION OR CONCEPTS WE
CONTINUE TO WANT TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS BILL. TO ENSURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY GET WHAT WE NEED IN
PROCUREMENT OF RENEWABLES THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE VALERIE
TRABAJOS WITH PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY WE ALSO
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF COMMENTS --
FOR CONSIDERATION AND WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS ON THE BILL --
PERHAPS NOT CONTEMPLATED EXACTLY --
IN A PRINT AS THE BILL IS TODAY
OR AS IT -- MAY BE AMENDED IN
THE FUTURE -- AFTER THIS
COMMITTEE -- PT JUSTWANTED TO
TESTIFY THAT.
WE'VE ALREADY EXPRESSED OUR CA
ARE A SUPPORT FOR ON THE CENTRAL
BUYER OPTION AT THE P. YOU SEE
IN TERMS OF RESOURCE ADEQUACY.
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS
CONVERSATION BROADENS -- THERE
ARE NUMBER OF COMPLEX ISSUES OF
P. GENIE IS OPEN TO HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS --
AND AUTHORS OF THE BILL THANK
YOU.
HEY THANK YOU WITHOUT ALL MOVE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IF ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
COMMENTS.
QUESTION.
THANK YOU -- I APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS THE WORK IN PROGRESS SO
I WILL VOTE FOR IT BUT I HAVE.
I HAVE BEEN HEARING TO THIS
CONFLICT IN.
OPINIONS ABOUT THE BILL FROM THE
CCA'S AND AND FROM THE MEMBER SO
CAN YOU MAYBE.
CLARIFY SOME OF THAT FROM ME OR
WHERE WE'RE AT AND IN FINDING
SOME COMMON GROUND THERE AND HOW
TO CEASE WILL OR WON'T BE
AFFECTED RIGHT SO -- ESTATE ADS
AS WE STATED ANY OTHER DUTIES AS
DEFINED HAS BEEN WELL WE'RE
TAKING THAT AMENDMENT ALSO THIS
DOESN'T EXPAND I THINK THAT THE
CCA'S I HAVE CCA'S IN MY OWN
DISTRICT AND SO -- AND CITIES
LIKE HAWTHORNE THAT HAVE I HAVE
ENJOYED WORKING WITH CCA'S AND
SO.
I THINK THAT THE CONCERNED
MOSTLY AT THIS POINT.
THIS DOESN'T EXPAND NY OF THE
PC'S RESPONSIBILITIES OR
AUTHORITIES OVER THE CCA'S I
THINK THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT ARE IN PLACE RIGHT NOW THAT
THIS SPECIES ARE NOT HAPPY ABOUT
HOWEVER.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THEM ON AND WE ARE
NOT TRYING TO EXPAND THAT THAT
AT THE ALREADY THIS IS REALLY
NEED TO BE USED AS A BACKSTOP --
BECAUSE WE HAVE WE DO FACE SUCH
ISSUES RIGHT NOW WITH OUR
UTILITY SYSTEM -- OKAY SO
[inaudible]
I WILL.
WAIT A I WILL FOR THE DAY BUT
BECAUSE OF THE CCA'S THAT I HAVE
IN MY DISTRICT AND THEY'RE NEAR
CCA'S THERE FOR HE NOW AND I
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO SAY.
THE LAURIE BECAUSE I SEE IT HERE
OR NOT -- AND JUST MOVING FOR
THAT THIS IS ONE OF I GUESS NOT
THE ATTITUDE THAT IN MIND I HAVE
NO PROBLEM VOTING FOR A TWO DAY --
AND I AND I TRUST THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM TO
GET THEM TO ACCOUNTABLE SPOT AND
AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT MY BILL
BUT I BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT AS
A CO AUTHOR I AM HAPPY TO COME
DOWN AND SIT WITH YOU AND KIND
OF WALK.
THROUGH SOME OF THE COMPLEXITIES
THAT I BELIEVE WERE SOME OF THE
CCA'S ISSUES AND CONCERNS RIGHT
NOW BUT THE GOAL IS NOT TO
INTERFERE WITH THEIR BUSINESS
MODEL AS IT STANDS TODAY.
OKAY -- AND AND THEN JUST MOVING
FORWARD AND AND NOT IN THIS BILL
THAT I I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE'RE HAVING DISCUSSION.
WERE ALSO HAVING A DISCUSSION
ABOUT RESOURCE ADEQUACY AND IN
THE BIGGER PICTURE US I'M NOT
ASKING YOU TO ADOPT THIS AT THIS
POINT BUT I DO THINK THAT.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE DISCUSSED AS AS WE'RE HAVING
DISCUSSIONS AND NOT EXPECTED TO
SHOW UP IN THIS BILL BUT I I DID
WANT TO BRING THAT POINT FORWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS EGGMAN.
JUST THE KIND OF THE CHIME IN
WITH DISCUSSION I KNOW THIS IS
NOT YOUR BILL AND THEN YOU ARE.
THE SECOND COMMITTEE I'VE SEEN
YOU PRIVATE.
AND AND I WOULD JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS I MADE IN THE FIRST
COMMITTEE AT THE PROBLEM IT
NEEDS TO BE SOLVED WE WE GOT TO
MAKE SURE WE GET IT RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF INPUT FROM A
LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO KNOWN NURSE ALONG
AND AND MAKE SURE IT GETS IN A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN ALL FEEL GOOD
ABOUT IT FORGETS THE FLOOR.
AND AND I APPRECIATE IT IS A
VERY BIG CONCEPT I UNDERSTAND
THAT ANY AND IT WILL TAKE TIME
AND I THINK THAT THIS AUTHOR WE
ALL KNOW WILL PUT THE TIME IN
AND WERE HOW OBVIOUSLY OUR HOUSE
OFFICES HAPPY AS LONG WHILE HE
IS NOT HERE. TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH HIM IN HIS OFFICE -- ON
THAT STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS BILL -- ARRIVES
AT A PROPER POINT.
MR MERCHANT THANK YOU.
MS BURKE I KNOW THIS IS NOT YOUR
BILL.
AND AND AND AND RIGHT I I FEEL --
THAT FOR MISTER GARCIA THAT THAT --
HE'S NOT ABLE TO TO JOIN US -- A
THE A I I AM CONCERNED THOUGH
THAT YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS THE
SECOND POLICY COMMITTEE HEARING
THAT.
THAT I'M HEARING THIS BILL.
AND YET THE CONCERNS OF THE
CCA'S.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO FEEL.
THAT THEIR CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED.
AND YOU KNOW I I I AM CONCERNED
THAT.
pTHIS COMPROMISE HAS BEEN MADE IT
STILL.
AN INFRINGEMENT ON THE CC
PROCUREMENT AUTONOMY -- AND SO I
YOU KNOW I I I FEEL THAT OF A
FOR US TO BE DOING OUR JOB AS AS
THE THE POLICY COMMITTEE AND FOR
ME ESPECIALLY AT HEARING THIS IN
THE SECOND POLICY COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THAT -- AS A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
CCA A PROCUREMENT TANAMI -- I
DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE IN VOTING
FOR THE BILL I WAS WANTED TO SEE
IF YOU CAN CHANGE MY MIND.
I I WOULD SAY THAT I THINK THE
OPPOSITION EVEN MENTION THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN OUT ANY OTHER DUTIES
AS DEFINED IN WE HAVE MADE SOME
SOME PROGRESS I THINK THE
OPPOSITION DID SAY THAT DURING
THEIR DURING THEIR REMARKS AND
SO.
I IT IS GOING TO TAKE TIME AND
WE DO ARE DEALING WITH A FEW
CHALLENGES BUT WE ARE MOVING WE
ARE MOVING ACTUALLY I BELIEVE IN
A DIRECTION.
THAT I HOPE WE ARE HOPING AT
SOME POINT THE CCA'S WILL BE
COMFORTABLE WITH BUT WE ARE WE
HAVE MOVED WE HAVE HAD SOME
POSITIVE MOTION JUST SO THAT
YOU'RE AWARE AND I WAS AWARE OF
YOUR CONCERNS IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE -- AND WE TOOK THE
AMENDMENTS IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
START TO ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS AND I WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK TOWARDS THAT.
MAY I ASK THE CCA FOR THEIR
WHEAT WHICH YOU WERE.
YEAH YOU CONFIDENT THAT THIS IS
A YEAR YOU'RE GOING TO GET.
TO NO I'M NOT ALTHOUGH I DO
WELCOME.
THE OTHER IN THE SPONSOR -- AND
AND WAS CRISTINA GARCIA AS WELL --
ABOUT EXTENDING THAT.
EXTENDING THAT OFFER TO MEET AND
AND AND WORK ON THE BILL SO I
APPRECIATE THAT -- AND AND SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION I THINK THERE'S
THERE'S DEEP CONCERNS THIS IS
NOT JUST A BILL THAT REITERATES
EXISTING LAW.
THIS IS A BILL THAT DOES HARDEN
DOWN THE IDEA THAT THE CPC HAS
POWER. TO COMPEL PROCUREMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE CCA WITHOUT AN
EXPLICIT AND STATED RIGHT FOR
THE CCA OR OR ANYONE ANY OTHER
TYPE OF PROVIDER TO SELF PROVIDE
FIRST.
AND THAT PRINCIPLE IS MISSING
FROM THE BILL IT WAS DESCRIBED
AS A BACKSTOP BILL BUT IT'S NOT
WRITTEN THAT WAY IT'S WRITTEN AS
BACKSTOPS IF THE CPUC CHOOSES TO
USE IT THAT WAY.
OR FOR PROCUREMENT OF THE CPC
CHOOSES TO USE IT THAT WAY
THAT'S A DEEP PROBLEM BECAUSE
THAT DOES OVERSTEP JURISDICTION
DRAMATICALLY COMPARED EXISTING
LAW.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MISTER
BURKE I'M NOT GONNA GET INTO THE
RE ITERATIONS OF I KNOW THIS
ISN'T YOUR BILL BUT I DO KNOW
THE AUTHOR WELL I'M ALSO OFFICES
GARCIA AND BUT AND I KNOW.
HE SAID I KNOW.
OKAY WHERE INTERCHANGEABLE
SUNDAYS I WAS LOOKING AT HER.
WE CAN ALL JOKE ABOUT IT BUT
MISS BURKE I I KNOW YOU'VE --
YOU WHEN I ATTENDED THE DEAL WE
SCHOOL FOR LEGISLATURE'S AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A KEEN
UNDERSTANDING OF ENERGY -- AS
WELL AS I DO AND I KNOW THAT MR
GARCIA -- IS ALWAYS WILLING TO
WORK HARD ON THESE SSUES -- AND
REALLY DRAW EVERYBODY TO THE
TABLE AND I KNOW IT'S HARD. TO
GET ALL THE PIECES RIGHT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD -- BUT THE ONLY WAY
TO REALLY TRULY HAVE THE
CONVERSATION IS TO RUN THE BILL
AND TO HAVE THE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND EVERYTHING ELSE --
SO ALSO FOR THE BILL TODAY --
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO BE INCLUDED
IN THE CONVERSATION AS IT MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND JUST AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION UP AND SINCE MARCH
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
AUTHOR MEMBERS WE BEEN TAKING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS BUT WE DO
HAVE OBVIOUSLY IDEAS AND AND
CONSIDERATION SO WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON OKAY THANK YOU.
COMMA.
I SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS IT IS THAT YOUR
CLOTHES THAT THAT CAN BE MY
CLOTHES.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING TODAY
FOR MR GARCIA I AGREE THAT THIS
IS BILLS A WORK IN PROGRESS I
THINK THERE'S A REAL ISSUE HERE
SO I'M GLAD THAT HE BROUGHT THE
BILL FORWARD.
AND I'M ALSO VERY GRATEFUL THAT
HE TOOK THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
BUT I AND I AM GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S A CONVERSATION THAT NEEDS
TO CONTINUE ISSUES WITH THE
OPPONENTS -- SO THAT THEY CAN
GET THE BILL YOU KNOW.
A PAST AND OUT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THINK WITHOUT DID WE
HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND CAN WE HAVE ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
ITEM TO AB FIFTY SIX BY EDUARDO
GARCIA THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
I'VE FLORA CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LOW MOAN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MURATSUCHI.
RIGHT TO GIN UP VOTING
[inaudible]
STONE. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THINKING.
THANK YOU -- MR LEVINE.
OF YOUR UP WITH SIX SIXTY TO
BEGIN
.
GIVE ME ONE BILLION DOLLARS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AB SIX SIXTY DIRECTS
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
BY TWENTY THIRTY TO INCREASE THE
SOLAR REFLECTANCE REQUIREMENT
FOR STEEP ROOFS.
ON EXISTING NON RESIDENTIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
ENERGY EFFICIENT RUSS ARE ALSO
KNOWN AS COOL ROOFS THESE RIFFS
ARE DESIGNED TO REFLECT MORE
SUNLIGHT ABSORB LESS HEAT THAN A
STANDARDROOF.
THESE PROPERTIES HELP LOWER ROOF
AN ATTIC TEMPERATURES ON HOT
SEVENTY DAYS TO REDUCE THE NEED
FOR AIR CONDITIONING.
THE CURRENT REAL FLAT REFLECTING
STANDARD FOR BOTH NON
RESIDENTIAL AND LOW RISE
RESIDENTIAL IS 20% THIS BILL
SENSIBLE 40% BY THE END OF THE
NEXT DECADE WITH ME TO DESCRIBE.
THE BENEFITS OF INCREASING THE
CORE OF STANDARD IS DOCTOR RONIN
LEVINSON WITH LAWRENCE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABORATORY.
THANK YOU LIKE MINUTES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR UP MY NAME
IS FROM ELEVEN CINEMA STAFF
SCIENTIST LAWRENCE BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABORATORY THE VIEWS
PRESENTED HERE ARE MINE IS AN
EXPERT OR NOT INTENDED TO
REFLECT ANY POSITION OF LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LABORATORY.
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY.
RESIDENTIAL COOL REQUIREMENTS OF
INVOLVED A LITTLE SINCE THEY
WERE INTRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA'S
BUILDING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS OVER A DECADE AGO.
TITLE TWENTY FOUR PART SIX
PRESCRIBE SCHOOL ROUTES FOR
HOMES IN ONLY SIX OF THE STATE'S
SIXTEEN CLIMATE ZONES.
BECAUSE THE ORIGINAL COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS PERFORMED BY
LBNL FOR THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
TITLE TWENTY FOUR CODE CYCLE
INCLUDED TWO KEY ASSUMPTIONS.
FIRST IT MODEL NEW HOMES IN A
WELL INSULATED ROOFS RATHER THAN
EXISTING HOMES OF POORLY
INSULATED ROOFS.
CORPS OF PRODUCTS ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE WHEN ROOFS HAVE LITTLE
INSULATION.
SECOND IT MODELED LOWER
PERFORMANCE RESIDENTIAL COOL
ROOFING PRODUCTS H. SOUL
REFLECTANCE 20%.
RATHER THAN HIGHER PERFORMANCE
RESIDENTIAL PRODUCTS WITHIN H.
REFLECTANCE OF 40%.
OR PERFORMANCE RESIDENTIAL COOL
ROOF IS NO COOLER THAN A TYPICAL
COMMERCIAL BUILDING GRAY ROOF.
AND AS MUCH WARMER THAN A
TYPICAL COMMERCIAL BUILDING
WHITE COOL ROOF.
A RECENT STUDY PUBLISHED BY LBNL
IN THE PEER REVIEWED JOURNAL
ENERGY AND BUILDINGS FOUNDER
EARLIER ANNOUNCES SUBSTANTIALLY
UNDER ESTIMATED THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF RESIDENTIAL COOL
ROOFS. FOR HOMEOWNERS TENANTS
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE KEY POINTS.
ABOUT 90% OF RESIDENTIAL ROOF
SURFACING MATERIAL SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR IS
INSTALLED ON EXISTING HOMES.
THE BENEFIT OF A COOL RIFF
PRODUCT ON AN EXISTING HOME.
IS ABOUT TWO TO FOUR TIMES THAT
OF THE SAME PRODUCT ON A NEW
HOME.
ALSO THE BENEFIT OF A HIGHER
PERFORMANCE RESIDENTIAL COOL
ROOF PRODUCT IS ABOUT THREE
TIMES THAT OF A LOWER
PERFORMANCE RESIDENTIAL COOL
ROOF PRODUCTS.
CONSIDERATION OVER THE NEXT
TWELVE YEARS FOR TRAINING --
CODE CYCLES TO RAISING PRODUCT
PERFORMANCE REQUIREMENTS FOR
RESIDENTIAL COOL ROOF RETROFITS.
AND EXPANDING THE RANGE OF
CLIMATE ZONES TO WHICH THESE REP
REQUIREMENTS APPLY IT YOUR TIME
IS UP IF YOU CAN FINISH UP WE
JUST FINISHING THE SENTENCE
COULD SUBSTANTIALLY BOOST THE
ENERGY CALL ROOF ENERGY COST
SAVINGS ENJOYED BY HOMEOWNERS
ATTENDANCE AND HELP CALIFORNIA
MEET ITS SB THREE FIFTY GOAL.
OF DOUBLING ENERGY EFFICIENCY BY
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IS THERE ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
FOR OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
OR ACTUALLY -- ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS.
NOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU -- WE HAD A MOTION TO
WE HAVE A SECOND.
OKAY -- MOTION THE SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
ITEM NINE AB SIX SIXTY BY MEMBER
LEVINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
CHAU CHAU I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LOW MOAN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
READ THROUGH THREE AYE STONE.
FIVE ONE OKAY WOULD LEAVE THE
ROLE OF AND PERHAPS MEMBERS IT
WAS FIVE TO ONE OKAY AND I THINK
YOU'RE UP NEXT WITH.
SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AT FOURTEEN FORTY SIX
REVISED OUTDATED STATUTORY
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE
EXTRACTION OF OIL AND GAS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO PRIORITIZE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION OVER COMMERCIAL
INTEREST IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
THE STATUTORY LANGUAGE PROMOTING
IN PRIORITIZING OIL AND GAS
EXTRACTION IN THIS THAT THIS
BILL WOULD CHANGE WAS ENACTED.
BEFORE TRANSPORTATION RELATED
SMOG AND THE GOAL OF THE LOS
ANGELES BASED IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES.
AND BEFORE CALIFORNIA ENACTED
THE FIRST TAILPIPE EMISSIONS
STANDARD IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX END BEFORE
THE SANTA BARBARA OIL SPILL OF
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND THE
ENSUING STATE MORATORIUM ON
OFFSHORE DRILLING.
AB FOURTEEN FORTY IS ESSENTIALLY
A CAPSTONE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP AND PUBLIC HEALTH
AWARENESS EFFORTS THAT TOOK
SHAPE IN EARNEST IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AND HAVE GROWN IN
SUBSEQUENT DECADES.
THIS BILL IS ENTIRELY IN KEEPING
WITH THE SENTIMENTS OF
CALIFORNIANS AT THE CLOSE OF THE
SECOND DECADE OF THE CENTURY.
WITH ME TODAY ARE TO
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE SPONSORS
OF THIS LEGISLATION AND
ALEXANDER WITH AND ARE DO YOU
SEE AND BILL ELIUD OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
THANK YOU I AM BILL ALLEY --
WITH THE EWG THE AIM AND
SUBSTANCE OF AB FOURTEEN FORTY A
STRAIGHT FORWARD TO MODERNIZE
THE STATUTES REGULATING OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT BY REMOVING
LANGUAGE IT'S AN ARTIFACT WITH
VERY DIFFERENT TIME IN OUR
HISTORY.
EARLY IN THE LAST CENTURY
AGENCIES REGULATING OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION CALIFORNIA TWO MAIN
GOALS TO EVENT THE KIND OF HARM
TO OIL AND GAS RESERVES THAT CAN
HAPPEN AND AND REGULATED.
DRILLING FREE FOR ALL AND TO
MAXIMIZE EXTRACTION WHICH COULD
ALSO MEAN MORE REVENUE TO THE
STATE.
THESE MAY HAVE BEEN FINE GOALS
AT THE TIME THAT DRILLING FREE
FOR ALLS ARE NO LONGER HAPPENING
THANKS IN SIGNIFICANT PART. TO
THE EVOLVING OF DOCTOR THE
DIVISION OF OIL AND GAS EIGHTY
YEARS LATER WE NOW UNDERSTAND
MORE ABOUT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS THAT ACTUALLY ATTEND
THESE DRILLING OPERATIONS.
A REGULATORY STATE AGENCIES
SHOULD NOT HAVE A GOAL OF
ALLOWING THE MAXIMUM OUT OF OIL
AND GAS. TO BE EXTRACTED OUT OF
THE GROUND BUT INSTEAD TO ALLOW
EXTRACTION IN A MATTER THAT IS
SAFE TO THE ENVIRONMENT AND TO
RESIDENTS NEAR THE DRILLING --
THIS A THESE THIS BILL AS PART
OF A REFORMED ONGOING REFORM TO
DOCTOR THEY'VE COME A LONG WAYS
IN THE LAST EIGHT YEARS WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE TO KEEP THAT
REFORM GOING.
IN ALL TURNED OVER TO MY CO
SPONSOR FOR THE REST OF THE
STORY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M AND ALEXANDER WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
AB FOURTEEN FORTIES PURPOSE IS
VERY SIMPLE IT IS AIMED AT
MODERNIZING AND CLARIFYING THE
MISSION STATEMENTS AND FINDINGS
AND THE STATUTES THAT GOVERN OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
IT WOULD DO THAT FIRST BY
ELIMINATING LANGUAGE AND BOTH
THE DOCTOR STATUTE AND THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION STATUTE.
THAT ARTICULATE AND OUTDATED
POLICY OF MAXIMIZING OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION AND SECONDLY IT WOULD
CLARIFY THE CURRENT DUAL MANDATE
IN THE DOCTOR STATUTE BY
pAND SAFETY SHOULD BE GIVEN
PRIMACY IN AGENCY DECISION
MAKING.
WHICH IS OF COURSE SOUND
PRACTICE FOR ANY MODERN
REGULATORY AGENCY.
NOW TO BE EQUALLY CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT THIS LEGISLATION WOULD NOT
DO -- FOURTEEN FORTY WOULD
CREATE NO NEW PROCESS SEES OR
REVIEW REQUIREMENTS AND IT DOES
NOT STATE A POLICY EITHER
AGAINST OR IN FAVOR OF
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTION IT'S
SIMPLY RENDERS THE STATUTE
NEUTRAL ON THAT POLICY QUESTION
IS IT SHOULD BE.
THESE CHANGES ARE VERY SIMILAR
IN SPIRIT TO REFORMS THAT WERE
JUST SIGNED INTO LAW IN THE
STATE OF COLORADO.
MUCH ALIKE AB FOURTEEN FORTY
COLORADO'S SB ONE EIGHTY ONE
ELIMINATED A REQUIREMENT THAT
THE REGULATORY AGENCY QUOTE
UNQUOTE FOSTER OIL AND GAS
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S CREATING A
COMPETING MANDATE.
OF THE SORT THAT WE HAVE HERE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE STAFF AND
THE SPONSORS -- HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH DOCTOR
REGARDING SOME RELATIVELY MINOR
CHANGES TO IMPROVE THE
LEGISLATION AND WE ANTICIPATE
THOSE WILL CONTINUE.
AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE MR
LEVINE SUPPORT FOR THIS COMMON
SENSE PROPOSAL TO BRING
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS GOVERNING OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION INTO THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
WAIT RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION ANDREY WILL WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND HERE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN A WIKI WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU TWO MINUTES EACH.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- PF ANY THOMAS.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION.
I WERE IN OPPOSITION.
TO AB ONE FOREIGN -- ONE FOUR
FOUR ZERO IT IN THE BILL AS
AMENDED VERSION MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- IT'S SOMEWHAT
CONFUSING FOR EXAMPLE ACTUAL
SECTION THIRTY ONE SIXTY OF THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES CODE -- DOES A
COUPLE OF THINGS ONE IT PROVIDES
A BALANCE IN PRODUCTION AND THE
AUTHORITY TO IMPLEMENT THE
SAFEST OIL IN AFTER GAS PRETTY
PRODUCED IN OUR NATION.
THE SECOND THING THAT IT DOES IT
IS APPROVED IT IS IMPROVE IT IS
PRUDENT.
IN ITS REALITY OF RISK IN THE
INDUSTRY THAT WE DO HAVE.
HOWEVER WITH YOU WHEN YOU GO TO
PAGE FOUR OF THE BILL PAGE.
FOUR LINES ONE THROUGH THREE
SMALL DE.
THEY'VE BEEN DELETED FROM THE
BILL.
NOW WHAT'S BEEN DELETED IS AS
FOLLOWS TO BEST MEET ALL THE GAS
NEEDS IN THE STATE.
THE SUPERVISOR THE DOCTOR
SUPERVISOR SHALL ADMINISTER THIS
DIVISIONS SO AS TO ENCOURAGE THE
WISE DEVELOPMENT.
THE WISE DEVELOPMENT OF OIL AND
GAS RESOURCES.
IF IT IS ON THE TERM WISE
DEVELOPMENT.
BEING THE OPTIMAL TERM.
IF WE AREN'T WISELY DEVELOPING
OIL AND GAS AND THAT'S BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE BILL THAN WHAT
WE GOING TO DO IN SO FAR AS
DEVELOPING FALLING GAS.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH MEDIAN NEEDS
OF THE STATE IN A SAFE AND WEISS
MATTER I ASKED.
IF THE BILL IS SIGNED INTO LAW.
IT WILL BE A BLANKET GOLD LIGHT
FOR IMPORTS MEMBERS WE CURRENTLY
PAY EIGHTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS A
DAY.
WE PAY EIGHTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS A DAY FOR IMPORTS.
IF THE POLICY IS TO KEEP IT IN
THE GROUND THEN MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR AND THEN WE CAN HAVE THAT
POLICY DISCUSSION THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL IN A BERKELEY DOES.
BY CHANGING THE TERM MAXIMUM OUT
OF THE IN FACT.
OTHER THE MISSION STATEMENT SO
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO ENTER BUT
ALL OF US ARE GONE.
IN THE FUTURE WHO'S GOING
INTERPRET WHAT MINIMUM IS WHAT
MAXIMUM IS BUT THE MIDDLE LINE
IS SO AS I CLOSE THIS BILL MAY
IN FACT PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE.
BUT I THINK THE RESIDENTS OF THE
STATE DESERVE A CLEAR
EXPLANATION OF WHAT COMES NEXT
IF WE IN FACT LOSE PRODUCTION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IN CLOSING I WOULD JUST SAYS IS
THE JOB OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ASSIST IN MEETING
THE ENERGY NEEDS AND DEMANDS OF
THE RESIDENTS.
HI BUT SAY AFFIRMATIVE. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR DOES NOTHING OF THAT
SORT NOW WHEN COURAGE NO VOTE ON
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MANAGER MEMBERS THE LEGACY FOR
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
STATE'S MAJOR OIL.
PRODUCERS AND REFINERS IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND JUST --
BY WAY OF FROM HISTORY OF FROM
HER PERSPECTIVE -- THE
ASSEMBLYMAN MENTIONED ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE HAPPENED SINCE.
OF THAT STATUTE WAS --
IMPLEMENTED OR PUT AN INPUT IN
STATUTE.
I THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT.
CALIFORNIA HAS A HISTORY OF
DEVELOPING ITS.
HYDROCARBON RESOURCES IT HAS HAD
A HISTORY AND HAD A GROWTH
BECAUSE OF THE DEVELOPMENT OF
ITS HYDROCARBON RESOURCES.
WHEN THIS BILL LANGUAGE IS PUT
IN STATURE TO WISELY DEVELOP ITS
RESOURCES?
A COUPLE THINGS WILL SAID AS WE
DEVELOP THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE BUILT ADEQUATE DUCT WE BUILT
A HIGHWAY SYSTEM WE DID A LOT OF
MONUMENTAL THINGS IN CALIFORNIA
IN A LARGE PART DUE TO THE
RESOURCES THAT WERE DEVELOPED IN
STATE.
SO WE WE APPRECIATE THE IDEA OF
MODERNIZING OUR STATUTE.
BUT WE DON'T MODERNIZE BY GOING
IN AND JUST EXCISING A PIECE OF
THE STATUE WE DO A BY
RECOGNIZING.
HOW WE DEVELOPED OUR REGULATORY
STRUCTURE?
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS.
THE DEVELOP THE PRODUCTION OF
OIL AND GAS IS UNDERGONE A
TREMENDOUS TREMENDOUS --
RESTRUCTURING.
MANY OF BILLS THAT YOU ALL VOTED
FOR SB FOUR SB.
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE THE PUSH FOR
THE COMPLETELY RESTRUCTURING OF
THE UNDERGROUND TRACTION CONTROL
PROGRAM WE HAVE COMPLETELY
RESTRUCTURED HOW WE REGULATE OIL
AND GAS IN CALIFORNIA LAST TEN
YEARS.
AND THAT'S NOT BECAUSE WE GO
BACK TO THE DIGITAL OIL AND GAS
AND AND EXCISE OUT PART OF ITS
MISSION WE ADD TO THAT WE'VE
ADDED.
THE VERY VERY MUCH A STRONG ROLE.
FOR THE REGIONALLY -- WATER
BOARDS THE STATE WATER BOARD THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC STOP THE
SUBSTANCE CONTROL THEY ALL PLAY
SIGNIFICANT ROLES IN THE
PROTECTION.
OF THE OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN THE
PROTECTION OF OUR RESOURCES.
SO IT'S NOT SIMPLY LOOKING AT
THE DAHLE MANDATE -- THAT WOULD
BE INAPPROPRIATE TO SIMPLY LOOK
AT THE DIVISION ONE GAS AND SAY
WELL LET'S JUST TAKE THAT AWAY
AND WE'LL JUST DO IT THIS WAY
WE'VE ADDED AN ENTIRELY NEW
REGULATORY STRUCTURE ON TOP OF
THE DIVISION OF OIL AND GAS.
IN FACT BECAUSE OF BILLS THAT
YOU ALL HAVE APPROVED AND
BUDGETS OVER THE LAST.
I WOULD SAY FIVE YEARS.
YOU'VE TURNED WHAT -- THE
PRODUCTION OF OIL AND GAS INTO A
DATA GATHERING.
BUSINESS YEAR GATHERING NINE
BILLION DATA POINTS FROM OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT EVERY YEAR.
HERE YOU'RE GETTING SO MUCH DATA
ABOUT WHERE YOU TO WHERE YOU
PRODUCE WHERE THE WATER IS THE
EMISSIONS.
HERE GETTING SO MUCH DATA THAT
YOU HAD TO BUILD AN ENTIRELY NEW.
DATA -- SYSTEM WHICH FEELING GAS
IS PAYING FOR SO THAT YOU CAN
TAKE IN THAT DATA FOR THE YOU
CAN.
USE IT.
NOT ONLY FOR REGULAR WOULD MAKE
AVAILABLE TO YOU AS POLICY
MAKERS AND TO THE PUBLIC.
SO THIS THE LANDSCAPE IN TERMS
OF OIL PRODUCTION IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
IT IS DIFFERENT THAN WHEN THE
STATUTE WAS ORIGINALLY.
PUT IN IN THE CODE BUT IT'S ALSO.
ONE IT SHOULD BE REFLECTED HOW
MUCH WORK IS BEING DONE NOW BY
OTHER.
BY ALL OF THE OTHER STATE
AGENCIES WE OPPOSE THIS BILL WAS
ONE MORE SECOND BECAUSE IT WILL
CREATE.
A HUGE AMOUNT OF REGULATORY
UNCERTAINTY FOR THE ACTUAL
DEVELOPMENT OF THE RESOURCE. FOR
THAT REASON WE OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION [inaudible]
AND POSITION.
WE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL FOR THE REASONS STATED
THE REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY IS
DEADLY PROBLEM IF WE'RE GONNA
ATTACK SUPPLY BUT NOT.
JUST NAY AND ARE IN THE SECOND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
HAS THERE BEEN A MOTION
[inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
ME CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWENTY AB FOURTEEN FORTY BY
LEVINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN.
FLORA CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LOW MOAN MATHIS.
THE SNOW MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
RIGHT TO AYE STONE.
THREE ONE OKAY BERYL OPEN THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK MAKING
THEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR
WOULD INCLUDE AGRICULTURE AMONG
THE SPECIFIED ISSUES ON WHICH
THE COMMISSION THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION.
MAY RECEIVE TECHNICAL ADVICE AND
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH REGARD TO
ITS DECISION MAKING.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT --
ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TO
THE RUSH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU NO THIS IS BEEN A
LONG HEARING SO WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY YOU ARE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT.
I WAS THE NEXT PARAGRAPH BUT I
WANTED TO SPARE YOU FROM READING
YES INDEED I AM ACCEPTING THE
COMMITMENTS THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBER SEAN DRAKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
THE COASTAL COMMISSION DOES HAVE
A SUPPORT POSITION UNANIMOUSLY
ON THE BILL.
WILL FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE SPONSOR TO
ALSO DEVELOP PROGRAMMING TO
ASSIST THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY AND NAVIGATING THE
COMMISSION'S REGULATORY PROCESS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
HEARING NONE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE.
WE DON'T.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWENTY SIX A. B. SIXTEEN
FORTY FOUR BY MEMBER LEVINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN.
FLORA CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ BROUGHT TO JUNE
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible] THREE ZERO
SEVERAL OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
NEXT.
WE HAVE.
MR SALAS.
MOVE THE BILL.
THERE HAS BEEN IN MOTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND YOUR PRESENT IN AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY THREE THAT'S CORRECT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE RISEN ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTY THREE TO
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL WILL CREATE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND ANONYMOUS
SEQUEL LAWSUITS BY REQUIRING THE
DISCLOSURE THE PARTICIPATING
PARTIES WERE FUNDING SICK WHAT
CHALLENGES.
AN HONEST LAWSUITS ARE UNIQUE TO
SEEK WERE AND ARE RARELY ALLOWED
IN OTHER AREAS OF OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM.
IN FACT AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY THREE
IS CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT
JUDICIAL PRACTICE.
IN THE COUNTRY WHICH GENERALLY
DISAPPROVES OF ANONYMOUS
LITIGATION.
THE ABILITY FOR INDIVIDUALS OR
GROUPS TO FILE NONE OF US
LAWSUITS REPRESENTS.
A BLAME LACK OF TRANSPARENCY IN
OPENS THE DOOR FOR ABUSIVE
BEHAVIOR.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN A DEVELOPER
WANTED TO TURN A RUNDOWN MOTEL
IN SAN DIEGO.
INTO A TRANSITIONAL CENTER FOR
THE HOMELESS EVEN THOUGH THE
CITY COUNCIL APPROVED THE
PROJECT.
THE GROUP OF OWNER HOMEOWNERS
FILED AN ANONYMOUS EQUAL LAWSUIT
UNDER THE GUISE OF AN EVENT OF
AN ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP.
WELL THE JUDGE EVENTUALLY
THROUGHOUT THE CASE THE DELAY
LASTED SIX MONTHS AND DROVE THE
PROJECT TO THE BRINK OF
FINANCIAL COLLAPSE.
IN AN EXTREME CASE AN OBSCURE
ENTITY CALLED BETTER
NEIGHBORHOODS FILED NUMEROUS
SEQUEL LAWSUITS AGAINST PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO EXTRACT.
SETTLEMENT PAYMENTS FROM
DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE BETTER NEIGHBORHOODS GROUP
WAS EVENTUALLY TRACED BACK TO A
DISBARRED LAWYER.
WHO HAD PREVIOUSLY DEFRAUDED HIS
CLIENTS?
THE CONTINUED EXISTENCE OF
ANONYMOUS EQUAL LAWSUITS CAN
OCCUR JUST BAD BEHAVIOR AND
ALLOW FOR ABUSE.
THIS PRACTICE DEPRIVE THE PUBLIC
IN THE COURTS OF RELEVANT
INFORMATIONWHEN DEALING WITH
SEQUEL.
THE INTENTIONS OF PEOPLE FILING
SEQUEL LAWSUIT SHOULD BE MADE
CLEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
CHALLENGING PROJECTS BASED ON
LEGITIMATE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY THREE WOULD
CREATE TRANSPARENCY WITH OUR
LEGAL SYSTEM BY REQUIRING THE
DIRECT FUNDERS OF A CIVIL
LAWSUIT. TO DISCLOSE THEIR
IDENTITY.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY ALLOWS THE COURT TO
WIT HOLD PUBLIC DISCLOSURE IF
THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
IS CAPTAIN KEEPING THE
INFORMATION CONFIDENTIAL.
THIS PRESERVES A NON ENTITY.
AND LEGITIMATE CASES WERE
DISCOURAGING ANY FUTURE ABUSIVE
BEHAVIOR MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
BILL DOES NOT WE CAN SEEK WELL
WE'RE STREAMLINED CERTAIN
PROJECTS IT'S SIMPLY CREATES
TRANSPARENCY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
TO HAVE A TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
AT WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF.
OBSTACLE SINCE ITS INCEPTION
ALMOST FIVE DECADES AGO HAS
OPERATED AS A THE LIGHTING LAW
THAT.
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC IN A OPEN
PROCESS WHICH ALLOWS THE PUBLIC
AND LEAD AGENCIES TO ANALYZE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS --
MITIGATE THOSE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS IF THEY ARE SIGNIFICANT
TO THE EXTENT FEASIBLE AND SIX
PUBLIC COMMENT -- IT ALSO ALLOWS
CITIZENS TO ENFORCE WERE.
IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST THE
PROBLEM IS SEE WHO HAS THE
BROADEST STANDING REQUIREMENTS
OF ANY OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL LAW
IN THE COUNTRY IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON. FOR THOSE SIMPLY
OPPOSED. TO A PARTICULAR
DEVELOPMENT TO UTILIZE SEEK WORK
TOMORROW PROMOTE THEIR PRIVATE
INTEREST.
UNDER THE GUISE OF THE PUBLIC
AND TEY DO SO ENTIRELY
ANONYMOUSLY AND OFTEN UNDERSTOOD --
NAMES CREATED SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE PURPOSES OF DISGUISING THEIR
PRIVATE INTERESTS.
HOW DO I KNOW I USED TO ACTUALLY
LITIGATE?
DOING THAT VERY THING.
NO OTHER CITIZEN'S SUIT
PROVISION ALLOWS THIS NOT THE
CLEAN AIR ACT CLEAN WATER ACT
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT OR
EVEN SEEK WAS IT NATIONAL
COUNTERPART THE NATIONAL OF OUR
MIDDLE POLICY ACT.
THIS BILL DOES NOTHING MORE THAN
A LINE SYKORA WITH ALL OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL CITIZENS WHO
PROVISIONS BY REQUIRING
DISCLOSURE OF THOSE DIRECTLY
FUNDING THE LOSSES.
IT DOES NOT A ROAD OR EXEMPT ANY
SUBSTANTIVE REQUIREMENTS OF
SEQUEL IT DOES NOT CHANGE
MITIGATION MEASURES.
NOR DOES IT AS SOME OPPONENTS OF
SAID REQUIRE INDIVIDUAL
MEMBERSHIP DISCLOSURE THE
EXPRESS LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL
ONLY REQUIRES DISCLOSURE.
OF THE PERSONS OR ENTITIES
CONTRIBUTE DIRECTLY TO THE
LAWSUIT THAT DOES NOT.
COUNT FOR MEMBERSHIP DUES OR ANY
OTHER UNION DUES.
YOU MAY ALSO HEAR FIRST
AMENDMENT ARGUMENTS THAT THIS
BILL IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL CITING
A SIXTY YEAR OLD SUPREME COURT
CASE. TO BE CLEAR THAT CASE DOES
NOT BAR DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENT
LAWS IF THEY DID EVERY OTHER
CITIZEN'S SUIT PROVISION UNDER
ALL THE FEDERAL NORMAL LAWS I'VE
JUST I'VE STATED EARLIER WOULD
BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THAT COURT CASE AND DOUBLE ACP
VERSUS PATTERSON SIMPLY SAYS
IT'S A BALANCING TEST AND
DISCLOSURE SHOULD OUTWEIGH
ANONYMITY.
THAT IS WHY UNDER THIS BILL.
IT PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL LAYER
PROTECTION THAT ALLOWS THE COURT
TO WITHHOLD DISCLOSURE IF IT
FINDS THE PUBLIC INTEREST IN
KEEPING THAT INFORMATION
CONFIDENTIAL CLEARLY OUTWEIGHS
THE PUBLIC.
INTEREST.
TRANSPARENCY THE HALLMARK OF
GOOD GOVERNANCE AND WE SUPPORT
SEE WHAT TRANSPARENCY WE HOPE
YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
HI TODD DAVID ONLY HALF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
APART RIGHT.
LET ME DESCRIBE MYSELF I JUST
ASKED FOR ANYONE ELSE IN A
POSITION TO KNOW IF YOU KNOW
YOUR SUPPORT YEAH YES.
ON OKAY IN CS SO TIGHT EVEN WE
HAVE THE BAY AREA HOUSING UP TO
SEE COALITION AND SO I DON'T I
WANT TO REITERATE EVERYTHING
THAT WAS SAID I TOTALLY GREAT.
THIS ONE TO GIVE A COUPLE OF
VERY CONCRETE EXAMPLES OF HOW
WE'VE GOTTEN TO A PLACE WERE
REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF OB
LEGISLATION. TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT IT CAN OFTEN BE
WEAPONIZED TO DO ALMOST THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT IT WAS
MEANT TO DO.
RIGHT SO WE KNOW ON ALMOST EVERY
EVERY RESPECTFUL ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUP LOOKS TO SEE WHAT AND SAYS
THAT WE'VE GOT TO BE BUILDING
MORE URBAN INFILL HOUSE LIKE.
BUT 87% A SEQUEL LAWSUIT
LAWSUITS ARE TARGETED AT URBAN
INFILL HOUSING.
SO THERE IS THE WEAPONIZATION OF
MISUSE OF THE C. QUOTE THAT IS
ACTUALLY ADDING UP HURTING OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
AND I THINK THAT THE GOES PRETTY
CLEARLY ARE JUST THE HUMAN
EXPERIENCES.
ANONYMOUS AND THE NAME OF THE
LEADS TO THE WORST BEHAVIOR.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE WAY PEOPLE
BEHAVE ONLINE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
PUT THEIR NAME ON SOMETHING IT
JUST INCENTIVIZE IS THE ABSOLUTE
WORST BEHAVIOR?
IN SAN FRANCISCO LAST WEEK THERE
WAS A SIXTY THREE UNITS.
OF HOUSING PROJECT 25% OF WHICH
WAS AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
AND A SEQUEL LAWSUIT WAS BROUGHT
TO STOP IT BECAUSE IT CAST A
SHADOW ON ONE THIRD OF THE
BASKETBALL COURT. FOR ONE
HUNDRED MINUTES ON THE LONGEST
DAY OF THE YEAR.
AND IT WAS STOPPED. SIXTY THREE
YOU HAVE IT'S ABOUT SIXTY THREE
UNITS OF DESPERATELY NEEDED
URBAN INFILL HOUSING IN SAN
FRANCISCO WAS STOPPED BECAUSE A
SHADOW.
WAS FOR ONE HUNDRED MINUTES.
ON THE LONGEST DAY OF THE YEAR.
PREVIOUS TO THAT.
BOB HABITAT FOR HUMANITY HAD A
PROJECT IN REDWOOD CITY.
THAT WAS REALLY BUILD TWENTY
UNITS OF WELL IN MIDDLE INCOME
HOUSING THAT WAS THE LEAD FOR
SIXTEEN MONTHS.
pI THINK IS A REALLY SMART FIRST
STEP.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE MOST OBVIOUS
THE MOST EGREGIOUS MISUSES OF
SEQUEL ARE DONE IN A NOT TO MISS
NATURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE JUST THE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION.
WHEN IT WAS LIKE A VIRGIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
REALTORS IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TURNING TO THE CALIFORNIA PART
OF THE SOLUTION HERE SUPPORT.
SECOND NOT KNOCK IT OVER HERE
JOHNSON CLAN TO HAVE THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO ALL SOME SUPPORT.
SAYS THE MATTER THAT LIGHT HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS PART.
OKAY THERE'S ANSWERED THE CHARM
ANYONE ELSE OF THE PART
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION
.
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRENNAN DAWSON
FOR SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
IN OUR VIEW -- THE BILL DOES SET
UP WHILE DOESN'T LOOK AT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT ARGUE -- BECAUSE
ANONYMOUS SPEECH IS PROTECTED
SPEECH UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT --
AND FUNDING.
LAWSUIT IS ANONYMOUSLY IS A
CLEARLY A FORMER SPEECH AND
ACTIVITY IT DOESN'T OKAY --
FREEDOM OF ASSEMBLY AND THE
FREEDOM ASSOCIATION -- BUT OTHER
THAN THAT IT'S ALSO A KIND OF AN
UNWORKABLE BILL INTO ACTUAL IN
ACTUALITY -- FIRST OFF I WANT
PUSH BACK ON THE ANONYMOUS --
HOW ENORMOUSLY FUNDING SECRET
LAWSUIT IS BECOMING A DETRIMENT
TO HOUSING PROJECTS -- IF A
DEVELOPER WOULD LIKE TO BUILD A
HOUSING PROJECT ARE.
SEVENTEEN OR SO EXEMPTIONS UNDER
SEQUEL FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
ALONE -- SPECIFICALLY ONCE
TARGETING INFILL PROJECTS ON
THEREFORE THEY WOULDN'T EVEN
HAVE TO UNDERGO THE SECRET
PROCESS THE AND THEY COULD BLOCK
PASSING SEQUEL LAWSUITS BECAUSE
IT'S ALREADY A STATUTORY
EXEMPTION AVAILABLE --
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
DETRIMENT ENVIRONMENT A
COMMUNITY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS OF
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES --
BECAUSE THOSE COMMUNITIES RELY
ON SELF -- SELF ENACTED
BASICALLY SEE WAS A SELF IN
ACTING.
UP ENFORCEMENT LOS LAW AND IT
REQUIRES THE PUBLIC TO COME
FORTH IN BECAUSE ANYONE CAN
ACTUALLY BRING A LAWSUIT IN THE
NAME SI KHOA.
THAN.
BY REQUIRING THE ON BY REQUIRING
SOMEONE TO DISCLOSE WHO IS
FINDING THAT LAWSUIT YOU'RE
BASICALLY REQUIRING PLAINTIFFS
TO GO OUT AND SAY.
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION -- ON WHO GAVE ANY
AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR THIS TYPE OF
LAWSUIT -- AND THAT IS WHAT
HAPPENS Là ENVIRONMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WHERE THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING
OUT AND THEY'RE BASICALLY.
SELF FINANCING THESE PROJECTS --
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THE BILL -- PRIMARILY
BEFORE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T GET
THE FIRST MEMBER BUT ALSO
BECAUSE IT.
IS ON WORKABLE -- AND I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW IT DOES NOT.
ACTUALLY -- AFFECT A SEQUEL
LAWSUIT STILL ACTUALLY AFFECT
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN THE WAY
THAT SOME THE UPON PROPONENTS
WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE YOU BELIEVE
I WOULD.
RECOMMEND THAT YOU LOOK AT SOME
OBJECTIVE -- LITIGATION FACTS
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE BY NOT ONLY
THIS AN ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMPANY AND I'M.
COMMITTEE BUT ALSO THIS
COMMITTEE AS WELL IN THE PAST SO
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU CHELSEA TO SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY AN ENVIRONMENT.
WHERE IN THE VINYL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THAT'S BASED IN THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THINKING?
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AN
OPPOSITION.
BRIAN -- WITH YOU AT THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN
OPPOSITION.
TIFFANY IN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
VINYL JUST LINES ARE SO HOT IN
OPPOSITION.
SISTER DEALS WITH THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
JASMINE JOHNSON WITH PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES AND WE HAVE -- SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL.
IN THE CATEGORY WITH A NOT TO
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR SALAS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADDRESS.
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION FROM
TERENCE.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND LET ME JUST FIRST
BEGIN BY I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S TRANSPARENCIES USUALLY
SOMETHING THAT WE WE SEEK AND
THIS LEADS IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
THIS CAPITAL WE ALWAYS ONCE
CLOSURE.
AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF BILLS
THAT WE ALL VOTED ON TO INCREASE
DISCLOSURE ACTUALLY INFORMATION --
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS.
WE DON'T SEE THIS BILL IS
BENEFITING ONE GROUP OR ANOTHER
IT'S JUST TRANSPARENCY BRING
TRANSPARENCY TO THE ENTIRE
PROCESS.
AND SO -- YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD SAY IF YOU'VE HEARD FROM
THE PROPONENTS ABOUT SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT THEY'VE HAD WITH
HOUSING PROJECTS.
THAT THEY'VE DEALT WITH
SPECIFICALLY OUT IN THE BAY AREA
AND THEN FELL.
AND TO THE CONSTITUTIONALITY I
KNOW THAT -- ADAM SPOKE TO THAT.
FROM THE CHAMBER AND SO WITH
THAT I'LL USE THEIR COMMENTS AS
MY CLOTHES AND JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN THE
TIMES APPROPRIATE -- I KNOW
WE'RE MISSING A MAJORITY OF THE
MEMBERS.
UP HERE SO.
MAYBE.
ASK ONCE ALL THE MEMBERS ARE
HERE OR A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THERE IS THERE IS A CAME.
WITH A BROKEN THERE IS THE
MOTION AND A SECOND.
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T TWENTY A. B. SIXTEEN
SEVENTY THREE BY MEMBERS SALAS
TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN FLORA -- FLOOR
AYE CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING GARCIA -- CO
NO LEMOND.
MATHIS -- MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible] TWO ONE OKAY
THOROUGH OPEN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OR YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR L'OREAL BE PRESENTING AB
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO YES I WILL
MANAGER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HOW IT STARTED WELL I WITNESSES
THAT MAKE THEIR WAY THROUGH THE
GROUP ON THE HALLWAY?
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
THIS BILL -- THIS AFTERNOON OR
THIS EVENING I GUESS -- WHO?
I AM.
AB THIRD -- TWELVE THIRTY TWO
WILL CHOIR AFFORDABLE AND
UNREGULATED BELOW MARKET UNITS
RECEIVING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
FUNDING THE LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM TO
MAINTAIN AFFORDABILITY FOR UP TO
TEN YEARS.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WITH ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND WHETHER IS ATION
UPGRADES IN ORDER TO USE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF HOUSING --
THE BILL. FOR RENTERS THIS CAN
MEAN THE INSTALLATION OF ENERGY
EFFICIENT HEATING AND AIR ENERGY
EFFICIENT APPLIANCES AND
LIGHTING WINDOW REPLACEMENT.
WATER HEATERS THIS PROGRAM IS
INVITED FUNDED ENTIRELY BY THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND IT
IS A TESTAMENT TO OUR STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO CLIMATE EQUITY
ENSURING THAT OUR CLIMATE ACTION
SUPORT THE RESILIENCY OF
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
WHILE THE CARBON CARBON ISING
BUILDINGS IS CRITICAL TO REACH
OUR STATE CLIMACTERIC IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT AGAINST
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WHEN OUR
STATE DOLLARS HAVE BEEN INVESTED.
AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES
THIS POTENTIALLY MIS USE OF
STATE FUNDS BY REQUIRING THAT
UNITS RECEIVING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY FUNDING FROM THIS
PROGRAM MAINTAINED THEIR
AFFORDABILITY FOR UP TO TEN
YEARS.
THIS WILL ENSURE THE BENEFITS OF
THIS PROGRAM REACH AND REMAIN
WITH LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FOR
WHICH THESE FUNDS WERE INTENDED.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THE
BAD PLAYERS DO NOT MISS USE THE
STATE FUNDS BUT WE UNDERSTAND IT
THESE ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS
COULD POSE BEERS FOR LANDLORDS
WHO WISH TO ACCESS THESE FUNDS.
I'M EXTREMELY SENSITIVE TO THESE
CONCERNS AND FOR THIS REASON ARE
IN ARE GOING CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE STATE
AGENCY THAT ADMINISTERS THIS
PROGRAM. TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
STRENGTHENS IT IN THE CONTINUE
BRING FOR MUCH NEEDED BENEFIT TO
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
PLEASE INTRODUCE -- TWO AMAZING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE LEADERS --
WHO CAN SPEAK MORE ABOUT EIGHTY
TWELVE THIRTY TWO AND HOW IT
FITS INTO THE CLOSET FRAMEWORK
OF ACHIEVING CLIMATE EQUITY WE
HAVE?
SEEN A ROBINSON OF THE LOCAL
POLICY ADVOCATE ASSOCIATE FOR
THE ASIA PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK -- AND LEAP OF CHAIRMAN
DON HI ZAC -- WHITE HOUSE
CHAMPION OF CHANGE TWENTY
THIRTEEN AND A COMMUNITY LEADER.
WITH THE ASIAN PACIFIC IN VINYL
NETWORK AND LASTLY HIS
TRANSLATOR TORRENT -- TORN.
NAM FOR CERTAIN A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER WITH THE NETWORK AS
WELL.
THANK YOU I WILL ASK YOU TO HOLD
YOUR COMMENTS THE TWO MINUTES
AND I WILL GIVE ADDITIONAL TIME
FOR TO THE TRANSLATOR.
YOU CAN CHECK.
HOW OLD WELL I?
FORMALLY POUR CAM THEM OUTSIDE
[inaudible]
ALL.
MUCH ON TOP COMING.
OVER YOUR JOB ALLOWED ON OKAY.
MY NAME IS IT BOOKED AND PASS
OUT I'M KAMAL -- FROM NOW IS A
REFUGEE HERE.
OVERCOME FRIDAY WHEN THEY'RE UP
THE MOVES THAT I I ME AND MY
WIFE WE ALSO RECEIVE SSI THAT
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS.
IRAQI EAGLE PERLA KILL ON AMOUNT
BUT NOT COULD NOT.
HOW COME GOD IT GO A?
I LAUGHED.
SO NOT SALOON MY CALL.
A. B..
UNDER THE SONG LOOK AT SAM SONG.
I'M HERE TODAY TO THIS -- TO
REPRESENT HIM TO ASK YOU ALSO
SUPPORT.
THE B. L. A. B. -- TWELVE THIRTY
TWO A BY THE SUDDEN LONG WHILE
YOU MORE -- WON'T LET ME -- CUP
I'M NOT BUT NOW.
PATTON CAM LACKEY -- LONG YOU
CAN PUT MY GEAR AND GO PAN YEAH
IT DAY.
HOW WE ALSO WANT TO ASK YOU ARE
NOT ONLY MY FAMILY BUT A MANY
THE FAMILY IN THE COMMUNITY --
ONE THIS BE OUT -- TO SUPPORT BY
THE ASSEMBLY THE HOUSE RIGHT
SPENT IT BUT ALSO UTILITY BE I
WAS VERY HIGH -- AND THE A
CONDITION UP THE HOUSE -- IT'S
NOT AS GOOD.
WHAT WILL ALSO ABOUT LIKE THE
HOME GROUND?
GOOD MORNING.
I HADN'T BEEN A SOPHOMORE AT LET
ME LA.
NOT YET A BLOODY Là WHAT THE
LIAM [inaudible]
WHEN WE?
TED THE LANDLORD ABOUT THE
VENDOR LICENSE IN AND HOW THE
THE CONDITION IN THE HOUSE.
IT'S NOT GOOD AND THEN WE ASK
THE LANDLORD TO HELP US TO PICK
THE CONDITION -- INSTEAD UP BY
THE LANDLORD PICKING THE
CONDITION THAT LYNOTT TRACED THE
RAIN THREE HUNDRED A MONTH MORE.
I MADE THE ECONOMICAL ATOP.
A MOVE WELL I'M BELIEVE.
POLICY IN THE HELLO LEARNED A
LOT COULD NOT EQUIPPED COULD
TELL IT WILL GO TO RE.
AND TWELVE ABOUT THAT MAKE ON SO
WE HAVE TO MOVE TO A NEW PLACE
THAT THE LIVE RIGHT NOW EVEN
THOUGH NEW PLACE TO LIVE RIGHT
NOW WE RAIN.
AND STILL HAVE A LOT ABOUT --
BETTER LIFE IT'S IN THE SHOES
THAT HAVE THE CONDITION AND HOW.
SPENT TODAY THE ROOM ME IN MY
EYES LIT.
AT NIGHT WE CAN HE HAD THE VIN
COME INTO THE HOUSE WILL BE
CANNOT MANY TEN ON THE HIT IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AND
DOESN'T HIT THE HOUSE.
COUPLE OF DAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I'M AS YOU HEARD FROM ME BEAU
THIS IS AN ISSUE WERE HANG
DIRECTLY FROM OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
AND ENERGY AND SECURITY
CURRENTLY AFFECTS ONE IN FOR
CALIFORNIA UTILITY CUSTOMERS --
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY ON A. B. TWELVE
THIRTY TWO AS IT AFFIRMS THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM.
AS AN ESSENTIAL PER ALMOST SIX
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS WITH AN
AVERAGE BUILD SAVING OF 30% AN
AVERAGE OF EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS
OF 40% -- HOWEVER.
A REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION PROJECTS THAT
THREE TWENTY THIRTY THE HIGHEST
HOUSING GROWTH IS EXPECTED IN
COMMUNITIES WITH.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIO ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES MEANING DISPLACEMENT
PRESSURES WILL INCREASE IN THE
COMMUNITIES LIKE WEAPONS
DESIGNED TO SERVE.
AND THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
OVER. EIGHTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
ARE ON THE WAIT LIST.
CREATING SMART PRAGMATIC TENET
PROTECTIONS AND ASSESSING THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS OVER TIME ENSURES
THAT STATE FUNDS DESIGNATED FOR
THE BENEFIT OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT MISS USE DUE
TO INTENSE HOUSING MARKET
CONDITIONS.
COORDINATION BETWEEN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND HEALTH PROGRAMS
IS ALSO A DIRECT RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CLEAN ENERGY IN LOW
INCOME MULTI FAMILY BUILDINGS
ACTION PLAN. TO ADDRESS BARRIERS
AND THE GREEN DIVIDE.
WE HEARD ANOTHER LOCAL TESTIMONY
THAT A MEDICALLY VULNERABLE AND
RECENTLY ON HOUSE RESIDENT GOT
HEALTH EMERGENCY FUNDING FOR AN
AIR CONDITIONER WHICH HELPED
REDUCE RATES OF IS ASTHMA
ATTACKS.
BUT WITHOUT ANY CORRESPONDING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY MEASURES HIS
ENERGY BILLS SKYROCKETED AND HE
TO STRUGGLE TO PAY RENT.
WE NEED TO AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO
AS AN INTERSECTIONAL APPROACH TO
OUR HOUSING AND CLIMATE CRISES.
THAT FACTOR IN WHOLE EOPLE AND
IN PARTICULAR THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE'S MOST DISADVANTAGED AND
WE CAN'T DO THAT IN A WAY THAT
ADDS VALUE FOR PROPERTY OWNERS.
IMPROVES THE HEALTH AND
STABILITY OF RESIDENTS AND MEETS
OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
JUST YOUR NAME POSITIONER AND
ORGANIZATION.
PAN OF US BECAUSE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WITH THE CALIFORNIA RUN
TO SCIENCE AND ALSO STRONG CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
CHELSEA TO CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY ENVIRONMENT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MY CLUB SCENE ON WE HAVE THE
CALVARY SOLAR AND STORED
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HEY LIE ALL OR NONE.
HI Là M<c.cyan> JODY GOT EGGMAN</c>
DELEGATE THE LIKE DJ.
HOT LANSING LEARN OUR RESIDENT
OAKLAND ALSO IT COMMUNITY
LEADERS OFF ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK AND HE
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS HE'S NOT SAYING
[inaudible]
I AM.
ANY PAIN -- MEMBER.
I SAW PAUL [inaudible] TO SEE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
HI CAN OF TANK -- ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK AND ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SYLVIA CHEESY REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIPS CORPORATION THANK
YOU.
HELLO -- JOHN DORY AND I HAVE A
SON RUN SOLAR -- IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO KARATE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
ANDREY WILL WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT.
JOHNSON JOHNSON WITH PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL SPONSORING A LOS
ANGELES AND WE SUPPORT.
TIFFANY IN REGISTERING SUPPORT
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
NO OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
ONE ONE MOMENT WILL YOU BE
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
YES MANAGER THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL
[inaudible]
NO SECOND.
OKAY.
I I WILL DO THAT IN IN A MINUTE --
I WILL I WILL SECOND YOUR YOUR
BILL TODAY HI.
I'M OKAY WITH.
THE GOVERNMENT PRETTY MANDATES
ONLINE OR TUMOR GIVEN THE MONEY
AND THE STAFF A THEME THAT.
BUT I DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TEN YEAR WINDOW THAT YOU HAVE --
AND THIS BILL TODAY AND SO I'LL
BE TRACKING THIS BILL IF IT
MOVES FORWARD AND I WILL BE
VOTING FOR TODAY AND I DO HAVE
FAITH THAT YOU WILL GET TO A
COMPROMISE THAT.
MAKES A LITTLE MORE SENSE OF
THAT.
WERE NOT THIS INCENTIVIZING
LANDLORDS FROM ALLOWING THIS.
OF ALLOWING TEND TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS OF THIS --
PROGRAM OUT THERE.
BUT I I DO THINK IT'S FAIR GAME
FOR US TO STAY BY GIVE ME SOME
MONEY WE EXPECT TO CERTAIN
THINGS AND THAT SENSE.
I THINK WE HAVE SOME COMMON
GROUND TO BEGIN WITH ALREADY I
DO APPRECIATE THAT IT'S ALL THE
GIVING THIS A SECOND.
IF THERE ARE NO MORE COMMENTS I
WILL LET YOU CLOSE THE MANAGER
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BILL I APPRECIATE YOU UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH -- TODAY TO TAKE THE
MONEY THAT WE HAVE IS A STATE
INVESTED -- BUT NOT DISPLACE A
LOW INCOME FOLKS I WOULD
APPRECIATE OF THE MEMBERS A PEN
WHO ARE HERE TODAY I SHOT A LONG
DISTANCE BUT ALL THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR HAVE A THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B. TWELVE
THIRTY TWO BY MEMBER GLORIA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN.
FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA NOT VOTING
GARCIA NOT VOTING LIMON.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
MELENDEZ NO [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE [inaudible]
STONE.
SO. NINE TWO TWO WE'LL KEEP
THEIR OPEN PRESS THE NUMBERS
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
YEAH.
HI SIMILAR BONTA.
ELEVEN NINETY ONE SORRY.
OKAY YEAH WELL.
ACE FANS ARE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT
JUST A SECOND DOCTOR WOULD YOUR
UP NEXT.
I'M SORRY I'M A GIANTS FAN OKAY.
SO.
OUR DOCTOR WOULD PLEASE PRESENT
BEFORE I GET THROWN OUT I HAVE
COMMITTEE IS A LITTLE LITTLE
KINDER HERE [inaudible]
MY APOLOGIES.
A FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THINK --
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
I'D LIKE TO START BY GREEN TO
TAKE HIM MEN TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
TO RESTORE THE G. O. COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND THANK BOTH
COMMITTEES. FOR SOME CONFUSION
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN PARTLY OUR
FAULT AND WE APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
I KNOW THERE WAS MUCH BACK AND
FORTH IT TOOK A LONG TIME AND IT
THE IN APRIL -- TIMES TIME HARD
TO COME BY WITH THE COMMITTEE IN
THE STAFF SO I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE TUBS FIRE STARTED
IN CALISTOGA IN IN UST UNDER
FOUR UNDER FOUR HOURS SWEPT
TWELVE MILES TO CINEMA COUNTY.
INTO THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA THE
FIRE DESTROYED SPY THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE HOMES
STRUCTURES AND TOOK THE LIVES OF
TWENTY TWO PEOPLE.
NEARLY ALL OF THEM FOR WERE FROM
COMMUNITIES I REPRESENT.
TIME WE FELT THIS SO WE JUST
EXPERIENCE A ONCE IN A
GENERATION TRAGEDY SINCE THEN
THE THOMAS FIRE THE WALLS THE
FIRE CAMP.
CAR FIRES HAVE SADLY PROVEN US
WRONG WE NOW UNDERSTAND THAT WE
EXPERIENCED IN THE TUBS FIRE WAS
NOT A FREAK ACCIDENT WITH THE
PERFECT STORM BUT THE PRODUCT OF
A SYSTEMIC CRISIS.
GENERATIONS OF CLEAR CUTTING FOR
US PHOTO BY FIRE SUPPRESSION BOB
I COMMUNITY SPRAWLING INTO
WILDLANDS ALL EXACERBATED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THIS IS PUT HUNDREDS OF TOWNS IN
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS AT RISK
OF FOR CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES
THIS CRISIS CALLS FOR IMMEDIATE
AND BOLD ACTION WITH A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT.
AND IT HAS TO START WITH THE
HOMES THEMSELVES.
AB THIRTY EIGHT PROPOSES A THREE
PRONGED APPROACH FIRST WE
PROPOSE A REBATE AND NO INTEREST
NO OR LOW INTEREST REVOLVING
LOAN FUND TO HELP PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES TO HOMEOWNERS
TO RETROFIT.
THEIR PREVIOUSLY CONSTRUCTED
HOMES IN VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES.
SECONDLY WE'RE WORKING WITH FIRE
SCIENTISTS AND BUILDING ON THE
CHAIRS AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN
FROM LAST YEAR.
THAT WAS -- TASK THE TEST OF
STATE FARMERS WITH IDENTIFYING
LOW COST REFER FITS.
RESTING HOMEOWNERS TO CERTIFY
THESE RETROFITS HAVE TAKEN PLACE
BEFORE THE HOME IS SOLD.
AND FINALLY WE'RE PROPOSING A
STATE WHILE FIVE PREPAREDNESS
BOARD AND A NETWORK OF REGIONAL
WILDFIRE PREVENTION DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE PLANNING EDUCATIONAL AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO FIRE PRO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THERE ENTITIES OLIVER CALIFORNIA
DOING GREAT WORK PREPARING
COMMUNITIES FOR FIRE BUT IT'S A
VERY INCONSISTENT FROM COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY.
AND IS OFTEN THE CASE THE
COMMUNITIES WITH FEWER RESOURCES
TO SPARE ARE UNFORTUNATELY LESS
REPAIRED.
MEMBERS THIS IS NOT A SILVER
BULLET IS TAKEN AS GENERATIONS
TO GET INTO THIS SITUATION WILL
TAKE US YEARS TO GET OUT OF IT.
BUT I BELIEVE AB THIRTY EIGHT
TRULY MOVES US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
HOW CLOSE BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
AND INTRODUCE -- LIZ.
FORSBERG WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU SO LONG
DAY.
YES IT HAS AND I'M IN A VAN AND
IT'S A REALLY BEEN A LONG DAY TO
HOUSE OF THE SENATE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS LIZ FORCE BURKE AND I'M
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLICY FOR
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
THEY TO CONSERVANCY IS AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE FIRE ADOPTED
COMMUNITIES LEARNING NETWORK A
NATIONAL GROUP WORKING TO BUILD
SUSTAINABLE WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
CAPACITY IN FIRE PRONE
COMMUNITIES.
AND WE'RE HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB.
THIRTY EIGHT LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA SAW THE WORST
WILDFIRES IN HISTORY SETTING NEW
RECORDS FOR THE LARGEST AND MOST
DESTRUCTIVE.
IN THE FACE OF MAKE A FIRES WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO INVEST
IN AND CREATE FIRE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES WELL WE CAN'T STOP
THIS PROP.
OVERNIGHT THERE ARE TWO THINGS
WE DO INVEST IMMEDIATELY TO
BETTER BETTER PROTECT PEOPLE AND
NATURE IN THE FACE OF WILDFIRE
FORCE RESTORATION AND FIRE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES.
CLUSTER CALIFORNIA ONE BILLION
DOLLAR COMMITMENT OF FOREST
HEALTH AND FEELS REDUCTION OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS WE NEED TO
COMPATIBLE INVESTMENT COMMUNITY
PROTECTION PROVIDED BY A. B..
THIRTY EIGHT TO ADAPT OUR
COMMUNITIES TO DEAL WITH THE
ESCALATING THREAT OF FIRES.
IN ADDITION THE REGIONAL
WILDFIRE PREVENTION DISTRICTS
CREATED AN A. B. THIRTY EIGHT
ONE SURE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
HAVE FIRE PROTECTION PLANS AND
ACCESS TO TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
AND ASSISTANCE TO IMPROVE FIRE
SAFETY.
LET'S STOP MAKING HISTORY AND
START FIXING THE PROBLEM THROUGH
BOLD MEASURES LIKE AB.
THIRTY EIGHT WE THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON BE OFFICE THE ARK
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MARK FRENCH MAKER FOR THE
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS ARE
LETTER WAS A LITTLE BIT BEHIND
THE DEADLINE BUT WE TO STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
CIRCUIT US ON BEHALF OF ALL
STATE IN SUPPORT.
JERRY CAN FOR THE OAKLAND --
FIRE CITY COUNCIL AND FOR THE
CLARA CANYON CONSERVANCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS KELLY
COVERAGE OF WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE DID
NOT SUBMIT A LETTER IN TIME FOR
YOU TO REGISTER FOR PRESS YOU
REGISTERED -- IN OPPOSITION BUT
WE HAVE CONTACTED THE AUTHORS
OFFICE WE WILL BE WORKING WITH
THEM TO RESOLVE OUR HOPEFULLY
RESOLVE OUR ISSUES I JUST WANTED
TO BRING IT TO THE ATTENTION OF
THE COMMITTEE.
THAT THIS BILL INTRODUCES A NEW
STANDARD OF DISCLOSURE IN A REAL
ESTATE TRANSACTION THAT COULD
HAVE SOME UNWITTING HOMEOWNERS
BECOME FELONS.
BECAUSE THEY WOULD HAVE TO
DISCLOSE UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY SO WE THINK THAT THAT
COULD PROBABLY EASILY GET
RESOLVED I HOPE -- THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED
AND WE WOULD NOT LIKE TO CREATE
THAT PRESIDENT AND WE ARE ALSO
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
MANDATED COST BURDEN THAT WOULD
BE PLACED UPON AVERAGE HOMES AND
FAMILIES SO.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN RESOLVE THOSE
ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
ST NINE IN QUESTION THE
COMMITTEE.
SEE AN HONEST WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE -- I JUST RESPECT
LAST FOREVER I WAS NOT AWARE
THAT THERE WAS OPPOSITION -- I
KNOW THERE HAVE OUR CONCERNS AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY.
GOING TO WORK WITH EVERYBODY
LESS CONCERN IS COMPLICATED
ISSUE GOING FORWARD I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM ONE A. B. THIRTY EIGHT BY
MEMBER WHAT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN FLORA.
OR NOT VOTING CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA [inaudible]
I LIMON.
MATHIS -- MATHIS NOT VOTING
MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
STONE FIVE SO [inaudible] NINE
THREE ZERO OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ZERO AS A MEMBER BIGELOW.
I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN YES
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
YES SORRY.
MR BIGELOW PRESENTING.
TEN SIXTY SEVEN AB.
TEN SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY I AM
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SIXTY SEVEN I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS.
AB TEN SIXTY SEVEN REQUIRE STATE
PARKS TO DEVELOP A WELFARE FIRE
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
I HAVE SEVERAL PARTS OF MY
DISTRICT THAT NEIGHBOR HOUSES
AND PROPERTY OF MY CONSTITUENTS
AS WELL AS MANY OF YOURS IN FACT
SOME OF YOU UP THERE ARE MY
CONSTITUENTS.
WITH YOUR HOMES -- YET IN THE
STATE PARK AREAS.
AS A FIREFIGHTER I KNOW MORE AS
A FIREFIGHTER OF MORE THAN FOUR
DECADES OF EXPERIENCE I KNOW
FIRST HAND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO BE PREPARED AT EVERY LEVEL.
THIS MAJOR TAKES A SMALL STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION AND WITH THAT I
THANK YOU AND REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
CNN ANY OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MISTER BIGELOWWOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WISH.
PLEASANTLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DID YOU ACCEPT THE COMMITMENTS I
DID I SAID THAT MY VERY --
SECOND SENTENCE JUST CLARIFYING.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY.
HI CAN RELATE TOTALLY TO THIS
SOUNDS SECULAR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AT ELEVEN A. B. TEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY MEMBER BIGELOW THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN WE NEED THE
MACHINE [inaudible]
SORRY [inaudible]
FOR OKAY [inaudible]
AMBER'S FRIEDMAN.
FLORA I FLORA I CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE LIMóN.
MATHIS -- MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MELENDEZ REFUGEE STONE.
SO.
NINE FOUR ZERO BECAUSE FOR BOTH
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] FIVE ZERO SOME
OF MY BONTA.
PRESENTING A LEVIN.
NINETY ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE TODAY.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE CITY OF
OAKLAND AND OAKLAND EIGHTIES
HAVE BEEN WORKING TOGETHER ON A
PLAN FOR PRIVATELY
FINANCED BALLPARK NO PUBLIC
SUBSIDIES THAT WILL ENSURE THE
ETS STAY IN OAKLAND WE ARE PROUD
THAT WE'VE HAD THE IS AN OPEN
FOR FIFTY YEARS AND THEY AND WE
WANT THEM TO STAY FOR FIFTY
YEARS MORE.
AB AND MORE THAN THAT THE AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
HOWARD TERMINAL SITE.
IN OAKLAND TO INCLUDE A BASEBALL
BALLPARK. FOR THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS AS WELL AS MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND RETAIL THIS PLAN LOCATION
WILL INCLUDE A MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT.
THAT WILL PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
WATERFRONT AS WELL AS AN AMAZING
PUBLIC AMENITY. FOR THE CITY OF
OAKLAND IN THE EAST BAY.
AS MANY OF YOU ON THIS COMMITTEE
KNOW THIS PROJECT IS REQUIRED TO
MEET SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS UNPRECEDENTED
STANDARDS LIKE LEGAL
CERTIFICATION FOR THE ENTIRE
PROJECT NET ZERO GHG EMISSIONS
20% TRANSPORTATION EFFICIENCY.
EFFICIENCY WITHIN ONE YEAR OF
COMPLETION.
ADDITIONAL GHG MITIGATION
MEASURES THAT WILL ENSURE 50% OF
THE REDUCTIONS ARE DIRECT.
AND LOCAL.
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE THE HOWARD
TERMINAL SITE CONSIST OF A
PATCHWORK.
OF HISTORIC UPLANDS AND FILLED
FORMER THAILAND'S AS WELL AS
SUBMERGED LANDS THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO OVERSIGHT BY THE PORT OF
OAKLAND.
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION RBC DC.
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE PROVIDES
AUTHORIZATION TO THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION TO DETERMINE THE
TITLE AND BOUNDARY UNCERTAINTIES
AS IT RELATES TO THE HOWARD
TERMINAL SITE AND ALSO TO
APPROVE.
A TRUST EXCHANGE.
THE BILL DOES NOT REMOVE THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION AUTHORITY
TO REVIEW AND APPROVE EITHER THE
PROPOSED EXCHANGE OR THE TRUST
CONSISTENCY.
OF PROPOSE USES ON TRUST LANDS
NOR DOES THIS BILL SEEK TO
REMOVE BC DC'S AUTHORITY.
THE PROJECT REQUIRES A
SIGNIFICANT PERMIT THAT MUST BE
APPROVED BY THE CDS DC AND MUST
BE CONSISTENT WITH THEIR LEGAL
AUTHORITY.
AND THIS PROPOSED BILL.
THE CITY THE ETS THE PORT THE
COMMISSION AND THE CDC HAVE BEEN
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
COOPERATIVELY.
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL AS IT
MOVES TO THE PROCESS.
AND I COMMIT TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU MADAM CHAIR ON
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AS WE
NEGOTIATE THE LANGUAGE OVER THE
COMING WEEKS.
LET ME CONCLUDE BY SAYING THIS
THIS PROJECT MEANS A GREAT DEAL
TO OPEN.
AND THE EAST BAY THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT BASEBALL THE PROJECT
WOULD GENERATE APPROXIMATELY TWO
THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION JOBS.
AND EVEN MORE JOBS WILL BE
CREATED WITH THE OPERATION OF
THE BALLPARK WE ALSO EXPECT
SUBSTANTIAL JOB AND ECONOMIC
GENERATION FROM THE SURROUNDING
USES SUCH AS HOSPITALITY OFFICE
RESTAURANT AND RETAIL JOBS.
AB.
ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS VITAL TO
KEEPING THE OAKLAND ATHLETICS
ROOTED.
IN OAKLAND.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS THE MAYOR OF
OAKLAND LIBBY SCHAAF.
AND DAVE CAVELL PRESIDENT OF THE
OAKLAND ETS AS WELL SATURDAY AT
DIAZ THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
WELCOME IN TWO MINUTES A PIECE
PLEASE [inaudible]
OKAY -- WHAT'S YOUR PERCENT
FRIEDMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AS THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND I
WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROJECT I AM.
YOU KNOW OAKLAND LONG HISTORY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP OF
CHAMPION ARE WORKING WATERFRONT
ARE WORKING CLASS JOBS AND JUST
THE FACT THAT THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT BASEBALL THIS IS A
PRIVATELY FINANCED.
SPORTS PROJECT THAT WILL ALSO
HAVE TREMENDOUS COMMUNITY
BENEFITS INCLUDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING MOSTLY I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS WELL AS
TO ASSURE YOU.
THAT THIS HAS BROAD SUPPORT AND
THAT THIS IS A TREMENDOUS
BENEFIT NOT JUST OAKLAND BUT TO
THE ENTIRE REGION.
THANK YOU DAVE CAVELL PRESIDENT
OF THE OAKLAND ACE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE TIME I ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL WHICH IS.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
OPEN A NEW PRIVATELY FINANCED
BALLPARK AT THE WATERFRONT IN
OAKLAND WE SPENT FIFTY ONE YEARS
IN OAKLAND WE'VE WON WORLD
CHAMPIONSHIPS WE'VE HAD SOME OF
THE GREATEST PLAYERS IN THE
HISTORY OF BASEBALL.
WE WANT TO HAVE MANY GENERATIONS
TO COME OF THAT GREAT BASEBALL
THE COMMUNITY BENEFITS THAT COME
WITH PEOPLE GATHERING AROUND
BASEBALL ACROSS SOCIOECONOMIC
LINES TO ENJOY THE AMERICAN
PASTIME.
SO THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT STEP
FOR US WE'VE COMMITTED TO
PRIVATELY FINANCING THE ENTIRE
PROJECT IT'S GOING TO GENERATE
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
ECONOMIC IMPACT.
OVER TWO THOUSAND CONSTRUCTION
JOBS AND ALL SORTS OF ON GOING
LIVING WAGE JOBS FOR THE
CITIZENS AND COMMUNITY OF
OAKLAND EAST AND WEST.
SO THIS IS A GREAT PROJECT ONE
THAT WERE FULLY BEHIND ONE THAT
WILL KEEP US ROOTED IN OAKLAND
AND WE RESPECTFULLY AXED FOR
YOUR AYE VOTES OF THANK YOU.
I'M SURE MEMBERS SATURDAY AS A
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ABU
THIS PROJECT EMBODIES TRANSIT
ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT.
AND ACTUALLY CREATING THE JOBS
WHERE HOUSING IS GOING TO BE
CREATED I THINK WITH THE LOCAL
HIGHER AGREEMENTS THE ONGOING
SUPPORT THAT THIS PROJECT GOING
TO PROVIDE FOR THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY IS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO PASS UP.
WE ARE WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THE MAN CHAIR WOMAN KEEP DONE ON
BEHALF THE DISTRICT COUNCIL
FARMWORKERS CALIFORNIA AT ECHO
THE BUILDING TRADES JUST SAY
THIS IS A LONG WAY TO GO TO
SUPPORT MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AND
HISTORICALLY UNEMPLOYED
OAKLAND'S WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MIKE MONEGAN AN OAKLAND NATIVE.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF LEXICAL
WORKERS A CALIFORNIA STATE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL IN THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY QUEST REPRESENTING DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
BOB STOKER REPRESENTING NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHEET METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE OF FOUR AS WELL AS THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL OF ALAMEDA COUNTYAND WE
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GIVE A GONZALEZ I'M HERE WITH
THE PORT OF OAKLAND I'M SUPPORT
THE PROCESS WHEN I THINK THE
AUTHOR COMMITTEE STAFF -- AS
WELL AS STATE LAND TO BE CDC FOR
THE WORK ON THE BILL AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
CONCLUDING NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ACE WERE LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS AS THE PROCESS MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD EVENING COUNCILMEMBERS
GLENN LOVE ON BEHALF OF THE IRON
WORKERS UNION LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JOHN SHIELDS SECOND REPRESENTING
DIE HARD FANS DAYS EIGHT DIRE
DAYS FANS EVERYWHERE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
CATHOLIC A STUNNING HOOVER DAVIS
CALIFORNIA AND BASEBALL FAN IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD EVENING HONORABLE MEMBERS
MIKE BARN BOMB -- HAVING.
EXPERIENCE -- WITH THE THIS
PROCESS IN THE PAST WITH
SACRAMENTO AND GETTING THE
SUCCESS OF THE GOLDEN ONE CENTER
OF SACRAMENTO PROUD PROJECT
BUILT THAT IS BIGGER THAN
BASKETBALL -- I AM -- FULLY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
NINETY ONE THANK YOU.
KEVIN TO RELAY I LIVE IN THE
CITY OF OAKLAND AND I SUPPORT.
I'M BRIAN BEVERAGE THE CO
DIRECTOR OF THE WEST OAKLAND
ENVIRONMENTAL INDICATORS PROJECT --
WE HAVE -- MEMORY MINT
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING WITH
THE TEAM TO DEVELOP A A WRITTEN
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY BENEFITS
AGREEMENT.
THAT WILL INCLUDE THINGS LIKE --
FUNDING FOR LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE --
SUPPORT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES SO
THAT PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY MAY
ONE DAY ON THE CONCESSIONS THAT --
THAT THE TEAM USES --
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION.
YEAH SORRY WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
TAKEN THE TESTIMONY SO JUST NAME
AND AFFILIATION WITH THE SUPPORT
BUT THEY HOPE TO SUPPORT IT
THANK YOU.
THE FREEBIRD FOR MARTINEZ
CALIFORNIA I ALSO SUPPORT THIS.
EVIL LIEU BASEBALL FAN IN
SUPPORT.
KEVIN LOVE CASH VALUE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HEY MY NAME IS VINCE BORN IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
EDDIE EISENBERGER OAKLAND
RESIDENT FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CATHERINE ACRE A SPAN I FULLY
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
IT'S HI CALVIN RESIDENT OF
OAKLAND A SPORT THIS BILL.
TRAVIS ALTHOUGH JAY I AM ROOTED
IN OAKLAND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
KAYLA TAYLOR FAN OF THE BASEBALL
TEAM FULL SUPPORT.
DILLON WEBSTER BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THE BILL.
STU HELL FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION TEAMSTERS COMMITTEE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
JAMES MEMORY BECAUSE BAY AREA
RESIDENT FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ROSS MILAN OAKLAND RESIDENT
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MATT PEARL FROM SAN LEANDRO
CALIFORNIA I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- JAKE MEYER FANNED THE IS
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JULIE PARECE SAN FRANCISCO
RESIDENT STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROLINE BERNARDI ACE FAN STRONG
SUPPORT.
LOOK SALAS SLASH LONG A SPAN
SEVEN SQUARE ISN'T FULLY SUPPORT.
MARC BASHAM OAKLAND RESIDENT
FULLY SUPPORT.
THE CITY NO BAY AREA RESIDENTS
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CAITLYN WELSH MAN OF THE ETS AND
I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HAIR COLOR FAMILIES AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LOCAL PERSON BERKELEY RESIDENT
IN SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY CARILLO ACE FAN I FULLY
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL ROGERS OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I FULLY SUPPORT.
LARA KERBER ETS FAN AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OUR PANEL'S BAY AREA LOCAL AS
FOR THE SPELL.
FOUND GROWTH LIVERMORE AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL GO S..
TAZ MCDOWELL OAKLAND RESIDENT
ND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI GLASS RESIDENT OF OAKLAND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
KATIE STREHLOW LIFETIME MAYES
FAN I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE AIRLINES A FAN AND OPEN
RESIDENT I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THE CALL RISE OAKLAND RESIDENT I
FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE ANIMAL.
IS PHËN I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ROSE THEN FILL A SENATOR FOR THE
BILL.
HI THERE IS AN OPEN RESIDENT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MARIAH STEVENSON OAKLAND
RESIDENT I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AMANDA TO MELLOW ALAMEDA
RESIDENT I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS PARRIS OAKLAND
RESIDENT AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STEPHANIE GATEWOOD BAY AREA
RESIDENT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CHARLIE HUNTS A SPENT AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ERICA GEORGE OAKLAND RESIDENT
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BUT IT IS NOT LIKE SET THEM IN
EAST BAY NATIVE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IS HE MAY HAVE FEES SAN LEANDRO
IS AMAZINGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BUT SHE'S.
OVER THE SIZE STRONG ACE FAN AND
I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CHRIS VAN DYNE LIFELONG IS FAN
OAKLAND RESIDENT AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
JACK RALLY OAKLAND RESIDENT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RYAN BRAND IS FAN AND I FULLY
ALSO CANNELLA CASTRO VALLEY
RESIDENT FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
VERONICA REVERSE OAKLAND
RESIDENT FULLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THE NAY GARCIA ACE FAN AND I
FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STEPHANIE TRAN BOARD IN OAKLAND
I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PAUL BASILIO A FAN AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CHEERIO TO IS FAN STRONG WAS FOR
THANK YOU WITH THOSE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL PLEASE COME UP.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY THIS ANYONE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WE CAN TAKE OF UP TO
FOUR BUT IF THIS SUPPORTERS
COULD PLEASE GIVE THEM SOME ROOM
THANK YOU.
AND TWO MINUTES A PIECE PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M BISHOP BOB
JACKSON PASTERNAK'S FULL GOSPEL
CHURCH IN EAST OAKLAND I'M HERE
TO OPPOSE A. B..
ELEVEN NINETY ONE AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE PLANS TO FACILITATE
THE BENEFITS OF DEVELOPMENT OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMERCIAL
REAL ESTATE AND A WORLD CLASS
STADIUM FOR OPEN.
IN REALITY THIS LEGISLATION WILL
HARM CURRENT RESIDENT AS IT
WOULD LEAD TO THE CONSTRUCTION
OF LUXURY HOMES RESIDENTS CANNOT
AFFORD AND THE BAND THE MEN OF
THE EAST OAKLAND COMMUNITY.
THERE IS A LACK OF
PRIORITIZATION ON AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN OAKLAND'S EAST
OAKLAND ESPECIALLY WITH ONLY 7%
OF PROJECTED BUILDINGS RESERVE
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
PUTTING CURRENT RESIDENCE AT
RISK OF BEING PRICED OUT BY
RAPIDLY GROWING BAY AREA PRICING.
GENTRIFICATION IS ONLY WORKS IN
THIS ISSUE AND HAVING BEEN A
PART OF THE STOKE ON FOR DECADES
I CAN SAY WE DO NOT NEED A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION.
THAT WILL ONLY EXACERBATE THE
EFFECTS OF GENTRIFICATION WITH A
LUXURY HOMES IS THAT A FORCE IN
THE CHOICE BETWEEN THE WILL.
THE WELL BEING OF OPEN RESIDENTS
IN A WORLD CLASS STADIUM
SUITABLE FOCUS MAYES AN IDEAL
OPTION IS RE DEBT REDEVELOPING
AND INVESTING IN THE EXISTING.
OAKLAND ALAMEDA COUNTY COLISEUM.
THE COLISEUM HAS BEEN HOME TO
THE OPEN A SINCE THEY PLAYED
THEIR FIRST GAME THERE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX AND BOTH THE
STADIUM AND THE TEAM OR ENTER
CALL PARTS AT LEAST OPENS
IDENTITY AND HISTORY.
IN PARTICULAR THE COLISEUM
BROUGHT WITH IT INITIAL PROMISES
OF NEW PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT
JUSTIFIED USING EMINENT DOMAIN
TO DISPLACE EAKES.
HE'S OAKLAND RESIDENTS MANY
DECADES AGO.
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS
ESSENTIALLY FOR SAKE IN THIS
PART OF EAST OPENS LEGACY A
LEGACY THAT SHOULD BE
REINVIGORATED WITH NEW ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY.
HAVING THE OAKLAND EIGHTIES
REMAIN AND AND REDEVELOP THE
CURRENT SITE WITH ADDITIONAL
HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL REAL
ESTATE WILL HONOR THAT HISTORY
AND REVITALIZED EAST OAKLAND
WITH A WORLD CLASS STADIUM
SURROUNDED BY HOUSING
RESTAURANTS AND ENTERTAINMENT.
IT WOULD BE A MUCH NEEDED
INVESTMENT AND TO THE EAST
OAKLAND COMMUNITY I URGE THE
COMMUNITY TO RECONSIDER A. B.
ELEVEN NINETY ONE FOR THE SAKE
OF CURRENT RESIDENTS WHO CALL
OAKLAND.
THEIR HOME.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT TAKE ABOUT
THE PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION REPRESENT WHICH
CARRIES MARINE TERMINAL OPERATOR
TENANTS AT THE PORT OF OAKLAND --
AND WHERE OPPOSE THIS
LEGISLATION -- BEFORE IT HAPPENS
WITH I WANT.
TO SAY THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA FOR THE THOUGHT
AUTHORS MA'AM IF YOU -- TO WITH
RESPECT WOULD BE CDC LANGUAGE --
OUR OUR CONCERNS ARE ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SITE BEING
POTENTIALLY INCONSISTENT WITH --
THE THE CDC SEAPORT PLAN --
INCONSISTENT WITH THE THAILAND'S
TRUST -- WHAT YOU HEARD FROM THE
BILL'S SPONSORS TODAY --
PRESENTS A PLAN WHICH IS
INCONSISTENT BOTH WITH THE
TITANS TRUST IN THE CURRENT BE
CDC PLAN -- THIS BILL IS NOT
NECESSARY TO TELL THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION HOW DO THEIR
JOB THEY KNOW HOW TO DO THAT.
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT NECESSARY TO
TELL THE CDC TO DO THEIR JOB SO
WE APPRECIATE THOSE AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY THAT THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S INTENDED BY THE
BILL -- THE REASON WHY THOSE
AGENCIES EXISTED TO PROTECT --
WATER FROM RESOURCES BECAUSE
WATERFRONT RESOURCES.
ARE IMPOSSIBLE TO REPLICATE ONCE
THEY'RE GONE THEY'RE GONE.
WE BELIEVE THAT ONCE YOU'VE
REPLACED A WATERFRONT ASSET LIKE
THE HOWARD TERMINAL.
WITH HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL REAL
SAID THE CAN GO ANYWHERE IN THE
US THE STADIUM THAT COULD BE
BUILT.
AT THE CURRENT LOCATION IS
OAKLAND JUST AS WELL THE COULD
BE ANYWHERE ELSE -- THAT YOU'VE
DONE IRREPARABLE HARM TO OUR
BUSINESS YOU'VE DONE A REPROBATE
HARM TO THE REGION AND TO THE
OVERALL ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA WE
CAN'T REPLICATE THE BENEFITS
THAT COME FROM HAVING A WORKING
COURT.
ANYWHERE ELSE EXCEPT ON DEEP
WATER -- AND WE ARE REALLY PROUD
OF WORKING WITH FOLKS IN THE
COMMUNITY LIKE BISHOP -- BUT
ALSO WITH OUR LABOR FORCE OUT OF
YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS PRESENTING A
CASE FOR WHY YOU SHOULD KEEP THE
COMMISSION THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION NBC DC?
AND THE DRIVERS SEAT WITH
RESPECT TO PROTECTING YOUR
INTEREST IN THE TIDELANDS AND
WITH RESPECT PROTECTING THE
STATE'S INTEREST IN MOVING
FORWARD WITH INTERNATIONAL TRADE
ARE PORTENT ASPEN.
pTHANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS LISA AND ALL.
I AM THE CITY OF ADVOCATE.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT.
OF THE INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE
AND WAREHOUSE ASSOCIATION --
WHICH REPRESENTS FOURTEEN LOCAL
UNIONS -- FROM EUREKA TO SALINAS.
WE ARE OPPOSED AB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE BECAUSE THE BILL WOULD
ELIMINATE THE CURRENT PUBLIC
TRUST PROTECTIONS AT HOWARD
TERMINAL. FOR THE ACE BALLPARK
PLAN.
THE PUBLIC PRESS PROTECTIONS
RESERVE BORDER WAYS FOR NATURAL
HABITAT PROTECTION.
IN MARITIME ACTIVITIES
[inaudible]
THEY ALSO.
HAS ALLOWED THE PORTABLE GOING
TO BE ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
IN THE WEST COAST.
OAKLAND SPORT IS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY
AND SEAPORT ACTIVITY.
AT THE PORTS SUPPORTS MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION IN TO WRECK
WAGES AND SALARY PRINTERS REAL
JOBS.
THAT PERSON THAT SUPPORT THE
LANGUAGE FOR MANY AREA RESIDENTS.
OF THIS JOB TOTAL COMES TO ABOUT
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND REGION WIDE.
THE EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND
REGIONAL JOBS 20% OR SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND OF THOSE JOBS ARE IN
THE CITY OF OAKLAND.
LET'S SAY THAT THE CON HOLD THE
MIKE.
HELLO BUT THE OKAY.
HELLO THERE ALRIGHT I WON'T HOLD
IT.
SO THE LEGISLATION FAILS TO
ADDRESS POLICIES TO MAKE TO
MAINTAIN CURRENT MARITIME
INDUSTRY JOBS IN THE PORT AREA.
IT DOES NOT ADDRESS ABOUT PER
AREA BETWEEN THE WORKING POOR IN
THE PROPOSED RESIDENTIAL HOUSING.
THE BILL IS ALSO LACKING
REALISTIC SOLUTIONS TO FREIGHT
TRANSPORTATION CONGESTION.
OUR MARITIME WORKFORCE
REPRESENTS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
SKILLED IN HIGHLY SPECIALIZED
BLUE COLLAR.
LABOR IN NORTH AMERICA.
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT THE
CITY OF OAKLAND IN A SPORT
COMMISSIONS SEEM TO BE SEEM TO
HAVE A NEW VISION OF THE PORT.
THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE US THIS IS
TROUBLING CONCERNING THE REDUCE
PORT AREA MEANS REDUCE WORK
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE MARITIME
WORKING COMMUNITY.
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT
ENDORSE THE REMOVAL OF THE
THAILAND STRESS FROM THE
WATERFRONT PROPERTY WITHIN THE
PORT OF OAKLAND OR ALLOW FOR THE
CREATION OF A HOUSING.
SLASH OFFICE SLASH STADIUM
BEGINS WHEN HE'S BEEN ALONG.
YOUR TIME IS UP IF YOU CAN
FINISH UP WHICH IS COMPLETELY
INCONSISTENT WITH THE PUBLIC
TRUST ARE WORKING WATERFRONT
RESPECTIVELY AS A YOU PROTECT
THE PORT OF OAKLAND.
IN OUR MARITIME RELATED JOBS
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS I MARIN PIN IT ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHORE AND WAREHOUSE UNION --
ONE THING TO CONSIDER HERE IS
THAT THE SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL
I TALK ABOUT JOB CREATION FOR US
IS A JOB ELIMINATION IN THE LONG
RUN AS IT.
AFFECTS THE POOR ACTIVITIES I
DESIRE AS WE FACE TECHNOLOGY HAS
WE WE START TO FACE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES YOUR EVENTUALLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR WILL BE PUT OUT
OF A JOB AND IS THERE JOBS THE
CANNED BEEF AT REPLACE.
DOES JOBS YOU CAN JUST TRAIN
SOMEONE AND SAY WE'LL FIND YOU A
JOB SOMEWHERE ELSE AGAIN --
FAMILIES HAVE DEPENDED ON THIS
JOBS AND WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
THOSE JOBS OTHERWISE WE'D END UP
WITH A POPULATION THAT.
CAN'T PUT THE KIDS TO COLLEGE
CAN BY HOUSING SO AGAIN WE'RE
PICKING.
ONE GROUP OF CHUCK ONE A GROUP
OF JOBS OVER ANOTHER -- ANOTHER
PIECE SO WE ASKED FOR A WE ASK
FOR IN A NOBLE.
THANK YOU THOSE WISHING -- TO
VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION THE BILL
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
JUST NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
WANT TO GET IN YOUR POSITION.
MY NAME IS NOT WILL MAKE A IN
THE PRESIDENT I'LL GIVE YOU
LOCAL.
TEN AYE OPPOSED THANK YOU.
AARON RIGHT BUSINESS AGENT I W.
LOCAL.
TEN PLEASE VOTE NO.
JOHN CASTANO THIRTY THREE YEAR
MEMBER VILE W. LOCAL TEN WITH
FOUR GENERATIONS MY FAMILY.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ROBERT ESTRADA REGIONAL DIRECTOR
OF THE INLAND OPENS UNION AND
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING THE EAST
OAKLAND STADIUM LANCE.
AND BY VIRTUE OF SUPPORTING EAST
OAKLAND AND OUR PORT.
BY DEFINITION I'M OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ROBERT DE BRADFORD JUNIOR.
I W. VICE PRESIDENT I'M OPPOSE
THIS.
C..
I. O. W. -- MEMBER.
I OPPOSE THIS BILL IT WILL CALLS.
US ALL A LOT OF MONEY FOR
MATERIALS. THREE TIMES AS MUCH
FROM LA OR ANOTHER STATE IF YOU
CLOSE IF YOU VOTE YES THANK YOU.
GAIL NELSON.
I L. W. YOU'LL LOCAL TEN I DO
NOT OPPOSE THE BILL.
SHARING THEIR I. O. W..
I NEED MY JOB AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
FAR LESS DALY LOCAL TEN
SECRETARY TREASURER THREE
GENERATIONS AND AND PLEASE VOTE
NO.
GOOD AFTERNOON FRANK ASKING NOW
THE BEAUTIFUL TEN BUSINESS AGENT
GIANT FAN -- OPPOSES BILL THANK
YOU.
I AM SUSAN TERRY LOCAL SEVENTY
FIVE I. O. W. USE I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. FIFTEEN HARLEY KING.
NUMBER IW LOCAL.
TEN OPPOSES BILL BECAUSE IT DOES
NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND GLOBALLY CONNECTED ECONOMY
THANK YOU.
PLEASE JUST NAME FILIATION AND
WITH YOU OPPOSE.
AFTER GIPSON I W. YOU LOCAL TEN
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GEORGE FOR ERA I'LL TELL YOU
LOCAL TEN APPLES THIS BILL.
NOT ROOM IN CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION OPPOSE THE MEASURE.
JOSH WAS SHOT FOR SENATOR STEEL
INDUSTRIES OPPOSE.
Q. SHANKLIN ISLE W. THIRTY FOUR
IN ON THE FACE OF HIS BILL AND I
OPPOSE IT.
IF YOU WALL WITH THE CUSTOMS
BROKER SUPPORTERS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND PLEASE STILL SHORT CHANGE
THE PROCESS.
OR THE RESIDENTS.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW.
IT WOULD BRUCE I W..
LOCAL TEN AYE OPPOSED HIS BILL.
CHRISTINE SEMINAR ALL LOCAL
NINETY ONE VICE PRESIDENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MASTER DARREN BEREN OPEN
RESIDENT FOR REASONS STATED AYE
OPPOSED THE BILL.
GOOD EVENING PASTOR L. J.
JENNINGS KINGDOM BILLS CHRISTIAN
FELLOWSHIP AS WELL AS PRESIDENT
OF THE BE A COMMUNITY BENEFIT
ORGANIZATION WHICH IS A
CONSORTIUM OF CHURCHES IN
OAKLAND AS WELL AS ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ARE TWENTY ONE ELSE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY WITHOUT OUR TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANYBODY HAVE -- I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS -- MY FIRST IS FOR
ANY OF THE OF THE OPPONENTS WHO
WISH TO SPEAK WHICH IS IF
ANYBODY KNOWS WHEN THE LAST TIME
THAT THE CDC ALLOWED ANY HOUSING
I'M BE FILL.
AND WHAT OF THE CDC'S GOALS FOR
THE REGULATION OF BAY FILL OUR
AND IF THERE'S ANY OTHER
PROPOSALS THAT ANYONE KNOWS
ABOUT ABOUT BE FILL A PROPOSALS
FOR HOUSING.
THANK YOU THAT'S A THAT'S A VERY
CONFERENCE A QUESTION I'M NOT
SURE HAVE A CONFERENCE OF ANSWER
FOR IT BUT I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY IN THE SEAPORT PLAN -- THERE
IS NO ACCOMMODATION FOR HOUSING --
WE'VE HAD BILLS LIKE THIS IN THE
PAST WITH RESPECT TO OTHER PORTS
IN THE BAY AREA -- THERE HAVE
NOT BEEN ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
HOUSING WITHIN THE THE BAY FILL.
AND AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW -- BUT
MAY NOT UNDER THE NEXT YEAR
PATRICK SACK WITH SET UP THE CDC
WHEN YOU BUILD ON PHIL.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY STILL BUILDING
IN THE BACK -- SO THAT'S WHY THE
CDC WORD RETAINS JURISDICTION
AND SO HOUSING IS NOT ALLOWED ON
PHIL.
WHETHER YOU'RE PART OF THE SEA
PORT PLAN OR NOT -- SO THAT'S
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE THE
JURISDICTIONAL PROBLEMS MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE BILL -- IS THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
ASSERT A RIGHT TO BUILD HOUSING.
ESSENTIALLY WITHIN THAT THE BAY
ENVELOPE WITHIN THE BC DC
JURISDICTION THAT CERTAINLY
PROBLEMATIC.
THANKS.
AND THEN THE AUTHOR ON THE ACE
OF STATED CLEARLY IN A NUMBER OF
PUBLIC MEETING SOMETHING TO THE
EFFECT THAT.
THEY'RE NOT TAKING STATE
LEGISLATION TO CIRCUMVENT
EXISTING ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS AND
THEIR NOT SEEKING -- TO AND RUN
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION OR BC
DC -- AND I WANTED TO JUST --
CLARIFY THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
COMMIT TODAY THAT YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE SEEKING ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS IN THE FUTURE THAT
ARE GOING TO CIRCUMVENT EITHER
AT THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION OR
THE B. CDC PROCESS.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY AND THAT IF
THE BILL CHANGES SUBSTANTIALLY
YOU'LL BE WILLING TO BRING IT
BACK TO OUR COMMITTEE SO THAT WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO EVALUATE ANY OF
THOSE CHANGES MORE THAN HAPPY.
TO THANK YOU -- I WANTED TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING THE
LANGUAGE -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT LIMIT THE
AUTHORITY OF THE B. C. B. C.
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
ISSUES HERE AND YOU KNOW QUITE
HONESTLY THE MERITS OF THE
PROJECT OR NOT REALLY I THINK
THE COMMITTEE'S CONCERN IT'S A
LOCAL JURISDICTION BUT IT IS OUR
CONCERN. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC PROCESS IS RESPECTED BUT
THE PUBLIC HAS A CHANCE TO WEIGH
IN ON THAT THE CDC AND STATE
LANDS ALSO.
HAS THEIR FULL SCOPE OF
AUTHORITY -- TO EVALUATE -- THE
PROJECT AND BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
THE BILL MAKES THAT CLEAR THAT
THEY'RE NOT CIRCUMVENTING THAT
AUTHORITY I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
AND I CERTAINLY ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE OPPONENTS -- TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS A YOU KNOW A
FULL HEARING AT ALL OF THE
VARIOUS ISSUES -- AND AGAIN I I
THINK EVERYBODY FOR COMING TO
TESTIFY IN ALL OF YOUR YOU KNOW
CONSERVE YOUR COMMUNITY AND ALL
OF YOUR ACTIVISM AND EVERYONE
WHO LINED UP AND RODE BUSES AND
HOPEFULLY TRAINS TO GET HERE
TODAY SO THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT -- IS THERE A
YEAH.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
OKAY THAN A ROLL CALL PLEASE --
DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE I'M SORRY
I I I I APPRECIATE YOU
HIGHLIGHTED WHAT YOU DID AROUND
THE FACT THAT THE CDC AND STATE
LANDS.
ARE FIRMLY IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT
THAT WE HEARD THAT FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT THEY SHOULD BE
THEY ARE THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
BE THAT IS THEIR ROLE.
WE HONOR THAT ROLEWE WANT THAT
ROLE TO CONTINUE IT'LL HELP US
GET -- TO AN APPROPRIATE --
PROJECT SHOULD BE APPROVED IF
THE AND WE ALSO HEARD SOME
CONCURRENT ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING JUST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BEING PROPOSED TO BE BUILT AT
THE HOWARD FROM THE SITE AS WELL
AS THAT THE CURRENT SITE IN EAST
OAKLAND COLISEUM SITE WE THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
CITY OF OAKLAND.
AND ITS FUTURE -- WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS -- THIS IS A A
PROCESS RIGHT NOW THAT'S MOVING
FORWARD WITH MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS AT THE TABLE IT
WILL BE A BETTER PROCESS AND A
STRONGER PROCESS BECAUSE OF THE
STAKEHOLDER INVOLVEMENT.
AND WE COMMITTEE GETTIN IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS GOING FORTUNE WE GET
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
AN FIFTEEN A. B. ELEVEN NINETY
ONE BY MEMBER BONTA THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA AYE LORA AYE CHAU
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING LIMóN.
Là M<c.cyan> NOT VOTING MATHIS --</c>
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
I WAS MISTER SANTIAGO HERE -- IS
MISTER O'DONNELL HERE.
I DON'T SEE MISTER O'DONNELL
JUST KIDDING.
OKAY.
YOU ARE HERE FOR TWELVE SIXTY
TWO AND SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR YES
LIKE TO GO AHEAD WITH -- TWELVE
SIXTY TWO PERFECT BOXES TO AND
IF IF PEOPLE CAN PLEASE TRY TO
REFRAIN FROM SPEAKING UNTIL YOU
LEAVE THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU.
ARE YOU A YOU READY WE ARE READY
I THANK YOU.
YOU'RE DOING WELL IT'S BEEN A
LONG DAY MANAGER -- THANK YOU A
MANAGER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWELVE
SIXTY TWO WHICH REQUIRES AN
UPDATE.
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S SUSTAINABLE
FREIGHT ACTION PLAN BY JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN EVERY FIVE
YEARS THEREAFTER MOVE THE BILL.
I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE 15%
ALLOCATION A CAP AND TRADE
PROCEEDS TO THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
TRUCK BUS AN OFF ROAD VEHICLE
QUOTE AND AND TECHNOLOGY PROGRAM.
I WILL CONTINUE TO PURSUE
FUNDING FOR THIS VITAL PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
WANT TO POINT OUT HOW IMPORTANT
MULTI YEAR FUNDING IS TO
ACHIEVING OUR OVER ARCHY ARCHING
SUSTAINABLE FREIGHT AND CLEAN
AIR GOALS.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN GOVERNOR BROWN
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
CALLING FOR CALIFORNIA ITS
TRANSITION TO A MORE EFFICIENT
AND MORE.
ECONOMICALLY COMPETITIVE IN LESS
POLLUTING FREIGHT TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM.
EXECUTIVE ORDER DIRECTED KEY
STATE AGENCIES TO DEVELOP A
CALIFORNIA'S SUSTAINABLE.
FREE ACTION PLAN TO WRITE SHORT
AND LONG TERM GOALS FOR STATE
AGENCIES TO CONSIDER WHEN
PLANNING FOR FREIGHT
SUSTAINABILITY.
THE PLAN WAS AN UNPRECEDENTED
EFFORT TO INTEGRATE INVESTMENTS
POLICIES IN VARIOUS PROGRAMS TO
HELP.
REALIZE A SINGULAR VISION FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ENTIRE FOR ITS
SYSTEM.
GIVEN THE FREIGHT SECTOR
CONTINUED CONSTANTLY ADJUSTING
TO MEET.
EVER CHANGING SYSTEM DEMANDS IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT THIS PLAN
KEEPS PACE WITH INCREDIBLY
DYNAMIC SYSTEM IT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE ON AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO
REAFFIRMS OUR COMMITMENT TO
TRANSFORM THE FREIGHT SYSTEM.
BY CALLING UPON THE SAME KEY
STATE AGENCIES TO UPDATE THE
STATE SUSTAINABLE FREIGHT PLAN.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
RYAN SHOE SHARD WITH CAL STAR
AND I HOPE I PRONOUNCED YOUR I
DO.
PRETTY GOOD PRETTY GOOD THING
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING AT CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M RIGHT YOU
AREN'T ON THE HALF CAL START
WERE TECHNOLOGY CONSORTIUM
THAT'S BEEN WORKING THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO BUILD THE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS CLIMATE
GOALS HAVE GIVEN RISE TO A
RENAISSANCE IN VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING HERE COMPANIES ARE
NOW SETTING UP SHOP IN
CALIFORNIA TO RESEARCHED DESIGN
BUILD.
RESEARCH IS AN AND BILL CLEAN
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES ACROSS ALL
VEHICLE CLASSES COMPANIES LIKE
FOR TERRA MOTIVE B. Y. DE CHANGE
GREEN POWER AND COMMENTS ARE
JUST A FEW THE MANUFACTURERS
HAVE COME HERE CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE GROWING BECAUSE OF CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE
JUST THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
AS A RESULT MANY NEW VEHICLE
CLASSES IN THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY SPACE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
WERE BECOMING ARE ALREADY BECOME
COMMERCIALIZED.
AS LONG AS THE STATE'S STAYS THE
COURSE OF THIS KIND OF
COMMITMENTS THESE TRENDS ARE NOT
ONLY CONTINUE BUT INCREASE.
AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO IS THE NEXT
LOGICAL STEP IN OUR STATE
PLANNING EFFORTS TO KEEP
RATIONING DOWN A VEHICLE
EMISSIONS DEVELOPING AS A SAMPLE
FREIGHT SYSTEM AND SIGNALING TO
MANUFACTURERS AND POLICE THAT WE
ARE NOT BACKING DOWN FROM A
CLINIC MINUTES.
INCENTIVE MONEY FOR CAPTURED IS
ALSO CRITICAL TO SUPPORTING THE
COMMERCIALIZATION PROCESS
REQUIRES TWO THINGS ONE DECISION
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS TO CREATE THE
INDUCEMENTS NEEDED FOR COMPANIES
TO KEEP BUILDING THE PIPELINE
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY.
AND UBER TO GUARANTEEING INVEST
IN MULTIPLE YEARS OUT THAT'S
BECAUSE IT TAKES MANUFACTURES
FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS TO TO BRING
A NEW PRODUCT TO MARKET THEIR
UNLIKELY TO START THE PROCESS
UNLESS THEY CAN LOOK OUT.
AND HAVE A CLEAR PICTURE OF THE
DEMAND PARTNERSHIPS AVAILABLE
OVER THAT TIME FRAME.
BUSINESSES ARE MAKING INVESTMENT
DECISIONS ON A LONG TERM BASIS
THE STATE NEEDS TO MORE CLOSELY
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATIONS FOR
CLEAN VEHICLE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS
WITH THESE INVESTMENT CYCLES.
AND WHICH WOULD HELP BRING MORE
THESE VEHICLES TO THE MARKET
FASTER FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
Q. ANY OTHER PERSONS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
FOR THE COALITION FOR NO ABOUT
NATURAL GAS AND SUPPORT.
MARYLAND GOVERNOR TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL PENINSULA THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSITION OF A SUPPORT POSITION
ON THE PREVIOUS VERSION THE BILL
WILL BE LOOKING AT IT AND DO ONE
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE FONG
GOING APPROPRIATIONS -- FOR
BRINGING ELECTRIC VEHICLES UNTIL
TO TO TO LIGHT -- IN
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE NOT TAKING
ANY MORE TESTIMONY JUST NAME AND
A TWEENER ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION
DOES HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL.
IN SUPPORT OF INTEGRATED TO
SAMPLE FREE PLANNING THINK GOT
IT THANK YOU.
I A RYAN KENNEY CLEAN ENERGY IN
SUPPORT.
I THOMAS LAWSON ON BEHALF OF THE
BODY ENERGY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
AFTER GAS VEHICLE COALITION
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE ALSO WERE THROWING CAL
CHAMBER IN SUPPORT.
OUR MARK A PREY ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
MAR INTERNET ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE AND
WAREHOUSE UNION SUPPORT THANK
YOU MISTER O'DONNELL FOR
CONTINUE BRING FUNDS TO THE
PORTS TO A CLEAN ENVIRONMENT.
PERSONALLY COULD US HERE ON
BEHALF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND THE PART OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SING NUMBER GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
ANYBODY.
NO OKAY THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR I WOULD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THAT'S WHEN I WROTE.
GREAT GREAT CLOSE -- THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US IN THE
COMPANY AMENDMENTS -- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND CANAVERAL
CALL PLEASE ITEM NINETEEN AB
TWELVE SIXTY TWO BY MEMBER
O'DONNELL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA I'D CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
READ THROUGH TREES.
STONE. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
AND YOU HAVE A BE.
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS IDENTIFIED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL A LOT OF BILLS
TODAY IN FACT.
I AM PLEASED TO RESENT AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR WHICH WILL
EXPAND THE TERRITORY OF THE SAN
GABRIEL LOWERS RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY. TO
INCLUDE THE TO MAKE THIS CHANNEL
WATERSHED AND CATALINA ISLAND.
SINCE ITS ESTABLISHMENT TWENTY
YEARS AGO THE RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY HAS
SUCCESSFULLY PURSUED A MISSION
OF PRESERVING OPEN SPACE AND
HABITAT WHILE FACILITATING
PUBLIC ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA'S
WILDERNESS AND WILDLIFE.
BY PROVIDING GRANTS TO VARIOUS
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE THE
TERRITORY IN EASTERN LOS ANGELES
AND WESTERN ORANGE COUNTY.
THE CONSERVANCY HAS IMPROVED
WATERSHEDS RESTORED WILDLIFE
HABITAT AND PROVIDED NUMEROUS
OUTDOOR RECREATIONAL AND
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
WELL THE CONSERVANCY HAS HAD
GREAT SUCCESS WITH NUMEROUS
PROJECTS WITHIN ITS TERRITORY
SEVERAL NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES.
HAVE NOT HAD THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE DIMMING IS CHANNEL WATERSHED
LOCATED ON THE EAST ON TO THE
EAST OF LOS ANGELES RIVER IS ONE
AREA WITH SEVERAL COMMUNITIES IN
NEED.
INCLUDING PORTIONS OF INGLEWOOD
CARSON TORRANCE ST PETER AND
SEVERAL OTHER COMMUNITIES THE
DIMMING IS WATERSHED IS HEAVILY
DEVELOPED.
AND SEVERELY LACKING AND
PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE OPEN SPACE.
ANOTHER NEARBY OTHER NEARBY IT
THEY AND OTHER NEARBY AREAS YOU
NEED US CATALINA ISLAND.
WELL NOT IN NEED OF OF MORE OPEN
SPACE ACCESS TO THAT -- WHEN
SPACE CAN PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE ADDITIONALLY THE
ISLANDS DEPENDENCE ON THE
VOLATILE TOURISM INDUSTRY MAKES
IT DIFFICULT TO SERVE
CONSTITUENT LONG TERMS TO
SERVICE CONSISTENT LONG TERM
FUNDING FOR OPEN?
SPACE OR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS THE SAN GABRIEL RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY IS UNIQUE
IS IN A UNIQUE POSITION. TO HELP
THESE AREAS AND EXPAND THEIR
MISSION OF PRESERVING
COMMUNITIES ACCESS TO THOSE
AMENITIES.
AB SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR WILL
ALLOW THEM TO DO EXACTLY THAT.
BY EXPANDING THEIR TERRITORY TO
COVER THESE AREAS AND GREATER
SERVICE THE CITIZENRY OF THESE
AREAS HERE JUST TESTIFIES MARK
STANLEY FROM THE RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
THANK YOU.
THE ARTSY AS OUTLINED BY THE SAY
GET REAL MOUNTAINS THE WATERSHED
OF THE SAME GAME -- RIVER FROM
ITS HEADWATERS TO THE OUTLET AT
THE PACIFIC OCEAN IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
THE LOWER HALF THE LOS ANGELES
RIVER BELOW THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES TO THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH.
ADDITION OF A SAID A KILLER
SENATE CANDIDLY THE ISLANDS AND
AND TO MAKE EYE SHADOW WATERSHED
SHARE MANY OF THE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE EXISTING
CONSERVANCY BOUNDARIES.
THE NATURAL ENVIRONMENT AND VERY
HIGH NEED.
WITHIN KNOWING COM PARK FOR
COMMUNITIES ARE NO DIFFERENT
THAN.
WHAT THE CONSERVANCY CURRENTLY
PROVIDES RESOURCES TO THE
INCLUSION OF SENATE -- CATALINA
ED DOMINGUEZ -- WHAT A SHED
REPRESENTS LESS THAN?
A 4% INCREASE IN THE RESOURCE
AREA OF THE CONSERVANCY OF ITS.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED SQUARE MILES --
THIS PROPOSAL TAKES IN INGLEWOOD.
IT AREA THE FIVE BY LESS THAN
POINT.
EIGHT PARTS PER ACRE PER ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE CITY OF
CARS SEND WITH ONE POINT. FIVE
ACRES FOR ONE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HARBOR
GATEWAY COMMUNITIES WITH LESS
THAN POINT.
FOR ACRES PER ONE THOUSAND
PEOPLE A PARK LAND.
THE FOR CATALINA -- THE CATALINA
ISLAND CONSERVANCY IN THE CITY
OF AVALON -- PLANS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE CONSERVANCY
AND ITS EFFORTS TO CONSERVE.
EDUCATE AND PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY
FOR LOW IMPACT RECREATION.
THE TIMING OF THIS ACTION
APPEARS APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
ARM C. WAS FORMED IN NINETEEN
NINE NINE THROUGH SB TWO SIXTEEN
TWENTY YEARS AGO.
IT IS DUE FOR A WIN -- REVIEW OF
ITS OPEN SPACE PLAN THE
INCLUSION OF CATALINA AND THAT
DIDN'T DOMINGUEZ CHANNEL.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNE TIME TO BE
INCLUDED.
YEAH THAT ANALYSIS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
AND I'M SURE MEMBERS CONDUCT
USED TO REPRESENT THE WATERSHED
CONSERVATIONAUTHORITY.
THE TWO IN SUPPORT SIX THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK JUST
COME TO THE MIKE PLEASE.
WITHOUT BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
AVALON IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
NO WOULD YOU LIKE A DISCURSIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER DONALD I'LL BE
VOTING FOR YOUR BILL -- AND I
DID GET TO SPEAK TO MR SALLY
EARLIER INSISTS.
UNEXPECTED UNANSWERED WHAT'S
WANNA MAKE A COMMENT -- I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE'RE
EXPANDING TERRITORY THAT
COMMUNITIES ALONG THE LA RIVER
ARE NOT GOING TO BE IMPACTED AND
LOSING RESOURCES.
ALONG THE WAY INSIGHTS ON ECHO
THAT CONCERN AND I HAVE FAITH
THAT THE CONSERVANCY WILL FIGURE
IT OUT.
ALONG THE WAY THAT FOR THE SAKE
OF I DON'T WANT TO SEE I FORGOT
TO SAY SOMETHING.
THANK YOU.
IF I COULD RESPOND -- ELEVEN I
THINK THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION THIS AND I DON'T HAVE
AN INTEREST IN IN IN IN IN UNDER
FUNDING MY OWN AREA AS WELL.
BUT THE WAY I SEE THIS GOING
FORWARD WORKING OUT GOING
FORWARD IS THIS IS GOING THE
SPEED OF THE WHEN THE WHEN THE
MONEY IS DECIDED HOW MUCH MONEY
EACH CONSERVANCY.
IS GOING TO GET THERE SOME
POLICY BUT THERE'S ALSO SOME
POLITICS TO BE QUITE FRANK WITH
YOU.
AND I THINK WHERE WE'RE
EXPANDING WILL HELP US WITH THE
POLITICAL AND CERTAINLY THE
POLICY AND TO AND ALSO SERVE.
THE PEOPLE.
IN THE EXPANDED AREA.
THE MEASURE OF AN OFFICER
STANLEY WANTED COMMON MADAM
CHAIR OR I CONCUR.
OKAY.
PASSING THE WEATHER OF QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CLASS
RIVAL.
THANK YOU -- HAPPINESS FOR YOUR
BILL TODAY -- WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
ITEM THIRTY AB SIXTEEN NINETY
FOUR BY MEMBER O'DONNELL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ WROTE TO TREAT STONE.
FIVE ZERO WE HAVE FIVE VOTES
LIBERAL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY.
MISTER SANTIAGO HERE.
OKAY THEN WITH A MISS CARILLO
EUROPE NEXT.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THAT WILL.
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU HOW
WILL CREATE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF -- FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL AND
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
AS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS OFTEN FACE A RANGE
OF SINCERE CHALLENGES RE
INTEGRATING BACK INTO SOCIETY.
SUCH AS REDUCE TIES TO THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES AS WELL
AS LOWER LEVELS OF EDUCATION
LITERACY THAT SERVICE BURIALS
BARRIERS FOR GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
IN CALIFORNIA THOUSANDS OF AND
MADE TO SERVE AND HAD SOMEONE
HAND CREWS.
AT WILDFIRE SCENES AREPAID ONLY
ONE OR TWO DOLLARS A DAY WE HAVE
SEEN THIS AND THE NEWS
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE FACE THE
NEW NORMAL IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY DO THE VERY IMPORTANT
WORK OF HELPING TO MANAGE
MASSIVE WILDFIRES INCLUDING
THOSE THAT RECENTLY WITH.
RAGE THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL
ENSURE THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS
CAN UTILIZE THEIR SKILLS -- THAT
THEY HAVE ATTAINED WHILE DOING
THIS WORK.
AFTER THEY ARE RELEASED OUR
STATE IS IN NEED OF A DYNAMIC
WORKFORCE TO ENGAGE IN CRITICAL
AND COST EFFECTIVE DEFENSE
AGAINST NATURAL RESOURCES. FOR
THE REPORTS SOME OF THE HIGHEST
RECIDIVISM RATES IN THE NATION
WE ARE.
IN A PLACE WHERE WE MUST
CULTIVATE PROGRAMS THAT FOR TO
FORWARD THINKING METHODS OF
OVERCOMING BARRIERS TO RE
INTEGRATION.
THE BILL AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
OR CREATES AN EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT REENTRY PROGRAM TO BE
OVERSEEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORD TO PROVIDE
HOPE AND OPPORTUNITY. FOR
FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS BY OFFERING THE TRUE
PATH TO A LIVING WAGE.
THAT OUR STATE CAN MOVE FORWARD
IN INSURING THE CRITICAL
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT OF THAT OUR
STATE NEEDS.
SO HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS
KRISTI PALMA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY THEM ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
WE'RE ACTUALLY PLEASED AND
HONORED TO BE SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE.
WE THINK IT BUILDS UPON THE WORK
OF MS EGGMAN IN THE FOREST YOU
COR CRUISE.
UP MY FIREFIGHTERS BEEN DAYS AND
WEEKS ON THE LINES IT'S BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED BY ALL OF YOU AND
SUPPORTED -- FOR BATTLING WILD
FIRES THAT ARE FUELED BY THESE
EXTRAORDINARY FUEL THAT OUR IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
AND WE HAVE A DESPERATE NEED FOR
WORK FORCE HERE AND WE THINK
THAT S. A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT MEETS THAT NEED AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO MITIGATE THE
STRENGTH OF THESE FIRES GOING
FORWARD WHICH IS A SAFETY ISSUE
FOR MY MEMBERS.
IF WE CAN STOP THESE BEFORE THEY
START.
EVERYBODY WINS COMMUNITIES
WITHIN BY MEMBERS GET TO RETURN
THEIR FAMILY SOONER -- AND
CALIFORNIA'S BETTER REPRESENTED
SO I KNOW THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS DISCUSSES POLICY IS
DISCUSSED THE ISSUE IN BUDGET
HEARINGS ABOUT NEEDING A WORK
FORCE AND NOT HAVING AND HAVING
IT TAPPED OUT.
AND AS MY AUTHOR VERY CLEARLY
IDENTIFIED.
WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
DEVELOPED THE SKILLS AND WOULD
NEED AN OPPORTUNITY TO USE THEM
AND EXPAND UPON THEM AND GET
SOME EDUCATION AND STABILITY IN
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY SO THEY CAN
SUCCESS FOR RE RE ENTER SO WE
THINK IT'S A GREAT PARTNERSHIP.
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
WISHING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
OKAY IS THERE ANYBODY WANTING TO
VOICE ANY OPPOSITION.
A WITHOUT A BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE -- ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
I'M A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I'VE A
MANAGER THANK YOU THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT BILL AND I'M VERY
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND CANAVERAL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY MEMBER CARILLO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN AYE
FLORA CHAU EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
MON I MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY MELENDEZ FRONT
TO TREAT.
STONE. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
BELIEVE THE ROLE OF AND THANK
YOU.
OKAY MISTER SANTIAGO I DO NOT
SEE -- MISTER GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I WILL
BE BRIEF I KNOW WE HAD A LONG
HEARING ON THIS LAST TWO WEEKS
AGO -- AND I WILL JUST BRIEFLY
PRESENT ON THE AMENDMENTS.
AGAIN THIS IS AB FOR THIRTY THE
CAMPFIRE HOUSING ASSISTANCE ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
WHICH CREATES A NARROWLY APPLIED
STREAMLINED APPROVAL PROCESS.
FOR BUILDING HOMES IN THE AREA
IN THE REGION AFFECTED BY THE
CAMPFIRE -- MINUTES HAVE
NARROWED THE BILL TO APPLY ONLY
TO SPECIFIC CITIES IN THE REGION.
ADDITIONALLY I'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OUTLINED BY THE SIERRA
CLUB.
AND IN WORKING WITH THE CHAIR WE
HAVE ALSO COME WITH ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS.
A MODIFIED VERSION OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS.
WHICH THE CHAIR AND I HAVE
AGREED UPON WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
A MINIMUM DENSITY LIMIT OF FOUR
UNITS PER ACRE.
LET ME DEVELOPMENTS TO WITHIN
CITY LIMITS OR SPECIALIZE
RESIDENTIAL PLANNING AREAS --
FIFTY ACRE OF MAXIMUM ACREAGE
AND REQUIRING DEVELOPMENTS TO
ACHIEVE SUSTAINABILITY RADIANCE.
ABOVE THE MANDATORY BUILDING
STANDARDS -- SO WITH THAT I
WOULD ASK FOR RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL AND APPRECIATE --
COMMITTEE STAFF AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS BILL I THINK
WE'VE I THINK WE'VE GOT A GOOD
PRODUCT HERE SO I'D APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER WITNESSES --
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL PLEASE COME A
MICROPHONE.
LIKE IT DOES HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY A FEW IN SUPPORT.
TONY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION HERE
SUPPORT.
SILVIO FOREVER THE CIVIL JUSTICE
A STATION CALIFORNIA IN THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY REPRESENTING THE
WORLD COUNTY STONE SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
IF YOU'RE GONNA ALL ALLOW THREE
WITNESSES OF TWO MINUTES A PIECE.
IN BETWEEN YOU CAN WHY DON'T YOU
WAIT AND THEN OKAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
RANDALL STONE ON THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF CHICO I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE HAS IN HIS POSSESSION
AT LEAST THREE OR FOUR LETTERS
OF OPPOSITION OUR COUNCIL VOTED
GOT RECENTLY -- TO NOT SUPPORT --
A BEFORE THIRTY WE ARE CONCERNED
AND CONTINUE TO REITERATE OUR
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED --
POSITION WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE CONDITIONAL LAND USE
AUTHORITY AS HAS BEEN DETAILED
BY A MAJORITY BY COUNCIL MEMBERS
IN THEIR LETTERS -- WE DIDN'T A
VOTE TO OPPOSE RATHER WE WANT TO
WORK WITH THE ASSEMBLYMAN TO TO
LIFT THAT CONDITIONAL LAND USE
AUTHORITY AGAIN THAT'S FOR
COUNCIL MEMBERS -- AND I BELIEVE
BOTH SUPERVISORS FROM OUR A
JURISDICTION FROM THE CITY CHICK
OPPOSES AS WELL -- SAID THE
NUMBER GALLAGHER THE AUTHOR THE
BILL HAS HAS OFFERED TO REMOVE
THE CITY OF CHICO AND IF THAT --
THE BEST WE CAN DO THEN -- THEN
WE'RE REQUESTING THAT -- WE ALSO
QUESTION WHAT THE STATEWIDE
CONCERN IS LIMITING A LOCAL
CONTROL OF OUR LAND USE
AUTHORITY IS IS NOT TYPICALLY
THAT THE JURISDICTION OF THE OF
THE OF THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
CITY CHECK A CURRENTLY HAS FIFTY
THREE HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER SOME --
VARIOUS LEVELS OF OF STAGES OF
DEVELOPMENT AND AND I'M JUST NOT
SURE THAT THIS IS THE SOLUTION
TO A UNLIMITED OUR OUR LADIES AT
THIRTY THANK NEXT NEXT WEEK
[inaudible]
GOOD EVENING.
MADAM CHAIR.
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S RICHARD
HARRIMAN I'M GENERAL COUNSEL TO
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND MORE
MENTAL DEFENSE CENTER.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK JUST VERY
BRIEFLY A COUPLE APPOINTMENTS
OTHER PEOPLE WANT TO SPEAK.
OUR POSITION IS IS THAT THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT NEEDED.
THERE'S ALREADY SUFFICIENT OF
PRODUCT IN THE PIPELINE -- WE
VERY MUCH YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
HAVING LOCAL CONTROL OVER TAKEN --
BY THE STATE MANDATE ON THIS
PARTICULAR.
PROJECT.
THE PROBLEM IS IN THE FINDINGS
THE DATA DOESN'T SUPPORT FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THIS PLACE TO HER GOING TO BE
NEEDING THE THE NEW HOUSING OR
THAT THE RESIDENTIAL.
TENANCIES BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT UP 2627080% OF THE PEOPLE
WILL BE GONE BEFORE THE NEW
HOUSING IS ACTUALLY THROUGH.
THAT'S PROVIDED BY THIS
LEGISLATION.
IN ADDITION BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT IT DOESN'T ADDRESS HUMAN OF
IMPACTS BECAUSE OF THE SICK WERE.
EXEMPTION THE TAXPAYERS AND
RATEPAYERS AND THE SALES TAX
PAYERS OF THE CITY OF CHICO IN
PARTICULAR ARE GONNA BE LEFT
WITH.
CONTINUED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE'S ACTION
REGARDING TRANSPORTATION WHICH
IS ALREADY.
DETERIORATED SUFFICIENTLY THE
CITY OF CHICO IS LOOKING AT
DOING A BOND MEASURE SO WE HAVE
THE DEEP DEEP DEEP CONCERNS
ABOUT INFRASTRUCTURE
DEFICIENCIES THAT ALREADY EXISTS
GETTING COMPOUNDED.
IN THE MITIGATION MEASURES IN
THE TAXES OR THE MITIGATION FEES
ARE REQUIRED OF NEW DEVELOPMENT.
WE'RE NOT INCREASE FROM TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN THROUGH LAST YEAR
SO WE'RE ALREADY BEHIND THIS
HIGH RATE OF GROWTH IS GOING TO
HAVE THE CIVIC AND SUPERIOR
SERIOUS -- IMPACTS ON THE LOCAL
EXISTING RESIDENTS WHO HAVE TO
PAY THE PROPERTY TAXES.
IN THE FEES.
THE EVENING.
ELIZABETH DEVEREAUX FROM FRIENDS
OF THE FOOT HILLS -- I THINK BIG
CITES THE FACT THAT -- THE
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL PROCESS.
I SEEMS TO BE AN OVER REACH FOR
LOCALLY ELECTED.
REPRESENTATIVES -- THE SEQUEL
APPROVAL PROCESS -- IS THERE TO
PROVIDE NOT ONLY PROTECTION TO
THE ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF THE PEOPLE AND TO
GIVE THE PEOPLE A VOICE IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS -- AND BY
PASSING SECRET WOULD SET A VERY
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT FOR
CALIFORNIA.
IN REGARDS TO STREAMLINING THE
DEVELOPMENT -- WE HOUSE WAS SET
A READY BUYER MAYOR THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE.
TEN THOUSAND HOUSING FOR TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE PIPELINE
AND OF FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS OUR
GENERAL PLANS OF CALL FOR NEW
URBANIST HOUSING AN INFILL
RATHER THAN SUBDIVISIONS.
AND THIS WOULD PREVENT URBAN
SPRAWL BUT IN CHICO PLANNING
STAFF BECAUSE SOME OF THESE
LARGE PROPOSED DEVELOPMENTS
INFILL.
AND THEY ARE NOT IN NEW URBANIST
INFILL DEVELOPMENT.
IT ALREADY HAS AN EXPENSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE.
AND WOULD OFFER POSSIBILITY OF
EFFICIENT PUBLIC TRANSIT WALK
ABILITY AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
THIS KIND OF INFILL ALSO
ADDRESSES I THINK ONE OF THE KEY
FACTORS WHICH IS CLIMATE CHANGE --
SOME OF THE PROJECTS THAT ARE
ARE.
UP.
RIGHT NOW CUMULATIVE LEE WOULD
ACTUALLY GIVE TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND CAR TRIPS A DAY.
AND CANNOT MITIGATE THEIR CARBON
EMISSIONS -- SO -- FOR I THINK
FOR TO WORSEN THE CLIMATE CHANGE
IN AIR QUALITY THEY SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED.
AND THE IRONY WOULD BE TO
APPROVE THAT BILL AB FOR THIRTY
AND STREAMLINE THIS PROCESS ON
THE VERY KINDS.
OF DEVELOPMENTS WHICH WOULD
ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTE. TO MORE
DISASTROUS EVENTS LIKE THE
CAMPFIRE.
SO -- I THINK WHAT WERE WHAT I
WOULD LIKE.
IS. TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FURTHER REVIEW THE NEW
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
SUBMITTED TO THE BILL AND I AM
OPPOSING THE BILL.
AND I'D I'D LIKE TO IN
CONCLUSION TO ADD THAT MY THE
CITY OF CHICO'S PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR AND A SENIOR STAFF.
HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THAT THIS
IS BAD FOR CHICO ELIMINATES OUR
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE WITH THE
PARKING CONSIDERATIONS AT LEAST
AS WRITTEN AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU I'M IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL IF YOU
CAN JUST COME TO THE MICROPHONE
GIVE YOUR NAME AND IF YOU HAVE
ANY AFFILIATION ON YOUR POSITION.
AND I'LL INVITE THE TWEETERS TO
COME UP AS WELL.
MY NAME IS SUSAN JUDY I LIVE IN
YANKEE HELP CALIFORNIA MY TWO
SONS BOTH LOST THEIR HOMES IN.
THE CAMP FIRE.
I OPPOSE -- AB FOR THIRTY ONE OF
MY BIGGEST CONCERN OR WE'RE NOT
TAKING ANYMORE TESTIMONY OKAY
JUST OKAY JUST BUT HOW DOES OKAY
THANK YOU.
DAVE GARCIA WITH -- CHICO THREE
FIFTY WE HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND WE OPPOSE.
GRACE MARVIN LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE ADVOCATE IN
CHICO AND I OPPOSE IT AS IT IS
NOW THANK YOU.
AND THAT KERRY AND I LIVE IN
PARADISE CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND I
OPPOSE THIS [inaudible]
BILL.
JANE COLEMAN OPPOSED AB
[inaudible]
FOUR THIRTY CHICO.
PRINTED ALSO SEE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA -- WE APPRECIATE THE
OTHER TAKING ARMAMENTS AS WELL
AS BEING ABLE TO MEET WITH US
AND TALKING ABOUT THE CURRENT
EVENTS -- WE SAID YOU HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONCERNS WITH SOME
OF THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
HOW THOSE WHEN I PLAY WITH --
WHAT THE BILL ALREADY HAS AND SO
WE'RE STILL TOPPING I'M STILL
WORKING WITH THEM AND STILL
HAVING A DIALOGUE ABOUT THAT BUT
WE'RE CONFIDENT WE CAN GET TO A?
NEUTRAL POSITION EVENTUALLY SING
HOW THE AUTHORS BEEN VERY
AMENABLE TO OUR SITUATION SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M WITH THAT I'M
GOING TO RETURN NOW TO THE
COMMITTEE -- MS EGGMAN.
THANK YOU AND IT'S NICE TO SEE
YOU BACK HERE TODAY MISTER
GALLAGHER -- AND I JUST WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU ON ALL THE HARD
WORK YOU'VE HAD TO DO ON THIS
CONGRADULATIONS NOT THE RIGHT
WORD BUT IT'S IT'S LATE AT
COMMEND YOU I THINK THAT'S A
BETTER WORD HIS COMMEND YOU ON
ALL THE HARD WORK YOU'VE DONE --
IN REPRESENTING YOUR DISTRICT
THAT IS FACED A HORRIFIC --
INCIDENT -- WE HEARD THIS COUPLE
WEEKS AGO AND AT THAT TIME WE
HAD THE SAME ISSUE EVER KIND
AROUND CHICO NAY BE ISM AND YOU
SAID -- IF WAS REQUIRED YOU
WOULD EVEN REMOVE THEM.
AND SO I TRUSTED YOU CONTINUE TO
GO FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO MEET
WITH ALL ALL PLAYERS -- NO WE
KNOW SOMETIMES A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN SAY NOT IN MY
BACKYARD -- IT SO I'M SURE
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO FIND.
THE THE PATH FORWARD AND I'M
GLAD TO VOTE FOR YOUR BILL TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER FLORA.
TOGETHER I JUST PROCEED TO BRING
THIS BACK -- YOU KNOW IT IS
FASCINATING WE'RE HEARING A LOT
OF OPPOSITION.
BUT I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY HOW
QUICKLY FORGET.
HOW QUICKLY FORGET OF WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED WHAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO?
WE ARE NINETEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE HOMES THEY'RE JUST
WANTING TO REBUILD [inaudible]
NOTHING MORE.
AND IF THERE ARE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO DO TO EXPEDITE THAT
PROCESS TO GET RUPES BACK OVER
THEIR HEADS.
NONE OF US PROBABLY SAID AT THIS
TABLE LOST THEIR HOUSES YOU
PROBABLY GOING HOME TO HOME
TONIGHT [inaudible]
I AM.
IT'S REALLY THAT SIMPLE.
SO I WOULD JUST SAY HOW QUICKLY
FORGET HOW BE.
GLADLY SUPPORTING THIS BILL
[inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
MISTER GALLAGHER I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR EFFORTS ON
THIS -- YOU KNOW WE WE GET AND
THE LAND USE ISSUES TODAY WE
HEARD -- BILL TALKING ABOUT
PUTTING IN -- STADIUM FOR
OAKLAND ACE.
AND I'VE GOT CONCERNS THERE WITH
WITH THE WATERFRONT STUFF LIKE
THAT BUT I MEAN HERE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
FOLKS WHO LOST THEIR HOMES.
AND IT IS TOO SOON THE MAYOR IS
I'M SURE IF YOU WANT YOUR CITY
EXCLUDE I'M PRETTY SURE MISTER
GALLAGHER GIVE YOU THAT -- IF
YOU JUST ASK THEM NICELY.
SHELL.
WEIGHT WITH THAT I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL MISTER
GALLAGHER -- JUST FOR THE AGAIN
I THINK EVERYBODY EVERYONE'S TO
SEE THESE PEOPLE HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO REBUILD AND GET THEIR LIVES
BACK TOGETHER. FOR THE AREAS IN
THE CITIES THAT ARE WILLING --
TO BE PARTICIPANTS GET THAT
GOING TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
OF MISTER GALLAGHER I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK AND FOR WORKING SO
DILIGENTLY AND OPENLY WITH THE
COMMITTEE IN WITH WITH ME ON
THIS ISSUE -- FIRST I KNOW THAT
THIS KIND OF PRE EMPTION FOR
LOCAL CONTROL IS REALLY
DIFFICULT I COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO I DON'T TAKE IT LIGHTLY AND I
DO HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US CITY OF CHICO AND
ANY OF THE OTHER COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE.
STRUGGLING WITH THAT LOSS OF OF
FLEXIBILITY AND I ALSO KNOW THAT
SEEK WOULD GIVE THE PUBLIC A
CHANCE TO TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
THE IMPACTS OF A COMMUNITY OF A
DEVELOPMENT AND TO BE ABLE TO
WEIGH IN -- I ALSO DO DO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU DO HAVE AN
EMERGENCY IN YOUR COMMUNITY AND
YOU ARE TRYING TO HELP -- GET
OUR HOUSES BUILT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND WE TRY TO HELP
BALANCE THAT.
SO BESIDES TAKING THEM THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU MENTIONED I
ALSO WANT TO JUST FOR THOSE
LISTENING WHO HAVEN'T SEEN THE
AMENDMENTS AND PRINT YET -- SO
YOUR CLUB AND OTHERS THAT THE
DEVELOPMENTS ALSO TO BE ABLE TO
USE THE STREAMLINING ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO ACHIEVE.
STANDARDS OF AT LEAST LEAD GOLD
OR EQUIVALENT SO THAT'S A PRETTY
HIGH STANDARD AND IT WILL HELP
TO GUARANTEE THAT WHATEVER
PROJECTS OR BUILD OR AT LEAST
SUSTAINABLE AND EFFICIENT.
REDUCING THE COST OF PEOPLE WHO
LIVE THERE BUT ALSO HAVING A
DEVELOPMENT THAT WILL USE LESS
RESOURCES -- YOU KNOW FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND AND BE A
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT AND I
APPRECIATE YOU I KNOW THAT WAS
KIND OF A TOUGH.
UP HOLD THE SWALLOW -- FOR SOME
OF YOUR YOUR AT FOLKS THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH BUT I DO
THINK IT'S GOING TO MAKE FOR A
MUCH BETTER PROJECT IN THE LONG
RUN.
AND AGAIN I THINK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH WITH ME AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING -- YOUR BILL TODAY
AND I WISH YOU THE BEST OF LUCK
WITH THESE PROJECTS AS IT MOVES
FORWARD.
I WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I'M SORRY WE DO NOT HAVE A
MOTION OR SECOND.
OKAY IF I CLOSE OF SORRY YES IF
YOU'D LIKE TO LIKE TO CLOSE.
AT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
THEN A BY APPRECIATE I MEAN --
MY UNDERSTAND YOU WERE JUST
GONNA PRESENT ON THE AMENDMENTS --
AS YOU HEARD TWO WEEKS AGO THERE
IS BROAD LOCAL SUPPORT -- FOR AB --
FOUR THIRTY INCLUDING THE COUNTY
ABUSE AND THE CITIES OF ORVILLE
BIG SAYING GRIDLEY -- THE CHICO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SUPPORTS
THIS BILL COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN DISPLACED AND
AGAIN I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT NO
LET'S NOT DISPLAYS DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND.
LET'S NOT UNDERMINE THAT THIS.
IS A HUGE DISASTER FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED IN THE BUTTE COUNTY
REGION 14% OF THE HOUSING STOCK
IN THE REGION.
HAS BEEN DECIMATED THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT AS PROVIDING
A USEFUL TOOL TO BRING ON
HOUSING.
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE -- WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDER JUST AS WE
WORK THROUGH AMENDMENTS HERE.
EVERYONE WHO IS PROVIDED ACTUAL
INPUT ON AMENDMENTS ON THINGS
THEY'D LIKE TO BE SET A CHANGE
IN THE BILL WE HAVE WORK TO TRY
TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES -- THE
CITY OF CHICO AS I THINK THE
MAYOR JUST.
STATED EARLIER HAS NOT SAID THAT
THEY OPPOSE THE BILL -- THEY
HAVE SAID THAT THEY HAVE SOME
CONCERNS I'M STILL WAITING ON
THE SPECIFIC.
ISSUES THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE CHANGED.
WE'LL BE HAPPY TO LOOK AT THOSE --
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
THE ISSUE HERE IS THAT WE HAVE
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE DISPLACED --
YOU HEARD FROM COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS ON THAT ISSUE.
YOU ALSO HAVE RECEIVED SUPPORT
LETTERS FROM TWO OF THE BIGGEST
EMPLOYERS -- IN THE REGION BILL
DOT COM AND AND LOW HOSPITAL.
WHO ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
LOSING CRITICAL EMPLOYEES
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT FIND HOUSING
IN THE REGION IN FACT THE
PRINCIPLE OF PARADISE HIGH
SCHOOL?
ACTUALLY JUST RESIGNED BECAUSE
HE COULD NOT FIND HOUSING IN THE
BUTTE COUNTY REGION WE ARE
LOSING CRITICAL PEOPLE IN THIS
REGION IT'S URGENT THAT WE ACT
NOW.
AB FOR THIRTY IS ONE OF THOSE
TOOLS -- AND AGAIN WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BILL -- WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IF ULTIMATELY THE
CITY OF CHICO SAYS HEY WE JUST
DON'T.
WANT THIS BILL FOR OUR CITY WE
WILL TAKE THEM OUT BECAUSE AS I
SAID THERE'S COUNTLESS OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND WHO WANT --
IN INDEED WANT THIS AS A TOOL TO
BRING ONLINE MUCH NEEDED HOUSING --
SO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR HELP --
IN IN WORKING THROUGH THIS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT -- TODAY.
THANKS AND ALSO JUST YOU KNOW
REMIND PEOPLE THAT IT DOESN'T
CHANGE UNDERLYING ZONING SO
CITIES ARE STILL ABLE.
TO ZONE FOR THE TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY YES WITH THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION AND WE HAVE A SECOND --
FOR THE BILL AS IN THE FOR THE
AMENDMENTS TO THOSE AMENDED
SICKLY ROLL CALL.
ITEM SIX A. B. FOR THIRTY BY
MEMBER GALLAGHER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
LARA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS -- MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ I RIGHT TO CHOOSE
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible] SIX ZERO SIX
ZERO PULLS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU THANK YOU VENTURE --
MR MULLIN I BELIEVE YOU'RE UP
NEXT.
YOU'RE HERE FOR AB.
FIFTEEN OH NINE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
PRESENTING AB FIFTEEN OH NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN SENATOR
HILL AND I ALONG WITH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN EGGMAN'S.
CO AUTHORSHIP INTRODUCED AB
FIFTEEN OH NINE IN RESPONSE TO A
FIRE CAUSED BY A LITHIUM ION
BATTERY AT THE SHORE WAY
FACILITY IN SAN MATEO COUNTY.
WHICH CAUSED EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGES THAT
SHUT DOWN THE FACILITY FOR
NINETY DAYS AND TOOK OVER A YEAR
TO RESTORE.
WITH OVER HALF A MILLION LITHIUM
ION BATTERY SOLD LAST YEAR AND
THE NUMBER OF BATTERIES ON THE
MARKET EXPECTED TO DOUBLE IN THE
NEXT SEVEN YEARS THE NUMBER OF
LITHIUM ION BATTERIES FOUND IN
THE WASTE STREAM.
WILL CONTINUE TO INCREASE THE
RISK OF MORE FIRES WILL RISE
ALONG WITH IT AB FIFTEEN OH NINE
TREATS LOOSE BATTERIES AND
BATTERIES EMBEDDED IN PRODUCTS
DIFFERENTLY.
AS HE ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES LARGE
RETAILERS TO HAVE A MECHANISM TO
ACCEPT ALL RECHARGEABLE
BATTERIES FROM CONSUMERS
RECYCLING.
BATTERIES THAT ARE EMBEDDED IN
DEVICES ARE NOT SUBJECT TO THE
LAW SO WE PROPOSED A RETAILER'S
HELP IMPROVE THE COLLECTION OF
PRODUCTS WITH EMBEDDED LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES BY ESTABLISHING A
TAKE BACK PROGRAM OUR DEPOSIT
SYSTEM.
OR A SIMILAR PROGRAM WERE
ALLOWING FLEXIBILITY SINCE THERE
IS SUCH A WIDE ARRAY OF PRODUCTS.
THAT HAVE THESE BATTERIES IN
THEM WHEN IT COMES TO
MANUFACTURERS OF LOOSE LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES WERE DEALING WITH
A MUCH NARROWER GROUP OF
COMPANIES.
AB FIFTY NO INE CALLS FOR THEM
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE END OF
LIFE MANAGEMENT OF THEIR
PRODUCTS WITH A PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY MODEL.
THIS MODEL ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THESE PRODUCTS DESPITE ALL OF
THEIR PORT APPLICATIONS AND USES
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT END OF LIFE
CONSEQUENCE WHICH THE
MANUFACTURER MUST HELP MITIGATE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE THE END
OF LIFE CONSEQUENCE FOR LITHIUM
ION BATTERIES AS FIRES THAT ARE
PUBLICLY FINANCED SOLID WASTE
AND RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE LIST OF
SUPPORTERS ON THE BILL THIS IS A
TRULY STATEWIDE MATTER I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON A. B..
FIFTEEN OH NINE AND AM AWAITING
MISTER BERMAN'S -- ATTENDANCE
HERE BUT WITH THAT I WILL --
TRIGGERED OVER -- TO ARE A
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL.
OF THE BILL.
GOOD EVENING AND HAPPY -- DAY
EVERYONE MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS JOE Là MERRY ON I'M
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
RETHINK WASTE WE ARE A JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY.
ARE -- HANDLING GARBAGE
RECYCLING COMPOSTING ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO PENINSULA -- WE ARE
TWELVE MEMBERS -- GOING FROM
EAST PALO ALTO TOO BURLINGAME
AND WE CAN WE SERVICE ABOUT 60%
OF THE COUNTIES MATERIALS.
I IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE HAD A
CATASTROPHIC FIRE -- IN OUR
RECYCLING CENTER -- WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF LITHIUM ION BATTERY
FIRES FROM TIME TO TIME IN THE
PRESENT A VERY SERIOUS THREAT --
TO THE WORKERS AND OF COURSE TO
THE FACILITY ITSELF WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE ON THAT DAY THE WAS NO
ONE HURT BUT IT DID CAUSE EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF DAMAGE -- AND IN FACT IT IS --
IT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS SOME
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES AS WE HAVE
LOOKED TO REPLACE THE INSURANCE
IT HAS.
HI IT HAS COSTS.
ABOUT THREE TIMES WHAT IT DID
PREVIOUS TO THE FIRE -- OR OR
FORMER -- INSURANCE PROVIDER
ACTUALLY FIRED US -- IN SO WE
HAD TO GO IN THE MARKET PLACE
AND GO SHOPPING AGAIN SO WE NOW
HAVE SEVEN INSURANCE PROVIDERS
PROVIDING THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY COVERAGE --
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ABOUT ELEVEN
BATTERIES LITHIUM ION BATTERIES
PER HOUR GOING THROUGH THE THE
FACILITY EVERYONE OF THEM
REPRESENTS A COMBUSTIBLE EVENT.
AND IT'S QUITE.
A IT'S QUITE -- A CHALLENGING
FOR US TO OPERATE OUR OUR
FACILITY -- THERE'S ABOUT A
HUNDRED PLUS OF THESE FACILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S
THOUSANDS OF JOBS AT STAKE HERE
AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT I WANT TO URGE IN
HIGH VOTE ON FIFTEEN OH NINE I
GAP IN THE COLLAPSE OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE BEING
MINDFUL OF THE TIME I'LL JUST
SAY THAT.
AS THESE BATTERIES BECOME MORE
MORE POPULAR AND CHEAPER AND
CHEAPER.
THE FIRES AT MATERIAL RECYCLING
FACILITIES HAVE BEEN GOING UP
PROPORTIONALLY AT THE SAME RATE.
I THINK THERE WERE SOMETHING
LIKE SEVENTEEN HUNDRED FIRES
LAST YEAR AMATEUR RECOVERY
FACILITIES.
THAT'S THAT COMMONSENSE BILL
THAT GIVES A LOT OF DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR INDUSTRY TO COMPLY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
THANK YOU JASON ABOUT FROM
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS YOU'RE TO COUNCIL IN
THE NATIONAL STIRRED CHIP ACTION
COUNCIL AND STRONG SUPPORT.
SCHERING GREEN SANITATION
DISTRICTS OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
LAUREN COMMON BE ALPHA SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. FOR
FRONT IMPACT THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSE RECYCLING COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
LIKE IT US HERE ON BEHALF OF
STOP WAY SOLID WASTE ASSOCIATION
OF NORTH AMERICA WESTERN PLASTER
WASTE MANAGEMENT THIRTY AND CITY.
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC HAVE A
SUPPORT AND CONCEPT -- REALLY
LIKE WHAT THE AUTHOR IS TRYING
TO DO BUT WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
FRAMEWORK WORKS AND HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH A DEPOSIT BASE
SYSTEM IF THAT'S USED AS A
COMPLIANCE OPTION.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT'S EASY
FOR CONSUMERS TO GET THEIR MONEY
BACK AT THE END OF THE DAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
OKAY SING NOT OFFERING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION THE
IN BETWEEN OKAY COME ON UP.
JAMIE MINOR REPRESENTING HP
HEWLETT PACKARD I REALLY
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE IN THE COURSE OF
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS BUT
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE WILL BE
MEASUREMENTS TAKEN -- TO REMOVE
PRODUCTS ALREADY UNDER THAT.
ELECTRONIC WASTE RECYCLING ACT
SO IT -- IN THAT CASE WE WOULD.
WE WOULD SUPPORT THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE HER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE.
I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION I THINK --
WHICH IS I I THINK THIS IS A
GREAT BILL AND I ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT IT -- BUT THEY NEED TO
ALSO BE A WAY TO NOTIFY
CONSUMERS OF WHICH PRODUCTS THEY
CAN THIS BUT HOW THEY CAN
DISPOSE OF DIFFERENT WAYS.
SO -- MY QUESTION IS ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING SOME KIND OF A
FUTURE WORK OR MEMINTA THIS OR
IS IT POSSIBLE NDER THE CURRENT
BILL THAT THERE COULD BE
REGULATIONS TO REQUIRE VERY
CLEAR INSTRUCTIONS FOR CONSUMERS
MAYBE EVEN ON THE BOX SO THEY
KNEW BEFORE THEY PURCHASED
SOMETHING.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE -- TO
DISPOSE OF IT DIFFERENTLY THAN
THERE USED TO OTHER PRODUCTS.
WELL I WOULD CONCUR THAT THIS
CAN ONLY BE EFFECTIVE IF
CONSUMERS ARE FULLY AWARE WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO OPEN -- TO ANYTHING
ALONG THOSE LINES TO ACHIEVE
THAT AND AND DON'T KNOW IF MY
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS OF ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENT ON THAT BUT
CONSUMER NOTIFICATION IS
ABSOLUTELY -- UP GOING TO BE
PART OF THIS HOW WE FORMULATE
THAT -- IS TO BE SEEN BUT YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO WORK THAT
ISSUE TERRIFIC.
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT CONSUMERS UNDERSTAND EVEN
BEFORE THEY PURCHASE SOMETHING
THAT THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY -- SO THANK YOU --
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH JUST A SIMPLY AS A
MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE STATUS
QUO IS UNACCEPTABLE -- THIS IS A
DISTRICT ISSUE BUT CLEARLY --
THERE'S A STATEWIDE CONCERN HERE
AS WELL AND THINK WE NEED TO DO
SOME ADDITIONAL WORK AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THE MATTER.
TRAFFIC THANK YOU WITH THE MOST
SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B. FIFTEEN OH
NINE BUYS ASSEMBLY MMBER MULLIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA [inaudible]
LIMóN.
MON I MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MELENDEZ. ONE DOES NOT VOTING
[inaudible] TO CHANGE
[inaudible]
STONE. THREE ZERO OKAY WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SANTIAGOYOU ARE HERE FOR AB.
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VENTURE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- TODAY
WERE HERE PRESENT ON A. B.
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK IN HELPING US TO
MAKE THIS A BETTER BILL AND
FOCUSED ON EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO DO -- IT'S A SIMPLE
BILL BUT THE WHAT IT WOULD DO
WAS THEY WOULD TAKE PROJECTS
ALREADY STREAMLINED THE SEQUEL
AND ENSURE THAT THOSE -- THAT
THOSE RELATED ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF DOLLARS
ARE ALSO COVERED UNDER SO WHAT
HAPPENED LOS ANGELES WHEN HHH
HHH PASSED IS THERE THERE
STREAMLINED FOR THE PROJECTS BUT
NOT THE ACTIVITIES LIKE
RELEASING THE DOLLARS AND AND
THEREFORE.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
BOTH PARTS OF IT ARE -- TO GO
STREAMLINED THE SAME WITH THE
HEAT DOLLARS AT THE STATE
ALLOCATED LAST YEAR EXACT SAME
THING -- DAN RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR PRIVATE.
THANK YOU.
YES WITH THIS BETTER SHARON
MEMBERS ANDREW AND WE WILL SHOW
YOUR AUNT'S WE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI -- WE THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO -- FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD WE'VE
EXPERIENCE ON THE GROUND.
SOME TO COMMUNITY FEEDBACK ON SO
AND IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS AND SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS HAVE NOT BEEN A
CAKE WALK.
AND ANY KIND OF CLARIFICATION
THAT WE CAN GET FROM THE STATE
ON IMPLEMENTING THESE PROJECTS
STILL RESPONDING TO THE
COMMUNITY -- WE WELCOME MAT
BECAUSE THESE CONVERSATIONS --
OUR DIFFICULT AT TIMES THE MAYOR
OF LOS ANGELES IS CHALLENGED A
COUNCIL MEMBERS TO CLOSE
PROJECTS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES --
BUT RESIDENTS ARE VERY VOCAL --
THESE ARE.
PART OF THE WILL OF THE VOTERS
THE VOTERS A LOS ANGELES HAVE
APPROVED -- BOND UP TO ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
THE SHELTERS WE HAVE A BRIDGE
HOME PROGRAM.
IN LOS ANGELES AND WE ARE
WORKING.
AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN WE JUST
OPEN THE PROJECT ONE OF FOUR
THAT WE PLAN IN SOUTH LOS
ANGELES -- DOES TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES FOR THE VERY NEEDY --
WE HAVE THE ISSUE OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS AT THE STATE LOCAL
LEVEL HEARING FROM CONSTITUENTS%
THAT THE VOTERS HAVE APPROVED TO
TAX THEMSELVES. TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM BUT WHEN THEY DRIVE TO
AND FROM WORK THEY STILL SUITS
TO STILL SEE PEOPLE SLEEPING ON
THE STREET.
AND SO WE'RE WORKING AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN EXPEDITIOUSLY AS WE
CAN TO IMPLEMENT THESE PROJECTS
WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT WE ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO.
IN A PIE TAKE IT FOR GRANTED THE
MOST PEOPLE KNOW WHAT HHH IS AS
AS WERE USED TO SAYING IT --
WHAT IT IT'S AN ALLEY CITY WE
PASSED A MEASURE -- TO RAISE THE
DOLLARS -- FOR SUPPORT HOUSING
FOR THE HOMELESS POPULATION AND
WE'RE STUCK IN THIS SITUATION
WHERE ONE PORTION OF IT IS
BECAUSE STREAMLINED BUT YET THE
ALLOCATION OF DOLLARS IS NOT SO
ONLY DOES IS REALLY A LINE IT.
ALONG WITH THE STATE DOLLARS I
CALLED A KEEPER FOR JUST REFRESH
EVERYBODY EVERYBODY'S MEMORY.
IN THIS IS WHERE IT'S GETS ME TO
WRITE BUT ITS THE THE HOMELESS --
MERGES HE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
DOLLARS THAT WE PASSED LAST YEAR
WHICH WE WOULD LOOK TO DO THE
SAME SORRY MADAM CHAIR FOR
TAKING THAT EXTRA MOMENT.
THAT'S OKAY AND ALSO JUST TO
CLARIFY FOR THE RECORD THAT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE OFFERED
WILL BE TAKEN IN THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE YES.
RIGHT.
AND THANK YOU AND THANKS THE
MAYOR FOR WORKING WITH US ON ON
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND I ON THIS
ISSUE.
THANK ABOUT ANY ANY -- ANYBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME UP TO A MICROPHONE.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY WINNERS OKAY WHAT'S UP HERE
THEY COME.
OPPOSITION WINNERS WINNERS
WINNER -- PRINTED OFF WAS UKIAH
CALIFORNIA -- WE HAD INITIALLY
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL -- DO
THAT'S CURRENT FORM BUT WE AFTER
LOOKING THROUGH AMENDMENTS AND
EVERYTHING WE WILL LIKELY BE
TAKEN OFF OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WE CHELSEA TO CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY ENVIRONMENT I ECHO
SIERRA CLUB'S COMMENTS THANK YOU.
HI TIFFANY IN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VIRAL JUST ALLIANCE
WE CURRENTLY MAINTAIN OPPOSE
POSITION ON THIS BILL HOWEVER WE
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THIS
RECENT PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU.
HI DOESN'T JOHNSON WITH
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LOS ANGELES AND I
ECHO -- SAY HAS -- THANK
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY I BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANNIE YES MISTER
MATHIS.
MR SAN DIEGO UNDERSTAND THIS IS --
LA SPECIFIC BILL -- BUT IF EVER
IN THE FUTURE YOU SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BROADEN THIS --
TO STATEWIDE APPROACH SO OTHER
CITIES -- IF THEY'RE ABLE TO
PASS BONDS OR DO THE SAME THING.
I WOULD BE ABLE TO GET THIS TYPE
OF STREAMLINING I'D SUPPORT THAT
AS WELL SO -- NAY IT I KNOW OF
HOMELESS PROBLEM IS.
AFFECTING ALL OF US EVEN NOT.
THOSE OF US IN RURAL AREAS SELL --
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO BROADEN IT.
WOULD BE AWESOME HI IN AGAIN I
KNOW IT'S LA SPECIFIC BUT A LOT
OF AREAS REALLY NEED THIS TYPE
EL.
TO AND THIS ONE DOES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MISTER SANTIAGO --
SO YOU SAID MEASURE HHH PASSED --
EVEN THOUGH.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THAT MEASURE
THAT TOLD VOTERS THAT -- IN AT
SOME POINT A SEQUEL EXEMPTION
WOULD BE GIVEN IS THAT CORRECT.
NOTHING IN THAT MEASURE SAID IF
YOU PASS THIS WE'RE GOING TO GET
A SEQUEL EXEMPTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE IN ORDER TO TO FAST
TRACK WHAT WHAT I THINK THERE
WAS AN EXPEDIT PROCESS.
RELATED TO THE MEASURE HOWEVER
IT'S THE SECOND PORTION WHICH IS
THE ALLOCATION OF FUNDS IF I
UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY.
THIS.
DOES THAT [inaudible]
I KNOW.
THE THE THE THE PART WE'RE
TRYING TO CHANGE.
IS V. THE RELEASE OF THE FUNDS
BECAUSE THAT'S BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THE WHAT THE PROBLEM IS SO
ALL THE ALL THE ON SEQUEL
PROCESS EXEMPTIONS OR OR ALREADY
IN PLACE AND LAW.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
WHERE THE PROBLEM -- HAPPENS I
KNOW THIS IS THIS LIKE TO
CONFUSE BUT THIS IS WHY THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR
CLARIFICATION.
WHERE THE PROBLEM IS IS IN THOSE
ACTIVITIES RELATED -- TO THE
PROJECT AND THAT INCLUDES -- THE
RELEASE OF DOLLARS SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS JUST SAY.
THESE PROJECTS ARE ALREADY.
A SINGLE EXEMPTED.
IT'S A TECHNICALITY THIS IS ME
IN LAYMAN'S TERMS IT'S A
TECHNICALITY THE RELEASE OF
DOLLARS [inaudible]
ON ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THAT.
OKAY I APOLOGIZE -- BUT I AM
[inaudible]
NOT.
FAMILIAR WITH WHERE IN THE BILL
IT TALKS ABOUT THIS JUST BEING
FOR THE RELEASE OF FUNDS IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS BILL.
RELATES TO SEE QUICK SANCTION SO
THAT YOU CAN GET THESE PROJECTS
MOVING.
AND MY INCORRECT I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS WE TOOK WOOD.
WHAT A LINE THOSE -- ACTIVITIES
DOES THE MINISTER WERE TAKEN
HOUSING.
SO THE BEER GUZZLING YOUR I'M
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS THE CURRENT
LANGUAGES PRETTY BROAD THE
AMENDMENTS WERE ACCEPTING.
IS WHAT WE WOULD BE VOTING ON
OKAY SO.
THE AMENDMENTS YOU ARE THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE TAKING.
I WILL BE TAKING HIM IN THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE MA'AM -- THIS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PROJECT
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE AND FUNDED BY
MAJOR H. H. EMERGENCY SHELTERS
[inaudible]
THIS.
ONE AS PROMISED.
FOR THE RELEASE OF AS WELL.
IF I IF I MAY IN THE CURRENT LAW.
BECAUSE BECAUSE THE PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION.
THE SEQUEL IS ALREADY EXEMPTED
FOR MOST FOR THESE PROJECTS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PROJECT IS
ALREADY EXEMPTED UNDER SYKORA.
SO THE DIFFERENCES THAT SOME
OTHER PARTS OF THEIR APPROVAL OF
THE FUNDING IS WHERE THE SEQUEL
WAS TRUE WOULD HAVE BEEN
TRIGGERED.
SO THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
BUILDINGS WAS ALREADY SEE C<c.cyan></c>
EXAMS IN THESE CASES.
SENATE IS THAT HELP CLARIFY.
I THINK I JUST CAN BE USED
EVERYBODY.
THIS IS.
SO WE'RE NOT.
THE END.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH.
THE AMENDMENTS BECAUSE NOW I'M
CONFUSED SO I THOUGHT.
IT IS A CHALLENGING SUBJECT TO
IT IN AYE AYE I MUST ADMIT.
I'M JUST I'M SORRY MADAM CHAIR
CAN SOMEONE SHOW ME IN THE BILL
WHERE IT'S JUST SINGLING OUT.
THE FUNDING MECHANISM LET ME ASK
THE AUTHOR WITH IF YOU'D RATHER
HAVE YOUR WITNESS FOR YOU OR I
CAN HAVE OUR COMMITTEE STAFFER
MAKE I'M JUST SORT OF EXPLAIN
AND WALK THEM THROUGH THE A MEMO
EVER.
EVER WHATEVER YOUR COME MOST
COMFORTABLE WITH -- SINCE I'M
TAKING A MOMENT YOU'RE MORE THAN
WELCOME TO PRESENT THEM.
SURE LARGE LENGLEN WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- SO THE THE
AMENDMENTS NARROW THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL AND FRANCE TO SUPPORT
OF HOUSING PROJECTS THAT ARE
FUNDED BY THE LOCAL BOND MEASURE
HHH.
AND EMERGENCY SHELTERS THAT ARE
FUNDED BY THE THE STATE FUNDED
HE PROGRAM BOTH WITHIN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES WHICH HAS THIS
VOTER APPROVED -- PROPERTY TAX
OF TO TO FUND THE PROJECTS.
THE THE THE POINT THAT THE
AUTHOR WAS TRYING TO MAKE IS
THAT.
WHILE EXISTING LAW.
EXEMPTS FROM C. QUIRK OR CREATES
A BY RIGHT APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF THE THE PHYSICAL
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT.
THEY'RE MAKING DECISIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THE THE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THESE PROJECTS
AT LARGE ADOPTING ORDINANCES.
FINANCING MAYBE LAND TRANSFERS
AND THOSE THOSE ARE NOT
NECESSARILY CAPTURED BY.
THE EXEMPTION THAT WAS ENACTED
LAST YEAR SOME OF THE PRIOR
EXEMPTION SO THEY'RE THEY'RE
TRYING TO BASICALLY COVER THEIR
BASES SO THAT.
THE THE FUNDING THAT THE VOTERS
APPROVED CAN.
YOU KNOW BE USED TO DEVELOP
THESE PROJECTS -- WHETHER IT'S
APPROVAL OF THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE PROJECT -- APPROVAL OF
FINANCING OR LAND TRANSFER MAYBE
ADOPTION OF AN ORDINANCE.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THIS IS WHAT WE SPEND SOMETIME
WITH THE BILL IT'S VERY
TECHNICAL I THINK THAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO JUST SORT OF IT'S
ALMOST LIKE I WAS IT IS SORT OF
LIKE TECHNICAL CLEANUPS OF
THINGS THAT JUST WEREN'T
ANTICIPATED IN.
SOME OF THE PASSED STREAMLINING
BILLS THAT WERE DONE AS THEY'RE
TRYING TO ENACT -- THE FUNDING
THAT THE VOTERS YOU KNOW HAVE
VOTED ON IN LOS ANGELES IN YOUR
PEOPLE VOTED ON THIS
ANTICIPATING THAT THESE PRODUCTS
WILL GET BUILT.
AND THEY'RE JUST TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SORT OF ADMINISTRATIVE KIND OF
HANG UPS IN THE PROCESS.
OF ENACTING THE CLEAR WILL OF
THE VOTERS OF LOS ANGELES RIGHT
AND AND I GET THAT I GUESS I'M --
AND I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THIS IDEA
AND JUST WHEN WE GO BACK IN TIME
TO THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE GO
THROUGH AND PICK SOMETHING OR
PROVE SOMETHING.
THAT THE VOTERS THOUGHT IN LOS
ANGELES AND IT WAS ALREADY
APPROVED I THINK THAT'S A
BACKWARDS WAY OF DOING THINGS
WHICH IS WHAT SEEMS LIKE WHAT
HAS HAPPENED HERE.
THOUGH I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE
IDEA I JUST WE HAD A NUMBER OF
BILLS COME THROUGH RELATED TO
SEEK WAY EXEMPTIONS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT PER HOUSING THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN -- APPROVED -- THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN DISTRICTS SPECIFIC
BUT I GUESS I DON'T WANT TO SEE
A PATTERN OF GOING BACK IN TIME
AND SORT OF TRYING TO FIX THINGS
BECAUSE A PARTICULAR.
CITY OF ONE AT A LARGE CITY LOS
ANGELES WHICH HAS A NUMBER
MEMBERS -- GETS TO GO BACK IN
TIME AND CHANGE THE BILL BUT
WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION APPRECIATE THINK
WE'LL UNDERSTAND THAT OF WE
DON'T SORRY -- BUT BUT I DO.
THANK YOU SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY SO IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
THIS IS AN EXEMPTION PER SE BUT
THIS IS A CURRENT LAW AND WE ARE
CLEAR FINE.
AT TO NARROWLY ADAPT TO THIS.
CURRENT LAW FOR THIS BILL IS.
MATT MATT MATT THAT'S NOT LEAST
MISTER SANTIAGO AFTER.
CURRENT LAW WHEN THIS WAS WITHIN
THIS WAS PASSED.
WAS THAT IT WOULD BE SEAT
BECAUSE STREAMLINING -- INVOLVED.
THAT WAS BASED ON A BILL -- MY
MEMORY.
RECOLLECTS THAT THE TWO MEMBERS
NOW SIR IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE
MEMBERS ACTUALLY -- WITH
DISCUSSES WHO BELIEVE DID IT HI.
I BELIEVE IS -- AB SEVENTY THREE
IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN BUT I THINK
WE CAN CLEAR THAT UP FOR YOU
[inaudible]
THIS PASSES.
SO GET VOTERS THOUGHT THAT WE
CAN GET THIS DONE NOW THERE'S
THIS OTHER ITEM THAT POPS UP
WHICH IS THOSE ACTIVITIES
RELATED -- TO DEVELOPING -- WE
COULD STREAMLINING THOSE
ACTIVITIES RELATED TO IT.
MEDIAN TRANSFER OF LAND TRANSFER
MONEY TO CHATTER WEREN'T WERE
SOMEHOW NOT IN THERE SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT SO IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY -- COMPLETE SO WE'RE
COMING BACK AND SAYING SINCE
THIS LAST PIECE WAS NOT INCLUDED.
LET'S JUST INCLUDE IT MEANING
THESE ACTIVITIES.
SUCH AS THE ONES STATED TRANSFER
PROPERTY TRANSFER DOLLARS THE
REAL STATE.
SO THE IT'S ALREADY SEQUEL
STREAMLINED.
SOME OF THESE ACTIVITIES.
MAY NOT BE EVEN THOUGH THE
TECHNICAL TRANSACTIONS IS I
WOULD AS I WAS EXPLAINING
[inaudible]
MAKES SENSE.
SO.
OKAY SO JUST TO YOU KNOW TRY TO
TAKE ANOTHER WHACK A CLARIFYING
THIS LITTLE IT DOES EXPAND.
THE SEQUESTERING LINING FROM THE
ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION OF A PROJECT
NOW TO THE ADOPTION OF THE
ORDINANCE OR TO THE FINANCING AS
WELL.
SO IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T CHANGE
THE SCOPE IN TERMS OF AN ACTUAL.
HOUSING PROJECT WE'RE STILL
TALKING ABOUT A PARTICULAR
HOUSING PROJECT WHERE UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE HOUSING PROJECT
ITSELF THE CONSTRUCTION.
HAS A SICK WAS STREAMLINING.
BUT THE ORDINANCE THAT WOULD
CREATE.
THAT HOUSING PROJECT MAY NOT
UNDER CURRENT LAW SO THEY WANTED
TO CLARIFY THAT IT WOULD ALSO
HAVE IT.
AND THE FINANCING PART FOR THAT
SAME EXACT PROJECT THE PROJECT
WE KNOW THE BUILDING OF THE
PROJECT HAS A SECRET
STREAMLINING BUT THE CREATION OF
AN ORDINANCE. TO CREATE THAT
PROJECT OR THE FINANCING TO
FINANCE A PROJECT MIGHT NOT HAVE
THE SAME SEEK WAS STREAMLINING
SO I THINK SO CITY UP TO MY
UNDERSTANDING AND PLEASE CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG IS CITY OF LOS
SANTOS WANTS TO MAKE CLEAR.
THEY WANT TO EXPAND IT SO THAT
THAT'S ALSO HAS THIS WEEK WAS
STREAMLINING.
THE WE KNOW THE BUILDING THE-CONSTRUCTION OF THE BUILDING
ALREADY HAS IT I THINK THAT THIS
DOESN'T CHANGE THAT BUT IT DOES
EXPAND THAT SHE WAS STREAMLINING
NOW TO THE PASSING OF AN
ORDINANCE.
OR TO THE FINANCING OF THE
PROJECT.
DOES THAT HELP IT IS NOT IS THAT
YOUR CREW UNDERSTANDING TO I
DON'T WANT IN THE WORD AND I AM
SURE AND I THINK YOU DID A GOOD
JOB OF DIFFEENTIATING BETWEEN
THE BUILDING OF A AND AND THE
LEAD LEG GALA THE OF THOSE
PROCESSES SITE PATIENTS STARTED
THERE.
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
DOES NOT USE. FOR LOS ANGELES.
WE GET CHALLENGED WHEN WE
IMPLEMENT THESE PROJECTS
ESPECIALLY WITH THE EDICT THAT
THE BEAR HAS ISSUED THE
CHALLENGE COUNCIL MEMBERS AT ALL
FIFTEEN PARTS.
A DISTRICTS WITHIN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES TO IDENTIFY PARCELS
A FOR THE SITES AND SO ANYTHING
THAT ADDS THE CLARITY WITH
RESPECT TO THE PLANNING IN THE
FINANCING OF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WELCOME BECAUSE THERE
WAS ALREADY STE -- STATUTES ON
THE BOOKS THAT PROVIDED
EXPEDITED PROCESS UNDER SYKORA
FOR DIRECTING THESE TEMPORARY
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND OF COURSE --
SOCIAL TO THAT WE GOT VOTER
APPROVAL FOR LARGER FUSION OF
FUNDING AND YOU KNOW AS I STATED
EARLIER ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY
CONSTITUENTS -- THEY'VE TAX
THEMSELVES AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS AND WHEN THEY DRIVE TO AND
FROM WORK THEY STILL SEE PEOPLE
SEE SLEEPING ON THE STREETS.
AND SO WE ARE TRYING TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THE PROMISE MADE MAKE
IT EASIER -- FOR LOCAL OFFICIALS
IN THEIR OWN DISTRICTS IN THE
CITY WRIT LARGE.
TO KIND OF HANDLE COMMUNITY
CHALLENGES TO COME FORWARD BUT
STILL BE RESPONSIVE AND GET THE
PROJECTS BUILT SO PEOPLE CAN GET
OFF THE STREETS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
OTHER THAN TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK ON ON ON THIS
BILL IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND TO HELP
IN ESTA.
STREET.
FORMALLY STREAMLINED THIS US OR
SPEAK AND MAKE SURE THEY TO TWO
DOLLARS WORK IN AND THAT THEY HE
DOLLARS OF THIS LEGISLATURE I
SENT BACK TO OUR COMMUNITIES
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED WE CAN GET
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET.
N. D. I. IN THE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND EMERGENCY SHELTER.
THAT'S REALLY THE GOAL THANK YOU
MANAGER RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOOK.
THANK YOU AND I JUST FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO MAYBE DON'T FOLLOW
LOS ANGELES AS CLOSELY AS THOSE
OF US WHO LIVE THERE -- WE HAVE
SEEN A LOT OF QUESTIONS FROM THE
PUBLIC AND FROM THE PRESS AS TO
WHY WHEN THE VOTERS VOTED FOR
THIS MONEY.
THE TAX THEMSELVES WHY THE MONEY
A LOT OF IT IS SITTING IN BANK
ACCOUNT -- NOT BEING USE AND SO
THE CITY IS REALLY MAKING A GOOD
FAITH EFFORT -- TO AN ACT WILL
THE VOTERS AND GET THIS A
HOUSING SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
SHELTERS YOU KNOW ON THE GROUND
AND SO I REALLY WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR BRING THIS MORNING
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND I WISH THE BILL THE BEST OF
WHAT CONSUMERS FORD.
WITHOUT WE HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND WE DO NOT WOULD SOMEBODY.
A WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN BY SANTIAGO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI STONE. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
MR.
TO WELCOME YOU'RE HERE FOR AB.
SEVEN TWENTY NINE MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RENDON CHAIRS ARE MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SOMEONE ****
AB.
SEVEN TWENTY NINE WHO TO ALLOW.
TO IS REALLY A FOLLOW UP BILL MY
BILL FROM LAST YEAR. TO IMPROVE
CARPET RECYCLING IN CALIFORNIA.
AB SEVEN TWENTY NINE ALLOW FOR A
BRIDGE OR A CONTINGENCY PLAN OF
COURSE BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT.
OF RESOURCES A RECYCLING AND
RECOVERY CAL RECYCLE FOR SHORT
TO AVOID DISRUPTING -- GOOD
DISRUPTING CALIFORNIA'S CARPET
RECYCLING EFFORT.
M. PROTECTIVE FEES PAID BY
CONSUMERS IN THE CASE THAT THE
STATE CARPET STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM
RUN BY THE MANUFACTURER.
MANUFACTURES IS DISAPPROVE OR
REVOKED.
IN ADDITION A BEAT SEVEN TWENTY
NINE REQUIRES THE COP IS TO
WORSHIP ORGANIZATION TO DEPOSIT
FUNDS.
INTO A TRUST FOR ESCROW ACCOUNT
TO REACH HIM FUNDING TO RUN THE
PROGRAMMING IN CASE THE PROPOSED
PLANNED IS DISAPPROVED.
FOOD BETTER TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BACKGROUND INFORMATION CALL
WHOOPED CALIFORNIA PASS AB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT SETS TANGIBLE
GOALS FOR THIS TOUR SHIP PROGRAM.
INCLUDING A 24% RECYCLING TARGET.
BY TWENTY TWENTY AND GIVING CAL
RECYCLE THE AUTHORITY TO SET
TARGETS MOVING FORWARD.
AND THE ALSO THE AUTHORITY THE
CALL COPIED RECOVERY AFTER CARE.
AND RIGHT NOW DO YOU CAL -- TO
RECYCLE DISAPPROVED THE PLAN.
OF OF FOUR FOUR GOOD FOR THE
CURRENT YEAR AND THE PROGRAM WAS
SEATS.
OF DISRUPTING CALIFORNIA COPIED
RECYCLING PROGRAM WAS ALL A WAY.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO RETRIEVE
CONSUMER OF FEATS.
M. PROVIDE GRANTS TO CONTINUE
THE PROGRAM.
SO AB SEVEN TWENTY NINE
ADDRESSED AS YOU.
BY ALLOWING A BRIDGE PLAN. TO
CONTINUE THE PROGRAM BY
UTILIZING CONSUMERS FEE.
IF IT'S PROPOSAL PLANNED IS
DISAPPROVED.
THE BILL IS STILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK OF HISTORY STAKEHOLDER TO
ADDRESS -- ISSUE THAT THEY DO
HAVE A BROUGHT TO TO OUR
ATTENTION.
WHAT'S SAD I WAS TOO YOU WILL
HOW BUT THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL.
AND SO -- SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND THE WE'RE HOW
[inaudible]
HONORABLE.
I'M SORRY -- SAID CONSERVE -- TO
TESTIFY THE THE THE TODAY.
WHICH IT WILL HAVE CHIU JASON IS
SH MISTER LESSER.
ON BEHALF OF NATIONAL STILL URGE
TO WORSHIP ACTION COUNCIL AND
GREAT CAMPBELL ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERFACE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AT
JASON ABOUT THE HER BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS YOU'RE
TO COUNCIL IN THE NATIONAL
STORAGE ACTION COUNCIL STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL -- KEEP YOUR
PROGRAMS -- WE TALK ABOUT THESE
FOR A FEW YEARS THIS IS ONE OF
THE ORIGINAL EARLY EPR PROGRAMS-THAT WAS PASSED AND WE'VE HAD
SOME STRUGGLES GETTING IT
IMPLEMENTED -- AND GETTING
COMPLAINTS FROM THE
MANUFACTURERS -- THIS BILL
NOTABLY DOES TWO THINGS AND I
WANT TO SPEAK TO WHAT THE
OPPOSITION PUT THEIR LETTERS
REALLY QUICKLY -- ONE ON THE
BRIDGE PLANET ESSENTIALLY
CREATES A MECHANISM IN LAW WHICH
DOES NOT EXIST RIGHT NOW FOUR IF
A STEWARDSHIP PLAN I WERE TO BE
DISAPPROVED OR GO TO FONG THEY
WOULD BE IN POSSESSION OF
CALIFORNIA FEE PAYER MONEY.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT SAYS HEY
YOU NEED TO HAVE AN ESCROW
ACCOUNT TO MAKE SURE IS THAT
MONEY FLOWS TO THE PURPOSES FOR
WHICH IT WAS INTENDED?
AND AND IS SAFE NOW WE'VE TALKED
TO THE OPPOSITION WE'VE TALKED
TO COVER CYCLE A LOT OF THIS
FLOWS FROM TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THAT WE RECEIVED FROM THEM -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE COULD BE
SOME HICK UPS AS FAR AS THE ONE
YEAR -- THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
GOES AND OF TIME OVER WHICH THAT
WOULD GO AND AND SPEAKING UP FOR
MY CLINTS WERE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO WORK OUT THOSE DETAILS THIS
ISN'T ABOUT -- A GOTCHA OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT IT'S ABOUT
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA FEE PAYER
MONEY -- SECONDARILY -- THE
LANGUAGE TO ADJUST THE PENALTIES
SLIGHTLY -- IT GETS RID OF A
THOUSAND DOLLAR LEVEL PENALTY
AND CREATES A TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR LEVEL PENALTY -- AND ALSO
GETS RID OF THE LANGUAGE --
ABOUT WILL FULL -- BUT NEGLIGENT
ETCETERA -- I DO WANNA MAKE A
QUICK NOTE THEY SAY I BELIEVE IN
THEIR LETTER THAT THIS THERE'S
NO OTHER IF YOUR PROGRAM WITH
THIS PENALTY LEVEL.
SB -- TWO ONE TWO LAST YEAR
JACKSON TING AND GRAY -- ON
PHARMACEUTICALS HAS A TEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR BASE PENALTY
LEVEL -- AND A FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR PENALTY LEVEL FOR WILL
FULL NEGLIGENT -- IT CETERA THAT
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR PENALTY
LEVEL IS NOT HERE THIS AMENDMENT --
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE LAST YOUR
BILL THAT WAS DONE IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HAS ONE ECHO AND
POINT THAT OUT.
AND THE REASON THAT WE'RE HERE
VERY QUICKLY.
WE'VE GOT MULTIPLE YEARS OF NON
COMPLIANCE BY THE MANUFACTURERS
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'RE
TRYING THAT THERE ARE CHALLENGES --
BUT THE PROGRAM NEEDS TO BE
WHIPPED INTO SHAPE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE CALIFORNIA THE PAIR
MONEY THAT WE ARE COLLECTING IS
BEING USED FOR ITS INTENDED
PURPOSE AND WITH THAT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS -- DRAKE
CAMPBELL AND I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING INTERFACE.
INTERFACE IS A WORLDWIDE --
COMMERCIAL FLOORING COMPANY AND
ALSO ONE OF THE LARGEST CARPET
RECYCLERS AND UNITED STATES.
INTERFACE HAS ALSO BEEN AN
INDUSTRY MEMBER OF THE
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL -- CARE --
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN.
TWENTY TEN WE REMAIN COMMITTED
TO ENCOURAGING BEST PRACTICES IN
RECYCLING ACROSS OUR INDUSTRY
AND LIKE OTHERS.
INCLUDING CAL RECYCLE NUMEROUS
TIMES WE HAVE CONCERNS OF THE
CURRENT DIRECTION OF CARE IS NOT
RESULTING IN CONTINUOUS MEETING
FOR TREATMENT TOWARDS OUR CARPET
RECYCLING GOALS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE THINK
THAT AB SEVENTY NINE AS
NECESSARY WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING IT FORWARD AND ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD EVENING MY CLUB IS
CALIFORNIANS WASTE AND STRONG
SUPPORT AND COMMEND THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS OVER THE
YEARS THANK YOU.
KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE AND SUPPORT.
LOOK AT US HERE ON OUR BEHALF IS
ALWAYS ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA AND SUPPORT.
LOWER FRONT AND HELP THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE WISHING TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RAINY POLLOCK ON
BEHALF OF THE CARPET AND RUG
INSTITUTE OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
ARE PART OF THE STORE TO PLAN
CALLED CARE.
I JUST LIKE MAKE ONE CORRECTION
THERE IS CURRENTLY AN APPROVED
PLAN THAT CARE IS OPERATING
UNDER AND THAT WAS APPROVED
EARLIER THIS YEAR BY CAL RECYCLE
I THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO MEET BY
SEPTEMBER FIRST AND WE HAVE A
RECYCLING RATE OF 24% OR CARE.
DOES BY THE END OF THIS YEAR.
I AGREE WITH THE WITH THE
SOMEONE AND THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
A CONTINUATION OR BRIDGE PLAN
OUR CONCERN WHICH WAS REYES --
BY JASON IS PUTTING THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS INTO AN ESCROW
OR TRUST ACCOUNT AND OUR
QUESTION IS WHERE DOES THAT
MONEY COME FROM.
THE MONEY THAT IS CURRENTLY IN
THE CARE ACCOUNT IS GOING TO BE
SPENT DOWN WHATEVER SURPLUS WE
HAVE IT IS PART OF THE PLAN.
THAT IS GOING TO USE FOR
SUBSIDIES IT'S GONNA BE USED FOR
GRANTS.
IN IN DISCUSSIONS WITH CAL
RECYCLE THEY WANTED TO HAVE A
TWO MONTH RESERVE AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'LL BE SPENDING DOWN THE
SURPLUS THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW
SO WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT AN
ADDITIONAL FEE AND CONSUMERS. TO
CREATE ANOTHER THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR ACCOUNT IS WARRANTED --
THIS ASSESSMENT AND CARBON HAS
BEEN INCREASED GETTING BACK IN
TWENTY ELEVEN FROM FIVE CENTS IT
WAS JUST INCREASED -- NOW IT'S
AT THIRTY FIVE CENTS THE LATEST
INCREASE IN JANUARY FIRST OF
THIS YEAR.
THE SECOND PART OF THE BILL THAT
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IS
ABOUT THE FINES HE USED TO BE
THAT IF YOU WERE FIND UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS THERE HAD TO BE
A STANDARD OF CONDUCT THAT HAD
BE SHOWN.
YOU HAD TO BE SHOWN THAT YOU'RE
NEGLIGENT THERE'S INTENTIONAL
MISCONDUCT OR KNOWING THIS
CONDUCT WE BELIEVE THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU APPARATUS THE
STEWARDSHIP PLAN YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY DIRECT CONTROL YOU'RE
WORKING WITH PROCESSORS TO
WORKING WITH RECYCLERS YOU'RE
WORKING WITH -- COLLECTORS AND
MANUFACTURES.
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THEM AND
YOU'RE GETTING AGREEMENTS WITH
THEM SAYING THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
PROMISING TO DO CERTAIN THINGS
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS WHAT WE SEEN
AS WE MAY HAVE AN EQUIPMENT
FAILURE SOME OP PROCESS OR MAY
HAVE AN EQUIPMENT FAILURE.
WE HAD ONE COMPANY THIS YEAR
THAT SAID THAT THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO TAKE THIRTY MILLION
POUNDS OF CARPET.
AND THEN THE COMPANY WAS SOLD
AND SO THAT FACILITY IS NO
LONGER RECYCLING CARPET THAT'S
SOMETHING BEYOND OUR CONTROL SO
WE BELIEVE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO HAVE A STANDARD OF CONDUCT
WHERE TO MINISTER TO LECTURE.
JUDGE CAN LOOK TO SEE WHERE YOU
NEGLIGENT IN YOUR DUTIES.
IN YOUR DUTIES WERE YOU
INTENTIONALLY WRONGFUL IN THE
WAY YOU CONDUCTED YOUR BUSINESS
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THAT IT'S
VERY ARBITRARY -- WE THINK THAT
THAT SHOULD BE REINSTATED AND IF
GORDON MISTER SMELTER THAT YOU
KNOW WE IN THE WEST OR CHIP PLAN
THAT THEY HAVE -- THAT STANDARD
THEY REMOVE THAT STANDARD BUT I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY I THINK
IT'S PROBABLY A HUNDRED TIMES
BIGGER THAN THE CARPET INDUSTRY.
AND SO THE NUMBERS THAT ARE IN
THAT BILL I DON'T THINK COULD BE
APPLICABLE TO HEAR FINALLY I'D
LIKE TO CONCLUDE IS THAT OVER
THE LAST -- DURING THE MOUNT OF
THIS PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE GIVEN
AWAY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANTS FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN SUBSIDIES AND WHILE
THE CARPET RATE CONTINUES TO
INCREASE WE HAVE SEEN THE
DIFFICULTIES OF LIKE CAL
RECYCLING TRYING TO MEET THE
OVERALL RECYCLING RATE OF THE
STATE WHICH IS.
SUPPOSED TO BE 75% AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR.
THEY STARTED A 52% SEVERAL YEARS
AGO THERE AT 42% RIGHT NOW AND
THE CLIENT SO THAT SHOWS YOU
THAT CREATING AN INTRICATE
RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA IS VERY DIFFICULT.
BUT WE BELIEVE CALIFORNIA WILL
MEET ITS GOALS ON CARPET AND WE
CONTINUE TO THINK WILL CONTINUE
TO THRIVE BECAUSE WE ARE THE
FIRST IN THE NATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- I GREW UP IN HERE
ON BEHALF OF MOHAWK INDUSTRIES --
AND AND WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL --
I I REITERATE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT -- MISTER POLLOCK SAID
INTEREST IN THE THE
UNPRECEDENTED NATURE OF THE OF
THE OF THE MASSIVE FINES -- FOR
IN TAKING OUT THE KNOWING IN
NEGLIGENT -- STANDARD -- ONE
THING I WANT TO POINT OUT AND I
GUESS I REALLY WANT TO SAY THIS.
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT THE AUTHOR.
HAD INDICATED AS HE WAS CLOSING --
AND THAT HE WAS THIS IS A WORK
IN PROGRESS AND I I REALLY WANT
TO FOCUS ON THAT -- WERE OPPOSED
TO THE WORK IN PROGRESS WE WE WE
WOULD WE WOULD PREFER THIS
COMMITTEE JUST VOTE ON A BILL TO
SAY HEY THIS IS THE BILL AND
THIS IS THE BILL OR VOTING ON
AND AND AND AS AS AMENDED REST
PROPOSED TO BE IN AND FOR THAT
MATTER.
WE WOULD REALLY STRENUOUSLY
OPPOSE A WORK IN PROGRESS
BECAUSE TWO YEARS AGO THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS ROLLED THROUGH
HERE WITH AB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
AND IT WAS A IT WAS A REALLY A
NOTHING BILL AND WE WEREN'T
OPPOSED TO IT WENT OVER THE
SENATE.
AND THE SENATE.
SUBSTANTIVELY CHANGED IT CAME
BACK TO THIS SITE IN AUGUST AND
AND AND THIS SITE HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO JUST HAVE A HEARING ON IT
AND JUST.
LET US VENT TO AND THEN PUT IT
ON THE FLOOR SO IT WE THINK HE
THE ASSEMBLY NATURI SOURCES
COMING.
HASN'T IT THE THE THE THE THE
SPONSORING AUTHOR HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO THE COMMITTEE TO
ACTUALLY VOTE ON A BILL HERE.
AND ACTUALLY ALLOW THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS IN THE IN THE IN THE
FOLKS ON THIS COMMITTEE ACTUALLY
CRAFT THAT BILL RATHER THAN LET
THE SENATE DO IT FOR YOU SO.
SO WE WE WE ASK YOU TO TO YOUR
TO DECIDE YOU KNOW THE THERE'S
SOME THERE'S SOME THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE AUTHOR STATEMENT
I'M IN THE OFFICE FACT SHEET
THAT INDICATES THE NEED FOR A A
TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR NO
NEGLIGENCE FINE.
THERE'S NOTHING -- YOU KNOW
DOCTORS FACTUALLY TALKS ABOUT
THE NEED FOR A BRIDGE PLAN WERE
FINE WITH THE BRIDGE PLAN -- BUT
BUT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE NOT
FINE WITH HAVING A YEARS WORTH
OF MONEY TIED UP IN IT THAT THAT
THAT'S NOT GONNA HELP THE THE
RECYCLING PROGRAM AND FINALLY --
JUST.
IF WE WANT CARPET RECYCLING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WORK.
DON'T LET THAT LET THE STORAGE
OF ORGANIZATION DO THEIR JOB
RATHER KEEP COMING BACK HERE
WITH LEGISLATION IF IF IF THIS
WAS NEEDED IF ANY OF THIS OR
ANYTHING.
THAT THAT THE IS PLANNED BY THE
SPONSOR IS NEEDED IT COULD'VE
BEEN DEALT WITH IN AB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT THEY JUST WROTE THE
THEY WROTE THAT BILL.
IT'S ONLY BEEN IT'S ONLY BEEN IN
IMPLEMENTED FOR A YEAR IT WAS
PASSED TWO YEARS AGO TOOK A YEAR
TO IMPLEMENTED IN OUR BACK HERE
WITH ANOTHER BILL.
JUST KIND OF JUST MAKING IT
HARDER FOR THE ORGANIZATION TO
DO THE JOB THAT YOU GUYS PASSED
THEM TO DO SO WE ASK FOR YOU TO
HEAR NO VOTE OR AT LEAST.
VOTE ON A BILL THAT YOU KNOW
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO SEE AGAIN
THAT THAT WILL BE THE SAME BILL.
OKAY.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY SING NUMBER GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THIS GARCIA.
THANK YOU I KNOW MR CHU HAS BEEN
WORKING ON THIS -- FOR MORE THAN
JUST THIS YEAR -- AND SO DO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT AND SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
UP -- WITH WITH THIS PROGRAM --
ARE HELPING TO GET SOME OF THE
DECISIONS FOR MAKING ON OUR
MATTRESS -- PROGRAM AS WELL BUT
I I DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AND
SOME CONCERNS AS YOU'RE WORKING
ON ON THIS IN THE FIRST ONE IS
TIED TO THE ONE YEAR'S WORTH OF
REVENUE THAT'S BEING SET ASIDE.
AND AND KIND OF THE RATIONALE OR
THE NEED FOR THAT CAN AND IT'S
PART OF WHAT THE OPPOSITION
SPOKE TO CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT.
WELL THIS IS THE VIEW THAT WE
COLLECTED FROM THE CONSUMER.
SO WE ASKED HIM TO DEPOSIT INTO
THE ESCROW ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD TO THAT.
YEAH LISTEN THE THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE GOT THE ONE YEAR -- WAS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FROM POWER
CYCLE I THINK.
THE IDEA IS WE WANT TO TALK TO
THE OPPOSITION AND SAY WHAT WHAT
MAKES SENSE PART WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER AN EPR PROCESSES.
IF THEY DISAPPROVE CARES PLAN
AND THEY GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF DOING ANOTHER PLAN THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TIME LINES THAT
ARE IN THE BILL THERE'S GOING TO
BE NINETY DAYS TO SUBMIT A PLAN
THERE'S GONNA BE A PERIOD TO
REVIEW THE PLAN.
SO IT COULD TAKE SEVERAL MONTHS
TO A YEAR -- TO GET THE NEXT
PLAN IN PLACE AND MOVING SO I
THINK I CAN'T SPEAK FOR POWER
CYCLE OF OBVIOUSLY NOT THAT --
BUT I THINK THE IDEA WAS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE WAS ENOUGH MONEY
TO CONTINUE THE ACTIVITIES OF
THE OF THE RISK FOR CYCLING
PROGRAM SO THAT THE RECYCLERS
DIDN'T GO DEFUNCT.
WHILE THE STATE WAS KIND OF
FIGURING OUT ITS BUSINESS WITH
THE PROGRAM SIGN AND A LITTLE
BIT OF THE TIME AND YOU GAVE ME
AND I WILL CONCEDE THAT YOU CAN
GIVE ME THE FULL DESCRIPTION IT
WAS A LOT LESS THAN A YEAR THAT
YOU GOT TO SUBSCRIBE TO ME.
THOUGH FOR THAT PROCESS IN THE
IN THE APPEALS.
ON AND SO MAYBE CAN I HEAR FROM
YOU GUYS ABOUT THE ONE YEAR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA.
WITH THE PLAN EVEN IF THE PLAN
IS NOT IN PLACE THE MONEY WILL
STILL KEEP FALLING INTO
CALIFORNIA YOU CANNOT SELL
CARPET IN CALIFORNIA.
UNLESS YOU PAY AN ASSESSMENT SO
THAT MONEY WILL CONTINUE TO FLOW
IN THE CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT GOING
TO STOP SO THERE WILL BE A FINE
SET UP WITH THE MONEY CONTINUES
TO COME IN TO OPERATE THE
PROGRAM.
THAT'S WHY WE OPERATE TODAY WERE
OPERATING AT THE MONEY COMES IN
WE'RE SPENDING IT ON THE PROGRAM
SO THAT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE.
SO IS THERE A SHORTER TIME LINE
THAT YOU WOULD BE.
ABLE TO DO IT WHAT WE'RE SAYING
THE MONEY IS ALREADY GOING TO BE
THERE WHY DO WE NEED TO TRY
STERN ESCROW UNTIL.
NO TIMELINE YEAH WELL I THINK I
THINK IT WOULD REALLY TRY TO SAY
IS THERE THE IF WE HAVE TO BUILD
INTO A SOME SOMETHING IN WRITING
THAT SAYS YOU KNOW.
WHAT A DIRT THERE WILL BE A A
TRANSITION MECHANISM TO GO FROM
ONE STORE SHIP ORGANIZATION TO
ANOTHER WE'RE FINE WITH THAT THE
THE THE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY?
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S GOING
TO BE SITTING THERE IS GOING TO
BE THIS WOULD BE THE SAME NO
MATTER WHAT WHETHER IF IF CARE
STILL EXISTS AFTER SEPTEMBER
SECOND.
NOT NOTHING CHANGES CHARACTERS
GOES FORWARD THEY THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY THEY WON'T
NECESSARILY NEED A BIGGER
RESERVE AND ANY NEW STORESHIP
ORGANIZATION ISN'T GONNA
NECESSARILY NEED A BIGGER
RESERVE.
AND AND JUST AS A MATTER OF
EQUITY NO CHARACTER STARTED
THEIR STASHED STARSHIP
ORGANIZATION FROM SCRATCH NOBODY
KNOWS.
NOBODY -- NOBODY FOR PRE FUNDED
THEM IN SAID HEY GET GET ROLLING
I MEAN THEY STARTED FROM SCRATCH
AND AND YOU KNOW AND IT'S HARD
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE WORKING NOT
THEY'RE WORKING ON YOU KNOW
FINING AND MARKETS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS
MONEY YOUR RIGHT IT'S KATE CALM
AND AND WE JUST WANTED TO PUT
THAT INTO A TRUST ACCOUNT.
JACKSON YOU HAVE.
BUT I THINK THE PROBLEM --FROM
THAT JUST A BUREAUCRATIC
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE CURRENT LAW THAT
SAYS WHAT HAPPENS TO THE MONEY
THAT INTO THE IN THE POSSESSION
OF A STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION IF
IT IS NO LONGER APPROVED BY
CARMICHAEL.
THERE'S NOTHING HAT SAYS WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE CALIFORNIA FEW
MONEY IF IT'S IN AN ACCOUNT IN
GEORGIA IT JUST IT DOESN'T SPEAK
TO IT.
WHICH WHICH IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT'S PART OF THE INTENT
OF THE BILL TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENS THERE -- AND WE'RE GOOD
WITH THAT.
YEAH.
AND SO I MEAN IN THAT THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOME COMMON GROUND
AT LEAST ON ON THAT PART OF THE
PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT WHETHER IT'S A
WHOLE YEAR'S WORTH OF PERCENT
ESTIMATE THAT IS WHERE WE HAVE A
DISCONNECT THEM.
I WOULD HOPE YOU GUYS KIND OF
COMING DOWN ON THAT WHERE YOU
MIGHT NOT BE HAPPY BUT IT'S
SOMETHING MAYBE A LITTLE LESS
HERE THAN WHAT THEY'RE ASKING.
FOR AND SO I KNOW RIGHT NOW YOU
KIND OF TELL ME NO BUT I HOPE
YOU MOVE CLOSER THAT DIRECTION
AND AND THERE'S A SPACE BECAUSE
BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN SO MUCH
WORK AND THERE IS A BOOM IS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN HERE.
ALONG THE WAY.
AND THEN MY SECOND QUESTION OF
MY FINAL QUESTION IS ABOUT THE
INTENTIONAL NEGLIGENT NEGLIGENCE
AND WE ARE REMOVING THAT.
IN THIS BILL.
IN FOR FOR THE SPONSOR AND THE
DOCTOR EXPLAIN TO ME WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO HELP US DO A BETTER
JOB AND RECYCLING.
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
NEGLIGENCE JUST VERY DIFFICULT
TO PROVE.
SO THAT THAT'S WHY WERE CUT WILL
HAVE TO CONSIDER AND PRETTY MUCH
GIVE THE THE THE THE LAW JUDGES
OF MORE DISCRETION ON HOW MUCH --
THEY FIND A ONE OR TWO IN --
IMPOSE ON ON A DAILY BASIS.
SO IN THE EXISTING BILL THERE IS
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE COMPLAINING
ABOUT NOW JUST AT A LOWER LEVEL
THERE IS AN EXISTING ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PENALTY THAT
DOES NOT REQUIRE THAT THE MAVS
BACK ON INTENTIONAL KNOWING OR
NEGLIGENT SO THE STANDARD IS.
IN CURRENT LAW RIGHT NOW AND IT
IS IN CURRENT LAW AND SB TWO ONE
TWO FOR PHARMACEUTICALS AT TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS I THINK.
THE REASON THAT WE'RE HERE AND
I'M NOT HERE TO KEEP ANYBODY OUT
BUT WE'VE BEEN IN THIS ENDLESS
ENFORCEMENT LOOP WITH THE
INDUSTRY 201-320-1420. FIFTEEN
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN PLAN WERE THE
PLAN THAT'S IN THE PLACE RIGHT
NOW IS ON A CONTINGENCY BASIS.
IN SEPTEMBER COVER CYCLES GOING
TO TRY TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'VE DONE THEIR JOB AS
DESCRIBED IN THE PLAN IF THEY
DON'T.
WE'RE GONNA BE IN THIS POSITION
WHERE WE'RE GONNA BE EITHER
DISAPPROVING A PLANNER REPEALING
A PLAN AND YOUR EARLIER POINT.
I THINK I OBVIOUSLY CAN'T SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT I
THINK THERE'S A DESIRE FOR MORE
TEETH IN THE ENFORCEMENT.
MECHANISM THAT'S IN CURRENT LAW.
BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN ALL ADMIT
THAT THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
THAT'S IN CURRENT LAW RIGHT NOW
IS NOT WORKING BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN IN THIS AND LET'S
ENFORCEMENT LIVE. FOR YEARS AND
YEARS AND YEARS.
SO IF I'M INTERPRETING CORRECTLY
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT BY
REMOVING THIS OR CHANGING THIS
LANGUAGE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
BETTER ENFORCEMENT.
BUT IT'S STILL GOING TO BE THE
LEGAL PROCESS NONETHELESS AND IS
STILL RIGHT.
YES CORRECT THE MET AND THAT'S
MY MY INTERPRETATION OF THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT WE
RECEIVE YES.
HI I JUST SAID TO ME WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE THAT IF YOU MISS ONE
DEADLINE YOU COULD BE FINED TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY.
YOU CAN MISS AN ANNUAL REPORT BE
FINED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY
THE WAY IT'S SET UP RIGHT NOW
AND AS CHASIN INDICATED.
YES -- IS NOT REALLY YEARS WE
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE WITH A
FINE HE'S LOOK AT ALL THE
INFORMATION AND HE DETERMINED
THAT WE WERE NOT NEGLIGENT.
BECAUSE HE REALIZED THAT WE HAVE
THEIR CONTRACT WITH THIRD PARTY
TO KNOW TO DO CERTAIN THINGS.
SO IN HIS RULINGS HE HAS FOUND
THAT WE WERE NOT NEGLIGENT OR
THERE IS NO INTENTION MISCONDUCT
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
IF YOU'RE GONNA YOU KNOW WE HAVE
LOTS OF PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
CAL RECYCLE ARE WE ALL GOING TO
HOLD EACH OTHER TO THAT SAME
STANDARD.
BECAUSE VERY HARD TO DO THAT
WHEN YOU'RE RELYING UPON THIRD
PARTIES -- I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR
FOR THE BILL TODAY I I DO YOU.
HAVEN'T HAD STATIONS ABOUT.
REMOVE INTENTIONAL NEGLIGENCE.
THERE'S TIME FOR SALE WE SHE
LITTLE BETTER WE SHOULD BE DOING
IT BETTER BUT WE STILL SCREW UP
I JUST GOT A LETTER ABOUT
SOMETHING I TURNED IN TWO DAYS
LATE AND AM I HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT AND MY FIRST GUT REACTION
US LIKE I SHOULD KNOW BETTER.
BUT THEN THEY WERE LIKE YOU
ACTUALLY WERE WAITING FOR LEGAL --
OPINION AND THAT'S WHY I TOOK HE
TOOK TWO DAYS AND SO CYCLE OKAY
WELL THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF AND
STILL GETTING TING.
RIGHT AN SO.
IT JUST REMINDS YOU OF WHY
INTENTIONAL NEGLIGENCE AND
SOMETHING THAT I DO THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S IMPORTANT HELLO
FOR THE BILL TODAY I DON'T KNOW
IF.
AS THIS BILL MOVES WITH THAT
PIECE I'M GOING TO BE OKAY WITH
THAT DOWN THE ROAD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR THE FINE IS
UP TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A DAY
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT HAS TO
BE TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO IT DOES GIVE -- OF
FLEXIBILITY TO LOOK AT EACH
PARTICULAR INSTANCE AND TO SAY.
IS IT SOMETHING THAT'S AGREE
JUST ARE NOT IS IT SOMETHING
THAT REALLY WARRANTS THAT KIND
OF FINE OR WAS THERE SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED THAT WAS OUT OF
THEIR CONTROL SO THERE CAN
CERTAINLY BE A LOT OF DISCRETION --
THAT'S USED THE CARD OTHER
COMMENTS FROM.
COMMITTEE YOUR QUESTIONS.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY -- I'M SORRY DID YOU WANT
TO CLOSE.
NO THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE YOU
ASKED FOR YOUR EYE BELOW.
THANK YOU I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL THIS IS CLEARLY YOU KNOW A
BIG.
PROBLEM -- WITH ART WITH CAL
RECYCLE WITH THE INDUSTRY -- I'M
GLAD THAT YOU'RE SOUNDS LIKE
STILL TALKING AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO DO THAT --
AND I'D COMMEND THE AUTHOR --
FOR YOU KNOW TAKING ON THIS IS
VERY DIFFICULT BUT VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY DO WE
HAVE A MOTION YET [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE DON'T WITH ANYBODY INTERESTED
IN MY OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU -- WE
WERE MOTION A SECOND -- ROLL
CALL PLEASE ITEM TEN A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
LARA NOT VOTING CHAU
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING GARCIA.
GARCIA I LOW.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
THE LENDERS KNOW MURATSUCHI
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
SO. NINE FIVE TWO FIVE TWO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN CRAFT
REMEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEC ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES.
WITH A. B..
SIX THIRTY NINE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I THIS THING IS
CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS OF
TRANSITIONING THE STATE'S GOODS
MOVEMENT NETWORK TWO ZERO AND
NEAR ZERO EMISSIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE REMARKABLE
PROGRESS ON REDUCING THE HARMFUL
MISSION THE STATE HAS FAILED TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACT OF THESE
ACTIONS ON INCUMBENT WORKERS
TODAY AB IS SIX THIRTY NINE
ESTABLISHES A COMMISSION TO
ADVISE.
STATE AGENCIES ON POLICIES WORK
FORCE POLICIES IN FUNDING TO
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF
TRANSITIONING SEE POOR OPERATION
TWO ZERO AND NEAR ZERO MISSIONS.
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
MORE IN MINUTES.
MARI BUT NOW WE HAVE LIVE.
MARIN PIN IT ON BEHALF OF THE OF
THE V. YOU WENT THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR I'M BRINGING
THE MEASURE FOR AND FOR THE
AMENDMENTS -- AT THE POOL THE
WORKERS AT THE PORTS ARE ANNA
AND TRANSITION TO MAKE
EVERYTHING EASIER AND IS YOUR
MISSION OF EQUIPMENT WE SUPPORT
CLEAN AIR.
AND THE BILL HELPS US TO
MITIGATE THE JOB IMPACTS AT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
CONTINUE.
WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVENING MY JACOB
HIM AS A BEHALF OF RETURN
OPERATORS ARE SCARCE WE HAVE AN
OFFICIAL SPORT POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IS THIS
MISS FORD.
AND CONTINUE DISCUSSION ON THE
ON THE TRANSITION ISSUES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MANY.
CERVANTES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECT CLASS FOR I ABOUT
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM EIGHT A. B. SIX THIRTY NINE
BY MEMBERS CERVANTES THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
MELENDEZ VOTING.
RIGHT TO CHIEF.
STONE.
PHONE. NINE EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MISTER LACKEY.
WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S?
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
IT'S BEEN VERY LONG DAY.
YEAH AND VERY EXCITED TO PRESENT
TO YOU.
A VERY -- MEANINGFUL BILL.
HAS TO DO WITH RECYCLING.
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM AND I
HAVE SO WITH IT'S BEEN WAITING
AS LONG AS WE ALL HAVE.
THERE'S JOHN KENNEDY AND I WANT
US FOR BRIEF.
EXPLANATION OF WHY THEY SHOULD
SUPPORT THIS IS THE BEST
PRESENTATION TODAY.
WELL DONE JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE
RURAL COUNTIES AND ALL
INCORPORATE BY REFERENCE A LOT
OF THE COMMENTS THAT I MADE FOR
HIS EGGMAN BILL EARLIER -- THIS
DOES DEFINITELY HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ADDRESS CHINA'S
NATIONAL SOARED AND DOES
DEFINITELY HELP US ACHIEVE THE
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE ORGANIC
WASTE RECYCLING REQUIREMENTS.
IMPORTANTLY -- THIS BILL HELPS
IDENTIFY BARRIERS -- FOR
CONSTRUCTING THE NEW FACILITIES
THAT WE HAVE TO BUILD OUT TO
ACHIEVE THOSE -- RECYCLING
MANDATES IT REQUIRES POWER CYCLE
TO ADOPT A PROGRAM E. I. R.
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT
UNDER SEQUEL -- THAT WILL REDUCE
LOCAL COSTS AND DELAYS
ASSOCIATED WITH GOING THROUGH
SEQUEL FOR EACH AND EVERY
FACILITY -- THAT'S BUILT EACH
EVER FACILITY WILL STILL HAVE TO
GET A C. QUOTE REVIEW -- BUT
THAT REVIEW IS NOT GOING TO TAKE
NEARLY AS LONG -- AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO COST AS MUCH -- BECAUSE
THIS STATE PROGRAM E. I. R. IS
GOING TO BE VERY VERY
COMPREHENSIVE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
Q. IS THERE ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THE PAPERS LIKE IT DOES HERE ON
BEHALF OF STOP WASTE SOLD HUESO
STATION OF NORTH AMERICA AND
WESTERN PLACERVILLE ACE
MANAGEMENT THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL OR ANY.
WINNERS ON THE BILL.
OKAY HELP SOMEBODY COMING UP.
HI TIFFANY HANG WITH A
CALIFORNIA BY RELIGIOUS ALLIANCE
TO HOW WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL AND ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED THANK YOU.
Q. ANYONE ELSE.
HI LIZ THAT HERNANDEZ WITH
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY WERE ALSO
CONCERNED WITH THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU OFFER GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY ANYBODY WITH
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THE
AUTHOR.
SING NOBODY LIKE TO CLOSE.
AND APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
I THOUGHT WE HAD A MOTION A
SECOND YES YEAH WE DID.
YEAH I AM EIGHTEEN A. B. TWELVE
THIRTY SIX BY MEMBER LACKEY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS A REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING LIMóN.
HI Là MON I MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI.
STONE.
STONE I EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO
YOUR BILL SOUND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS -- IS EGGMAN YOU
WILL BE PRESENTING FOR MR GARCIA.
NO NO YOU DID A YOU DIDN'T DO --
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX TWO THE BILL.
YOU DID ANOTHER BILL
[inaudible]
IT'S LATE.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ALREADY.
OKAY.
YEAH YEAH YES THE AB THIRTY NAY
THREE TEST CARP WITH CREATING A
STREAMLINED MECHANISM NOW WE'RE
BACK TRYING TO DO A LITTLE BIT
BETTER AND I HAVE MICHAEL B<c.cyan></c>
ADAIR YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT BETTER
THE TREASURER'S OFFICE MICHAEL
BOOKER ON BEHALF OF THE AG.
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION
THIS IS -- ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE LAST YEAR
CARB -- WORKED ON A PLAN ON HOW
TO IMPLEMENT A PILOT FINANCIAL
MECHANISM FOR THE LOW CARBON
FUEL STANDARD.
THE CONCEPT HERE IS VERY
STRAIGHT FORWARD SPACE TO
CREATING A LONG TERM CONTRACT
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL CREDITS
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE IMPORTANT
PROJECTS THAT ARE REDUCING
METHANE.
CONCEPT IS TO CREATE A LONG TERM
CONTRACT WITH THE FLOOR PRICE --
IT.
IMPROVES THE STABILITY REMOVES
THE VOLATILITY FROM THAT MARKET
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT OF CREDITS
WE GIVE YOU A QUICK EXAMPLE WHEN
WE BUILD A DAIRY PIPELINE BIO
GAS TO TRANSPORTATION FEEL
PROJECT.
MORE THAN 90% OF THE REVENUE
COMES FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CREDITS MAKING THESE PROJECTS
VERY HARD TO FINANCE BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO LONG TERM CONTRACTS
THIS BILLS DESIGNED TO CORRECT
THAT ISSUE -- THE TREASURES
OFFICES -- WAS THE PREFERRED
OFFICE FROM THE HERE RESOURCES
BOARD THEY DIDN'T FEEL THAT
THERE WOULD BE APPROPRIATE IF
THEY WERE IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM SINCE THEY ALSO RUN THE
LC FS.
PROGRAM THANK YOU. FOR THE
COALITION FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS WE REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MEMBERS IN ALL
SECTORS OF THE R. G. INDUSTRY
I'M INCLUDING UTILITIES --
ORGANIZED LABOR AND PRODUCES OF
OVER 90% OF THE ARE IN G. NORTH
AMERICA I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT
SPONSORING THE OTHER THIS BILL
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD WE
THINK IT'S CRITICAL. TO THE
ULTIMATE SUCCESS OF THE GOALS OF
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
AND WE'D BE ACCEPTING THE
ATTENDANCE THANK YOU.
OKAY -- IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE CA
WHO IS HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
REBEKAH BOUDREAUX BROWN FEELS
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP.
MORE OF A TWEENER BUT LAUREN
COMMON BE OUT OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA -- WE'VE BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
ABOUT SOME CONCERNS WE HAVE
ABOUT THE RECENT AMENDMENTS AND
ARE LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM ON THE THANK YOU --
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SEE NOW WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ON BEHALF MISTER GARCIA.
THANK YOU ALL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND AND WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
BUT WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
WHO IS THE SECOND?
I'M SORRY OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE NOW MOTION A SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
FOR ELEVEN FIFTY SIX ITEM
THIRTEEN A. B. ELEVEN FIFTY SIX
BY EDUARDO GARCIA THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA FLOOR AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN BY EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I'LL.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN
DESIGN OR TO TREAT [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THAT
BILL PASSES MS ONE ON EUROPE.
WITH.
SIXTEEN EIGHTY THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
EIGHTY RESPONSE TO THE
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNOR'S BROWN'S
CALL TO BRING STAKEHOLDERS TO
THE TABLE TO DEVELOP.
A NEW COASTAL ACCESS PROGRAM FOR
THE PUBLIC AT HOLLISTER RANCH IN
MY DISTRICT -- WITH THAT.
AS WE HAVE AVAILABLE ON THE FROM
A STUDENT.
WHO IS HERE TO SPEAK IN FOR THE
BILL?
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF FOR
A LOT OF ON THE HERE ON BEHALF
OF A SUIT -- I'LL BE BRIEF I
JUST GIVEN OUR EXPERIENCE
WORKING ON THE GROUND WITH --
WITH COMMUNITIES THAT
HISTORICALLY HAD REALLY HARD
CHALLENGES IN GETTING OUT TO THE
COAST -- WE FULLY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MONIQUE LOANS
EFFORTS. TO TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
A PORTION OF CINEMA COUNTY --
AND THEREFORE ASK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THE ROMERO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AT LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. ONE OF THE MEAT ON A
WITHOUT ABOUT CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
LARA NAVARRO HERE FOR AN RTC AND
ALSO FOR LIKE YOU KNOW I DOORS
HERE IN SUPPORT.
LAUREN COLUMN WAS SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY SING NUMBER GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
TAKE ROLL CALL PLEASE I AM
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY SIXTEEN
EIGHTY BY MEMBER LEMOND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLOOR I CHILD [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN HI LIMON AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
STONE.
SO. NINE SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU I'M
GONNA PASSED THE GAVEL TO MISTER
FLORA AND PRESENT.
THE LAST TWO BILLS OF THE
EVENING
.
NO ONE EVEN.
ALRIGHT MADAM CHAIR ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR THANK YOU MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YEAH -- CALIFORNIA'S YOU ALL
KNOWS BUT EXPERIENCING MORE
FREQUENT DEADLY WILDFIRES.
I'M NOT GONNA TAKE THE TIME
TONIGHT TO DELVE INTO THAT AGAIN.
THANK YOU.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE SOURCES FOR OF
IGNITION FOR WILD FIRES FROM
HUMAN ACTIVITY INCLUDING
ELECTRIFY THE ENERGY POWER LINES.
DE ENERGIZING POWER LINES IS ONE
OF THE MITIGATION MEASURES SUCH
PROPOSED WHAT WE KNOW OF COURSE
THAT THAT HAS HUGE IMPACT
SOMETIMES ON COMMUNITIES -- AND
A LOT OF OUR WORLD COMMUNITIES
ARE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE TO
THIS.
ENERGY STORAGE IN DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES LOCATED IN
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES COULD
ENABLE THE CENTRAL LOADS TO
REMAIN SERVICE IN THE FACE OF
MORE FREQUENT GREAT OUTAGES I'M
PROVIDE RESILIENCY FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR REQUIRES
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO USE UP
210% OF THE SELF GENERATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FUNDS FROM TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TO BE ALLOCATED
TOWARDS CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FACILITIES.
IN HIGH FIRE THREAT DISTRICTS
THE INITIATIVE FUNDS IN THIS
BILL COULD SUPPORT MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE LARGE FACILITIES
SUCH AS WATER SUPPLIERS
WATERSHED AGENCIES HOSPITALS IN
CAMPUSES.
AND MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED SMALL
FACILITIES SUCH AS SCHOOLS AND
FIRE STATIONS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS A
WITNESS IS JOHN KENNEDY FROM
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
GOOD EVENING JOHN CAN BE WITH A
RURAL COUNTIES -- THE AUTHOR
TOOK MOST OF OUR COMMENTS SO
I'LL JUST SAY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL IS A WAY TO
INSURE THAT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE REMAINS ONLINE.
DURING DINNER IS ATION EVENTS --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR UNDERSTAFFED AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO HELP
INSURE THAT THESE -- STORAGE
SYSTEMS CAN PROVIDE THE LONG
TERM -- DURATION THAT WE NEED --
TO GET THROUGH THE
STANDARDIZATION EVENTS AND LOOK
TOWARDS OTHER TYPES OF
TECHNOLOGIES THAT COULD BE USED
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT. FOR CALLING WAS
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MICHAEL DAY WITH -- TRAINING --
SOL RAND -- REPRESENTING A
COUPLE OF OUR CLIENTS INCLUDING
HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE A COMMUNITY
IN LAKE COUNTY -- WERE GENERALLY
IN SUPPORT WE'RE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE WITH THE AUTHOR WE
THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME WAYS
TO IMPROVE THIS TO ALLOW.
GREATER ADD TO ALLOW GREATER --
INFORMATION TO MAKE FUTURE
POLICY ON THANK YOU THANK YOU WE
WILL ALSO SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANY OPPOSITION.
CNN BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CNN MANAGER WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
I JUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU HAVE CIGNA
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWELVE A. B. ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA BY FLORA AYE CHAU
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA ISLA MON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S LINDA'S
AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE I TEN ZERO BILLS OUT TEN
ZERO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
NOT YET.
I ONE MORE BILL.
WE CAN TAKE THE ROLE FOR CONSENT
IF YOU WANT SURE.
BEST A GOOD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR CONSENT CALENDAR ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN AYE
FLORA AYE FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA ISLA MON.
Là MON I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ LENDERS I
MURATSUCHI WROTE TO GI STONE.
SO [inaudible]
NINE TEN ZERO WHAT'S NEXT.
THE NINETY FIVE SEVENTEEN NINETY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RECENT PRICE SPIKES IN
CALIFORNIA RESULTED IN OVER
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND NATURAL GAS PURCHASES TO
SUPPLY ELECTRICITY TO AND USE
CUSTOMERS.
THE ONSET OF THIS WAS UNEXPECTED
IN THE CAUSE NOT YET FULLY KNOWN.
THE UTILITY SERVING MY DISTRICT
EDISON ELLIE W. P. BURBANK WATER
POWER AND GLENDALE WATER POWER
AND THE REPAIRS OF ALL BEEN HIT
HARD BY THESE PRICE SPIKES AND
I'MSURE YOU ALL EXPERIENCE THE
SAME THING IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
AB SEVENTY NINETY NINE REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE CERTAIN
DATA REGARDING NATURAL GAS
MARKETS TO DETERMINE THE CAUSES
OF NATURAL GAS PRICE VOLATILITY
EXPERIENCED BY END USERS.
THE CDC WOULD ESTABLISH THE
JOINT AGENCY NATURAL GAS MARKET
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE TO GATHER
ANALYZE AND MAKE REFERRALS TO
THE ENFORCEMENT DIVISION OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO EVALUATE
WHAT DATE IS NEED TO UNDERSTAND
THE UNDERLYING CAUSES A PRICE
VOLATILITY AND THE STEPS OF ME
TAKEN TO LIMIT.
WHILE MUCH OF THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY SUBMITTED TO THE STATE
IT'S DONE SO IN A PIECEMEAL
FASHION AND THIS WOULD ENSURE
MUCH GREATER GOVERNMENT -- TRIP --
TRANSPARENCY AB SEVENTY NINETY
NINE WILL REQUIRE THE COLLECTION
OF INDIVIDUAL NATURAL GAS
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
COMPANY DATA IN A MORE HOLISTIC
AND COMPREHENSIVE MANNER.
THE BILL ALSO DIRECTS ALL LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES I USE MINIS AND
CCA'S TO SUBMIT A WHOLESALE
MARKET RISK MANAGEMENT PLANS.
THESE PLANS BUT INCLUDE HOW THEY
WOULD REDUCE THE RISK FROM PRICE
VOLATILITY IN THE WHOLESALE
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS
MARKETS BUT WHILE REDUCING
OVERALL GREENHOUSE GASES AN
INCREASE IN THE USE OF CLEAN
ENERGY.
REQUIRING A LECTURE PROVIDERS TO
PLAN FOR UNLIMITED PRICE
VOLATILITY WHILE REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
SUPPORTS THE STATE'S CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOALS WHILE
PROTECTING CONSUMERS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY AS A
WITNESS IS LARA NAVARRO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND.
HI EVERYBODY THANK YOU FOR
STAYING SO LATE -- THIS EVENING
THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE BILL MEANT
TO SAVE YOUR CONSTITUENTS
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WE SAW -- A PRICE SPIKE LAST
YEAR TO THE CALIFORNIA COST
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND HOMEOWNERS --
REAL PEOPLE ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS SO THIS BILL IS MEANT TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THE AVOID IT
THOSE SORTS A PRICE SPIKE SO WE
SEE MUCH SMOOTHER PRICES.
IN REAL PEOPLE'S ELECTRICITY AND
ENERGY BILLS SO BASICALLY IT
REQUIRES THE STATE AGENCIES WHO
WORK ON ELECTRICITY ISSUES TO
COLLECT DATA AND ANALYZE THAT
DATA.
THAT WILL GIVE US INFORMATION
WHAT CROSSES PRICE VOLATILITY I
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE LOW SERVING
ENTITIES. TO INCLUDE MEASURES TO
MANAGE THOSE RISKS THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED.
AND SMOOTHED OUT PRICE
VOLATILITY IN THEIR I. R. PEAS
THIS BILL WOULD HELP REAL
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES TO SAVE
MONEY AND HAVE PREDICTABLE
ENERGY BILLS WHICH I THINK WE
CAN ALL APPRECIATE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE TONIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD EVENING OF FURTHER ALONG ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WE GET CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
LARA COMMA SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
CNN ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
CNN QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING.
NINE I'M SURE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
NINE THANK YOU MADAM SECULAR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THIRTY ONE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY NINE BY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLOOR NOT VOTING CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA ISLA.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ NO ROUTE SURGERY. TWO
G. AYE STONE.
STONE I EIGHT ONE FILLS OUT A
ONE LEAVE IT -- FABS MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'LL GO BACK AND WE'LL GO
BACK NOW TWO BILLS THAT ARE ON
CALL.
ITEM ONE AB.
THIRTY EIGHT MEMBER WOULD KNOW
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS.
THREE TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN.
HI FRIEDMAN AYE VOTE CHANGE.
FOR LOADING TO I FLORA NOT
VOTING TO ARRIVE.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU I'D.
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
NO RIGHT TO CHEAT.
MURATSUCHI I YEAH.
NINE TO ONE ITEM TWO AB FIFTY
SIX ADVERT A GARCIA MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT WELL AS FIVE
TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
HAVE SENT MEMBER FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
LIMóN.
Là M<c.cyan> NOT VOTING MCCARTY.</c>
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
MELENDEZ NO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE NO [inaudible] TWO SIX SIX
TWO ITEM.
THREE AB ONE TWENTY SIX BY
COOPER.
DO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
GOAL IS SIX ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE IN THE MOON.
LIMON I'M MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE
STONE.
STONE AYE [inaudible]
ELEVEN ZERO ITEMS
FIVE AB THREE FORTY FIVE
MURATSUCHI TWO PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURVE BALL IS FOUR TO
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NO CHILD.
CHAU I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING LIMON.
LIMON I MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S NO STONE [inaudible]
STONE I SEVEN THREE YEAH
[inaudible]
ITEM.
SIX AB FOR THIRTY GALLAGHER DO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BEAU IS.
SIX ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE.
STONE [inaudible]
SO NO [inaudible] NINE ONE ITEM
EIGHT AB SIX THIRTY NINE
CERVANTES TO PAST REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
KERBAL IS.
EIGHT TWO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
TROUT I MURATSUCHI RIGHT
MURATSUCHI I CHEN [inaudible]
ZERO OKAY.
ITEM NINE A. B. SIX SIXTY LEVINE
TO PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA I LIMóN.
LIMON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
WHEN DOES NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I NINE TO ONE ITEM TEN A.
B. SEVEN TWENTY NINE CHIU.
DO PAST REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
TWO TWO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU [inaudible]
ROUTE I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I SEVEN TWO ITEM
ELEVEN AB TEN SIXTY SEVEN
BIGELOW DO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE -- VOTE IS FIVE TWO
ZERO ABSENT MEMBER FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I CHAU.
CHAU AYE THE MOON.
THE MOON I MCCARTY.
THE I. MELINDA'S MELENDEZ AYE
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I ELEVEN
ZERO ITEM TWELVE AB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR BY FRIEDMAN.
MOTION IS TO PASS -- VOTE
TENDERS HEROWITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBER TRIAL.
JOE HI.
ELEVEN ZERO ITEM THIRTEEN A. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX EDUARDO GARCIA
DO PASSES OF MANDATORY FOR TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERR
VOTE IS NINE TO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
CHILD.
CHAU I WROTE TO CHEAT.
MURATSUCHI I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM
FOURTEEN AB ELEVEN SIXTY MEMBER
DOLLY. TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT GOAL IS TO TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE LIMóN [inaudible]
LIMON I MATHIS -- MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY [inaudible]
WORKING RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH HI.
MCCARTY I MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I
STONE.
JOHN I TEND.
ZERO ITEM FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE BONTA -- PAST THREE
FOR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU.
TROUT I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NOT VOTING MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I SEVEN ZERO ITEM
SIXTEEN AB ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN
SANTIAGO TO PASS REFER TO
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE -- VOTE
SEVEN ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I HAVE SOME MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE I STONE
[inaudible]
SO NO [inaudible] NINE ONE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO
GLORIA TO PASS AS AMENDED REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS [inaudible]
TO TO TO ABSENT MEMBERS.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I CHAU.
CHAU I LIMóN.
LIMON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I WROTE TO G..
RIGHT TO GI [inaudible] SEVEN
TWO ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B. TWELVE
THIRTY SIX BY MEMBER LACKEY. TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT -- IS EIGHT
TWO ZERO WITH THE TRIBE VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
TROUT I MURATSUCHI.
RECIPE I TEND.
ZERO ITEM NINETEEN A. B. TWELVE
SIXTY TWO O'DONNELL TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT -- IS.
SIX TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS CHILD
[inaudible]
I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI.
RIGHT TO GI STONE.
STONE I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM TWENTY
A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY LEVINE DO
PASSED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT GOAL IS.
THREE TO ONE ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMANHI FRIEDMAN I'VE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHILD.
CHILD I LIMóN
LIMON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S LINDA'S NO.
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I NINE THREE RIGHT
[inaudible] EIGHTY THREE THE
CATCH IN A LONG DAY.
ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B. FIFTEEN NO
NINE MULLIN.
DO PASS REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE THREE TOZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHILD
[inaudible]
I GARCIA.
I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I STONE.
STONE AYE [inaudible] EIGHT ZERO
I DON'T TWENTY THREE A. B.
FIFTEEN ELEVEN BY BLOOM TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT -- IS SIX TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE THE MOON.
LIMóN AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ
AYE STONE.
SO. NINE ELEVEN ZERO ITEM TWENTY
FIVE A. B. FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE
EGGMAN. TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA I'D CHAU.
TROUT I THE MOON.
LIMON AYE MELINDA'S LINDA'S EYES
STONE.
STONE I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM TWENTY
SIX A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY FOUR BY
LEVINE TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE THREE TO ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA I CHAU CHOW I LIMóN.
THE MOON I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN
DESIGN MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE I ELEVEN ZERO ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
BUY CARILLO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE.
FIVE TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHOW I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO
GI STONE.
STONE AYE.
ELEVEN ZERO ITEM TWENTY EIGHT A.
B. SIXTEEN SEVENTY THREE BY
SALAS. TO PASS REFER TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE
TWO TO ZERO I MEAN.
TO TO ONE ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN NO FRIEDMAN NOW.
CHAU [inaudible]
LIMóN.
Là M<c.cyan> NO [inaudible]</c>
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I YEAH.
MCCARTY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI.
RESURGENT NOT VOTING STONE
[inaudible]
STONE NO [inaudible] THREE FOUR
ITEM TWENTY NINE A. B. SIXTEEN
EIGHTY LEMOND. TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
TROUT I MATHIS AND I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI I NINE ZERO ITEM
THIRTY AB SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR
O'DONNELL. TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU.
CHAU I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
THE LAND IS NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE I NINE ZERO AND THEN ON
THE CONSENT. TO PASS THE PROBES
OCCUR VOTERS TEND TO ZERO WITH
THAT YOU'RE VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBER CHOW.
CHOW AYE [inaudible] ELEVEN ZERO
THAT'S IT AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WAS THREE TO FOUR IT
FAILED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
NOTICE RECONSIDERATION ON THAT
BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
BRENT RECONSIDERATION MANAGER
LIKE TO CHANGE THE VOTE ON AB
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN SANTIAGO
FROM I DID NOT GO.
ME FIND IT [inaudible] ELEVEN
ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN SO THE BILL
IS A TO ONE IS THERE A TO TO ON
OUR EIGHTY ONE ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN ROUTE TO TREAT CHANGING AS
SO THAT'LL BE.
EIGHT TO ONE OKAY. FIVE THAT I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
AND ALL THE STUFF FOR STAYING SO
LATE IN FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORKING WITH THAT THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED